foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun and look at
the intense focus on magnus's face what
a performance it has been
once again vikon Zay starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th Tata steel
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back the world's number one looks to
further cement his legacy in this event
and the game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
championed here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
have the winner of the tournament and it
is Jordan Fanfare winning the dramatic
Armageddon
don't leave out those poised to capture
their first Tata title
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom
Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps
the Dutch referred to Tata steel as The
Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steeped in Prestige and Legacy and does
so again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mine Brendan it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament and it
starts right now
it's another chest filled day in Vikings
day we see the participants heading into
the playing Hall not just the Masters in
the Challenger section but also many
different amateur players as well they
love it they play it this is a chess
tournament this is Tata steel chess 2023
it's the second round of action I'm
Grandmaster Robert Hess alongside me is
my good friend International Master
Tanya sachsev Tanya we had a very fun
day one two decisive games are you
looking forward to today's second round
of action I can't wait to see what the
chess players bring on the board today
Robert we had five draws two decisive
game seven Fighting Chess uh games we
saw yesterday and I think today is going
to be no different the visuals that we
saw from the playing Arena were so
heartwarming it just simply feels that
life is back to normal the last two
years of the why can't say due to covert
you could not have uh the amateur event
you could not have spectators and media
around but we can see a full Hall uh and
it does look like everyone loves chess
and white right now
they certainly do each and every year
they come to Vikings a for this annual
chess Festival the action is back and
well today is the second round of the
action will only heat up because after
two decisive results yesterday with the
black pieces though dearbeck Abdus
atarov and dingley rent took down
Richard report and tomorrow Raju gukes
respectively we have two co-leaders so
uh heading into this second round Tanya
I mean the leaders they should be
thrilled they get the white pieces uh
but what do you see as being the players
who are going to be the hungriest today
this is such a long tournament uh Robert
so it's still too early to say anything
but I am so happy to see that Ding
Lauren started with a win we haven't
seen him much in action over the last
again because of kovid and he's had
difficulties playing classical games in
fact his last event before being at
Reich was back in July in 22 the last
game that he played against Hikaru which
he won and after that he beat gokish
yesterday so we know that Chess World is
a better place wending is in shape and I
have to say yesterday's game was
absolutely scintillating it was not just
the result but the way he played start
to finish with the black pieces again
he's world number two but it's easy to
forget just how strong he is and what a
BC is because the guy is so humble and
modest all the time
yes no indeed I mean some of these
players are easy to root for uh we saw
some fascinating chests yesterday some
players were gonna be a bit disappointed
with their draws others like LaVon
aronian and para maxulu they should be
quite thrilled to hold that half point
but heading into a second round we have
some mouth-watering matchups ahead I
mean we have players who have played
zero times in classical chess we have
some who have you know an extended
history against one another but as we
start at the top
time that we have Wesley so with the
white piece against your Patriot
argenterry Garcia Arjun gets his second
black pieces in a row
Arjun starts with the black pieces again
but that's cool that doesn't matter
because Arjun we know is super well
prepared he's taking this event really
seriously Robert it is his first time
playing in an Invitational Elite event
of this sort and he's playing against
Wesley they played they have played
before in Rapid formats at the Tata
steel chess in India but never In
classical so this is a big game for
Arjun as every game is against these
very established players uh very excited
about this one Wesley probably slightly
disappointed that he could not make more
of his position against Jordan from
round one where he did have the extra
Pawn but failed to convert we also have
Lavon taking on pregnant another clash
of the ages yes that is and the Old
Guard versus the teenager and these two
have not faced off in classical chess
but they've played many times throughout
the Champions chess tour and other
online events and rapping and Blitz time
control so levonne aronian he is
familiar with the youngster and Fabiano
caruana will get to his game soon but he
and anise Geary have said that it's
great to get that experience in against
the younger players because when they're
new when you haven't played them for it
you don't know what to expect from them
but because Levon has played pagnanda
online that should bode well for the
better player
you know even these even though these
five youngsters this is the youngest
daughter steal ever and the strongest
and that goes on to say something Robert
uh we've got Prague we've got
arjunback and Vincent they might be all
on the 20 years of age but you still
can't call them new Talent you can't say
that they've got potential they've
already arrived they've already made
their Mark in the Chess World they've
been really shaking up the World Elite
the one thing that's important though to
note is that it's often been in faster
time controls so they're looking to have
that breakout Moment In classical chess
and I think for Prague this event means
a lot because we've seen what he's done
in the Champions chess store against the
best players in the world but to keep up
that form in classical chess
it's the big question and you said how
the younger players have thrived in the
quicker time patrols nobody wreck of do
sitarov you know he is the former World
rapid Champion but some players and in
of note Vincent kymer and gookash they
actually don't play too much rapid and
Blitz that sounds strange because
Vincent himself just got second place at
the world rapid Championship but they
don't play as much online as some of the
other youngsters like prognanda like
Arjun aragaisy like nihal sarin So
speaking of Vincent kymer he gets the
white pieces against the world champion
all three formats Magnus Carlson that's
a big task
a big task ahead of Winston with the
white pieces and a big game for us the
two have played before uh in online
formats at the tour as well so this is
going to be a fun one to watch Vincent
in his interview mentioned that he is
really looking forward to playing
against Magnus these youngsters they
always take it as an opportunity to play
against the best player in the world and
give it all that they've got with gokish
I completely agree with what you said
Robert that for him his Forte is
classical chess we saw him skip the
world rapid and Blitz so that he would
have time to prepare for this event he
did have a shaky start yesterday lost
against ding with the white pieces he
needs to find the Rhythm back and he's
up against Anish today
so many tough matchups for these players
and the field consists of 14 the 14
names you see there it is a 13 round
event 13 The Players received invites
whereas Arjun aragaisy qualified by
winning last year's Challengers
tournament the scoring is typical one
point for win half for draw and of
course the player with the most points
at the end of the event is the Tata
steel 2023 Champion so as we look in the
playing Hall there are 14 participants
all of whom are vying for that
Championship some have won this event
before Magnus Carlson is an eight-time
Champion levonne Ronan has won it four
times but dingley Ren clapping in the
foreground right there he has yet to win
in tata steel but he got off to a great
start Tanya he won game one yesterday
with the black pieces today he gets
white and I think that he might strike
again
he's definitely looking for a thing is
super motivated in this event it
potentially could be his only classical
event before the world championship
match he is playing against Parham at
least on paper ding is a favorite in
this match but no result is foregone and
you can't really predict anything
especially with a player like Parham who
has the capacity to beat anyone on any
given day if he gets his kind of
position we saw the players applauding
and clapping Tata steel is all about
tradition this event is all about
Heritage and tradition and one of them
is before the start of the round they
have a special guest a chief guest in
round one that was vision and former
world champion comes and inaugurates the
round and we see a little we see a
little bell there and you've got to hit
it to announce the start of the round
and that's what just happened so round
two about to lift off vision and
somebody who knows a thing or two about
winning championships of course he won
the World Championship and he lost his
title to Magnus Carlson but he also won
in Viking Zay on many different
occasions and we see the players making
their first moves there's nurture back
Abdul satara taking on Fabiano caruana
Fabi supporting that new haircut short
cropped hairstyle and Abdus atarov and
he's looking to get another win he
started off with a bang by beating
Richard's report yesterday and today he
gets the white pieces we see only a
couple moves have been played and Tanya
do you like drinking tea during your
games because I see that t next to
Fabiano over there so some players
they're always drinking tea others are
drinking nothing what's your style
uh but I definitely agree with you we've
also seen the world often have a bottle
of orange juice with him but it's
important because this is a classical
game it's super long and you need all
the energy you can get also it's really
cold in bike right now so the players
need to make sure that they end up for
the hot action on the board and the
opening Robert we've got a ragazen on
the board
we do indeed and I like that Red Bull
shout out hashtag sponsored over there
Tanya you gotta I know you have to say
that uh but we do have ever goes near
Bishop comes to B4 so in this setup we
just saw the pawn capture on D5 once
black captures back on D5 we take with
the e-pawn your Bishop on C8 has new
life right before staring into a pawn
kind of like the French defense now the
bishop has a fuller diagonal to work
with that's the good news and white
speeds up that Queen side development so
Tanya I really like this opening I feel
like it often provides a lot of fight
because just like the game between
gookesh and dingly run yesterday we do
not have a symmetrical Pawn structure
once the C Pawn took on D5 it was the
e-pawn that took back so black continues
with the c Pawn white has the E Pawn
that's a different dynamic
different Dynamic but that said the
ragozin is actually the wombative
openings that and not a back he's super
well prepared in fact yesterday in his
game against Richard rapper Richard came
out with an opening surprise of course
that's no surprise to anyone because
that is Richard's style of play but not
about even had ideas in those positions
uh in this opening as we can see Fabi
has chosen to move 8-6 the bishop falls
back to H4 and now this is a critical
moment Robert because here plaque does
have the option to make things
absolutely crazy get rid of the pin with
ideas like G5 you hit the bishop Force
the bishop to fall back to G3 and then
go on to put more pressure on the C3
pinned Knight with jumping with your
knight to E4 but that is super committal
as well and long theoretical lines Fabi
he's a master of openings and we saw
this yesterday you were predicting his
moves on point what do you think is
going to be his opening approach against
Northern back today
uh you kind of foreshadowed it well that
five minute carwana he's a very concrete
player when he knows his opening so the
move G5 is committal it's going to be
harder to Castle kingside even though
often in the rug goes and they still
Castle kingside but the point is you
strike in the center with C5 you play
moves like Knight to E4 trying to
exploit the pin as Tanya mentioned so it
is a very direct approach and you know
Fabiano he knows these types of openings
inside now but if you didn't expect the
right goes in for today's game then you
might not have studied the opening last
night or this morning and that may make
you feel a bit uncomfortable what does
nerdybeck want from Fabiano is no
dirbeck trying to uh play some kind of
tactical sequence where he has an engine
prepared novelty that's the scary thing
in an opening like this Tanya so whether
or not he plays G5 might depend on how
recently he's looked at the line
very good point and as it probably has
to be as recent as this morning now
apart from G5 the other way to continue
as I was going to mention is Castle or
strike in the center with C5 Fabi
sticking to his style chooses the more
flexible shock Castle first keeping the
option of striking in the center open
for an opportune moment
for sure so he just gets the king the
safety quickly does nordierbeck play E3
that Bishop can come out to D3 the queen
often goes out to C2 so there's a set of
standard moves by the players and it
really depends on what they're looking
for in this specific game but let's zoom
out for a second this one likely will
get a little bit spicier as the game
continues but we have six other matchups
and I see just the move E4 from dingly
Red there in the bottom left but as I
look from board to board well it looks
like we have double Abdus Atara of
carwana so we'll get that fixed
everybody uh on the top row but the
players they are just starting out
making their opening moves and the
bottom right Tanya it's this a long line
it seems like between Lavon aronian and
prognananda and look at that pawn
structure for black A6 B5 C6 D5 all
these pawns on light squares that should
be an interesting start
very interesting this is the open
Spanish as we call it and uh I think all
the games that we've got we're seeing a
couple of E4 setups we're seeing a
couple of Queen pawns opening so it's
gonna be quite a mixed bag of middle
game fights that we're gonna see today
uh I do like the idea of jumping to our
own immunity to mentioned it's a long
line it's a complicated position and
maybe we can take it from the top
okay let's Dive Right In just like that
Knight has decided to dive right into
the E4 Square so it's an interesting
opening in this one we're gonna pull up
the game between Lavon aronian and
pragna Nanda uh both players Drew in
round one and here in round two we saw
the start of the game as a Spanish and
A6 so none of this Berlin where I know
so many people have said ah just please
just anything but the Berlin so we don't
have it ragnunda plays A6 and we get
this variation Tanya where black takes
quickly on the E4 square and white
strikes in the center so white is a head
development black temporarily a pawn how
much experience do you have on the white
and black side of the royal Lopez I do
play it from the black side but not the
open I used to for a short period of
time got some good results but it's also
such an uh such an interesting opening
because even though it's an a kind of
position where an attack is possible but
it's also extremely strategic as we can
see as it develops with all these dark
squared weaknesses that happen for black
it's definitely a line that requires a
lot of prep you need to be up to date
with all the changing ideas uh and it's
really a matter of style the one thing
frog in this event Robert is there with
his trainer he is in waikansea along
with his sister as well who's playing in
the challengers but also with his
longtime trainer Mentor Ramesh who's
with him and
I know from experience with them that
they are heavy on prep uh they're
extremely serious about the opening part
it's something that a lot of time and
talking to when you're playing against a
player of Levon stature it's never easy
to be sure what you can expect out of it
uh so interesting to see how it's going
to be handled in this particular
position developed D4 was white has just
sacrificed the E4 pawn and the reason
that you've done that is because black
has wasted time the king is still in the
center you're dreaming of opening up
that e-file you want to get you on and
make the most of the pin along the
e-file so it is really what it all hangs
on the sacrifice of the E4
that's right in blackplayed B5 kicking
that Bishop back to B3 and then Pawn to
D5 so claiming space in the center and
after Knight takes E5 we saw a swap of
knights and then the move C6 so the pawn
on D5 needed Defender this Knight on e4
it looks very promising but at some
point it can be kicked out with the move
F3 and as we see in the game Bishop E7
Pawn C3 giving the bishop an escape
Avenue back to C2 or if the black king
castles it will stare towards H7 so in
the early going we have a trade of a
knight and a pawn per per side and it
seems like a very normal looking
position and well I'm getting worried
that a normal position I'm sorry to take
us away from your Tanya but we have a
normal position in one of the other
games and if we look in the top right
dingley Ren has put E4 and part mcsubu
has not moved but he is at the board so
that is very strange that he only just
decided to play a couple moves after
sitting in the chair you know he saw
dingley runs first move and then he just
decided to spend a bit of time so that's
a strange thing to see from a player
like Parham who usually plays at a
blistering pace
really fascinating because it's not as
though he was not on the board but the
one thing to remember here Robert is
that Barham is a last minute replacement
for yantry in the tournament now he's
mentioned that playing in wike has been
his dreams so there's no way that he
would refuse the invitation but the
drawback has been that he's had no time
to really prepare against these players
you often know who your opponents are
going to be months in advance so
parham's come to the event without much
preparation I think every game he knows
that a few minutes with so much time on
the clock forward to just get his
thoughts together of how he wants to
approach the opening it is the most
important part of the game to set the
tone for the rest of it uh every player
I think has a different style when they
arrive at board do they immediately make
a move in response to your opponent you
take a couple of minutes to slow down uh
you know look around get your things get
your pieces and things in order Robert
what about you when you go to play in
competitive chess do you immediately
make are you more of the let me just
take it slow and ease into things
well it depends on who I'm playing and
what the situation is and my answer to
this question will actually lead me to
explain why Parham did not move
instantly
um sometimes when I'm playing somebody
who I'm familiar with and I played a
number of times I'll sit and pretend to
think just I don't know get into the
Rhythm make them wonder what in the
world I'm doing and just as a bit of a
distraction tactic right because if you
make the moves instantly the player just
says all right it's a game of chess but
if they're sitting there thinking about
what I'm doing they're not being uh
singularly focused which is what you
need an objective game so now getting
into that what was Parham doing the red
played E4 let's go back to move one uh
dingley Ren E4 I said that but dingley
red often plays D4 so what is ding doing
in this game in the candidates he was
playing the English with one C4 he often
plays D4 in previous candidates and
throughout his history but today he
chose E4 so what Parham was doing is
like uh oh I clearly was not preparing
for the King's Pawn in this game what is
he expecting from me so if dingley Wren
is expecting me to play a sicilian as
Parham has done time and time again I
think about the Olympiad when I was
coaching Team USA five minute car want
to play the white side of a Sharp
Sicilian against Barham and won that
game so param goes you know I think he's
preparing for the Sassoon let's go for
E4 E5 and then we get into a Spanish now
as we see the position unfold here the
downside of playing the Spanish against
dingley Wren is he plays the Spanish
himself with the black pieces so just
because he doesn't typically play E4
does not mean he is not well versed in
the intricacies of this opening so Tanya
I think that is why Parham sat and
thought and I'd be genuinely thought on
move one because he was worried about
what dingly Wren had up his sleeve
against a Sicilian hmm dangler and
coming up with a Sami surprise on move
one with E4 of course now when you're
pointing upon opening you're not
completely shocked because it's
something that I think you know what you
want to do but an important moment and
what you pointed out Robert for Parham
to take a call that perhaps my opponent
has prepared better than I have in the
Sicilian so I'm gonna mix it up and
counter surprise with moving my own
King's Pawn and these are candles
variation in the Spanish here uh thing
immediately responded with the move A4
in this position so he has a threat he's
targeting the B Pawn because of the pin
along the a file if it was white smoke
white would simply stay capture because
the Rook on it hangs
so Parham needs to decide what you want
to do and one of the ways to continue in
this position is you either decide to
move the Rook aside or you play Bishop
to B7 developing your Bishop defending
the Rook on A8 what Parham goes for is
the move Rook B8 so he takes control of
the B5 Pawn defensive also sidesteps
from the pit
he does that from the pin but he also
sidesteps from a potential open file so
oftentimes the trade ab5 ab5 happens and
The Rook on A1 is extremely happy it's
developed in its starting Place whereas
The Rook on B8 is staring into its own
Pawn not the end of the world but a
slight Edge For The Rook on A1 compared
to its counterpart on the other side of
the board so it's a necessary decision a
bishop B7 can be played but there are
you know many details in a line with
Bishop to B7 where is the bishop really
well placed there because often you want
to move the d-pawn and develop on its
first diagonal so it is going to be an
interesting strategic battle between
these two uh when I think of strategic
players I do think of dingly Ren and I
often do not think of Parham maksudu he
prefers tactical positions he likes
sharp games and right now he is not
getting that in the slightest
while he is playing with the black
pieces so you know Arkansas is an
opening in fact which is considered
quite the dynamic one when you develop
your Bishop to C5 very often in Lopez
the Spanish opening blacks Bishop lands
up on the E7 square instead of C5 so
it's a more active approach
um sticking to his uh true nature and to
and true style going for this D6 played
opening up the other Bishop as well it's
pretty clear if you haven't put the
bishop on B7 in the previous move you
want to either put it on G4 or on E6 uh
countering White's Bishop on B3 so it's
going to be a fun one and the other
thing I noticed is that just like Fabi
Parham likes history
yeah he is uh enjoying himself a nice I
would say a mug of tea but it's not
quite a mug but either way he is going
to enjoy some nice hot Bevy but D4 is
the principled approach you're striking
in the center and just to show one thing
very quickly if white does indeed play
the move d4 hitting the bishop so many
players would be tempted to take on D4
with the pawn but that is not what you
want because after he takes D4 C takes
D4 we see a very strong Center here for
white with the two pawns and a vacated
C3 Square for the Knight to develop to
so what you instead do is bring your
Bishop back to B6 because while E5 can
be captured in the ensuing sequence
after d takes E5 that if we see a series
of Transit 95 95 takes and you swap
Queens it looks like F7 is hanging but
so is E4 so you need to calculate this
all the way through that white wins upon
but gives one right back and you'd
rather not give up E4 especially with
the bishop lined up against the F2 Pawn
so I just think that this opening prep
goes quite a bit deeper than the current
position and wanted to show that the
move d4 Bishop B6 has in fact been
played and that's the reason why that
black did not want to capture on D4
very nicely pointed out and as you were
mentioning ding Blitz had the move on to
A5 and now you hit the bishop but you
don't have enough defenses on that pawn
but the problem with taking on A5 is
that you're putting your pieces way too
much into the corner for example you
can't even start with if we just back up
uh instead of Bishop A7 Bishop A5 was
not even an option because white simply
goes D5 you remove the defender and you
win the piece on A5 Knight to A5 is also
a bad idea in this position because now
a white can actually just go on to pick
up the pawn on E5 and win a Central Pawn
by giving a Side Pawn and that's never a
trade that you want in the opening you
want to keep your central pawns alive
very very true so the A5 Pawn from
White's perspective was used as a decoy
and he was not distracted parm brings
the bishop back to A7 and then H3 played
by dingley Ren so this Pawn A5 it forced
the bishop back but it could be a
long-term weakness it's overextended so
if all of the major pieces get traded
then that pawn could be difficult to
defend without further pushing up some
of White's pawns but for the in the
meantime it is taking control of
important space you push back a bishop
uh the pawn is defended by The Rook over
here there's Central tension the G4
square is now covered and do not I
repeat do not play Knight takes E4 this
is actually a very important tactic for
people who play Spanish Knight takes
e-force almost always met by Bishop D5
it is a fork of two different Knights
the knights are clumsy pieces here
you're gonna drop one of them and you're
gonna lose the game so that is why
Parliament said decided to Castle
kingside get his King to safety keeping
the status quo in the center not
grabbing any pawns so this game will
further develop but for now I think
Parham he chose this opening I don't
think he really wanted it because he
wasn't expecting E4 in the first move
wow this is going to be a strategic
battle and it's going to be a long one
and I think both players are ready for
this a nice provocation there to block
the queen side forcing it not forking if
I fall back with your Bishop keep things
under control and then develop the game
on the king side or the center let's
take a look at the bird's eye view
because there's been so much opening
action Robert and many interesting
approaches here by the players
all right we have seven games underway
in the top left that's the game between
norderbeck Abdus atarov and five
undercarwana C5 hasn't played we'll see
if that g pawn moves in the bottom left
we have Vincent kymer and Magnus Carlson
very early stages there still
interesting to see Magnus play a type of
grunfeld with the black pieces uh next
to that second from the left Wesley so
against Argent Eric icy that is Central
tension the D5 Pawn is under attack by
so many different pieces and we'll see
if Wesley wants to pick that off uh
Lavon we started out on that game a bit
has changed but we'll get back to that
in a bit Anish Geary against goopcast a
little bit of a positional flare uh but
in the bottom right that's the game I
would like to go to Tanya is the game
between Jordan Von forest and Richard
report uh these two players are so
creative I think very combative they
don't like draws and unfortunately for
Richard that meant a loss in round one
and for Jordan he did draw that game
it's Wesley so where he was worse but
look at this position I mean this
starting to Petrov and now we see that
white is Castle The Rook on the open
file and a lot of tension at the D5 Pawn
having this unique creative style of
play is a double-edged sword because
what gets you stoned against world-class
players but they backfire because very
often the ideas are not object sound but
practically very appealing and difficult
to find as well so Richard rappo and
Jordan man first are definitely two
players whose USP has been a creative
style of play in fact Jordan was in
magnus's theme for the world
championship match and Magnus often
mentioned and acknowledged that in his
team Jordan was definitely the one
coming up with the most fun entertaining
and creative ideas and ideas uh that
they would sit and analyze but he's
playing against somebody who also has
that exact same style so this is not a
clash of styles but actually two players
who have a very similar approach to the
game they seem to be uh playing and be
more tempted to beautiful options even
then what would be objectively or maybe
sometimes practice quickly something you
want to go for so this is going to be an
exciting one and as we can see from the
opening itself it's not a position that
we see very often
no it's not this is already into a
relatively rare territory and just to
Echo what you were saying these are
players who are creative who often have
decisive games and you know in their
history they've only played each other
three times in classical chess but there
was only one draw in those three games
so uh Jordan Von Forest right now he
suffers a deficit in the headset match
Richard Port leads with two wins and
just that one draw and both of the wins
that report has had have been in tata
steel so Tyler that's especially
interesting to me because Jordan bed
forest was the 2021 champion in Todd of
Steel but also he's over performed in
every event he's played in he feels
right at home in vikon Zay he has shown
great opening preparation I remember his
gaming as Niels grendelius
um when he won the toddler Steel
Championship and two years ago so I just
feel like he's always coming with his
best in like and for Richard report
suffering a loss in game one now the
black side of this particular position
and look at him with his head in his
hands I'm a little bit concerned for him
because Jordan is ready to strike
it's amazing to see the alternative
ideas to do quit Jordan as you mentioned
is the 2021 thought of Steel uh Masters
champion and that was such a Monumental
moment you just cannot get out of our
heads the tiebreak match that happened
between Anish and Jordan which Jordan
event and went on to take the title with
this event it means so much to Jordan he
started it as a kid in the amateur
section he played the open Event first
and he mentioned that in fact at that
time more than being concentrated on his
own game his Focus would be to look at
the top players the world's Elite
playing the Masters and he aspired to
play against them one day and slowly and
suddenly of course he's been a prodigy
he won the event he won the amateurs he
went on to play all the different data
he played in the challenges and then
finally in the a group and managed to
win in 2021 and that championship just
means so much to Jordan because it's
been a childhood dream for him uh which
came true but after that wind Robert one
had the feeling that somewhere Jordan
didn't realize or at least the
performances were a bit we didn't see
him win too many other events I mean
Tata steel Masters winning that is such
a breakout performance but then it
seemed to slow down the chart he also
went on to help Magnus with the world
championship be a key part of his uh
world championship team in the Dubai
match against
uh and it's going to be interesting to
see how that experience has also shaped
Jordan he's looking for a big result
he's always inspired to play on this
stage and he's playing against himself
in such inventive and imaginative chess
it's going to be a fun one the position
that we have on the board is already fun
because take a look at this Robert White
has got a double Bishop Advantage not
just that you've got the Rook on E1
already on the open file Richard's King
is still in the center so he is behind
in development the center is ready to
explode putting pressure on D5 speaking
of an explosive Center Richard not
backing down picks up the pawn on D4 and
is taking the fight head on
he steals that pawn on D4 and just
something you said I wanted to mention
that you know if Jordan Von Forest to
spend his whole life wanting to watch
the master section games it's good that
he's in that section now because he can
just watch his own game and focus and
he's going to need to focus because he
gave up a pawn in the center it's all
part of his plan I believe the queen on
F3 slides back to the D1 square and at
home on D1 if we can analyze for a
second here the queen comes back where
it puts some pressure on the Knight on
D4 so if you think you're just gonna
Castle there could be a discovery with a
capture on H7 not to mention the tension
between C4 and D5 is an important part
of this position so let's say black
takes on C4 white can just simply take
back and you think all right I'm gonna
Castle I'm ahead by a full Pawn that's
the good news but look at this queen on
d8 it is overloaded it's protecting the
Knight on D4 it's also protecting the
bishop on E7 so Rook takes E7 is a
female
sacrifice but it's not really a
sacrifice because once you take here
pause Black is up material but the
Knight on D4 lost the Queen's defense
over here and after Queen takes D4 Queen
E1 is checked but not mate because the
bishop slides back to F1 and Tanya this
would be a way for Jordan van Forest to
steal some material so there are tactics
in this position already the black king
as you were highlighting is stuck in the
center and it's not going to be easy to
Castle if and when white plays the move
Queen to D1
you've got to love the nerves on Richard
I mean just to be able to play Knight D4
with your king stuck in the center it
just goes on to show how much at home he
feels in these absolutely crazy
positions uh you know you would just be
thinking about how to go Castle how to
make your position safe but Richard is
ready for a fight night into D4 you're
pointing out the queen Retreat as a way
to handle this position with white I
love this idea that you mentioned with
sacrificing The Rook but Robert what if
white gets even more aggressive one way
to go for it is Queen D1 but the other
thing that comes to my mind is I really
want to find a way to stop you from
castling and what if I go Queen H3 I'm
eyeing that it's seven Pawn now and it
still takes away your right to Castle
because let's say you think that wait
that's all right now I then take on D5
with my knight deflecting your Defender
from F6 you can't capture on D5 seven
will be a mate I'm gonna be super happy
with this yes it won't happen but as
long as you can on cookshot Castle your
king is in the center
that's exactly what I want why not Queen
H3 here Queen H3 is a viable option as
is Queen G3 because after Queen G3 if
you want to Castle they're all often
Bishop H6 ideas with a pin on the G7
Pawn threatening Checkmate and the
Knight is also a bit loose on D4 so that
could play uh tactically into White's
hands so in general the position is the
following black may even be able to
remain up a pawn but there are so many
tactics that you have to look out for so
for report we know he has a bit of a
tactical flare he likes exciting chess
but he got a little bit too exciting in
the first game it did not work out well
for him he lost a pawn and then a game
in that Rook ending down the stretch
against nodier Beck Abdus tarab here in
game two we're still in familiar
territory the players might even have
studied this line before because it's
not the first time this has happened in
fact there are several uh dozen games in
this exact variation where players play
between Queen G3 Queen Street and queen
to D1 so you have your options if you're
Jordan bun for us but you have a very
Tactical type of position and he has the
bishop pair so in open space the bishop
pair thrives we'll see if he can make
the most of it as Richard report left
his chair probably looking at some of
the other games so why don't we follow
Richard's lead and go back to the bird's
eye view see all seven games as they are
underway and Tanya
um well we have many exciting options
where do your eyes land
my eyes are currently landing on Levon
aronian on our screen we saw him it's
good to see him back with his colorful
shirts on so that's the that's the love
that we know and they were slightly
surprised with his black shirt very
unlike left so going to be interesting
to see if that also influences his style
of play today as you were mentioning a
fun game between Jordan and Richard
Fisher but there's fun everywhere Robert
Let's do an opening door what catches
your attention first
I love how you know I asked you you
asked me back but you mentioned Lavon
aronian and he has uh you know a great
Style Both in terms of his fashion sense
and his chess uh here he likes to play
all sorts of openings and it was a
Spanish we actually tuned out from this
game because param had yet to move so
let's go back to that moment where we
saw a swap of knights the pond came to
C6 white developed black did the same
and in the last few moves something has
changed because after Bishop C too their
Prague went with F7 to F5 now that's a
very committal move the F2 and F7 pawns
are known as the golden pawns they
defend the king but now it's defending
the Knight and also having aggressive
intentions if you can push the pawn to
F4 so ampasan remember that rule if a
pawn goes two squares and you could have
captured from one on this and only this
turn you could take on that's what Lavon
did and Tanya the position is opening up
black has completed the development and
white has finally decided to strike with
F4 so the eval bar off to the side says
maybe not maybe this wasn't the best
choice for Lavon maybe it's this bishop
on E3 that won't find the best diagonal
but what do you make of this I like this
kind of style from both the players
again you know we've been talking about
Richard and Jordan being imaginative
players and levons right up there with
them as well he is known for his
creativity and I think that's what he's
going for in this uh game as well F4
regardless of what the eval Bar says it
makes a mess out of the position and
then very often Robert playing against a
player like Prague your best chances
probably is to make a position that your
opponents not comfortable neither of the
players have any idea what the objective
evaluation is so I like this approach of
f4 it is a little committal of course
because you're weakening your king a bit
you know there are sacrifices on H3 in
the air the bishop on E3 is always a
little loose right now but what white
wants is a stronghold on the E5 Square
so the knight from D2 wants to jump into
F3 wants to move on to E5 or to D4
you're also eyeing the move F5 shutting
off that Bishop on E6 so that there are
no future sacrifices on age history and
this actually makes it clear to Prague
that it's a critical moment does he
allow white all these moves to put the
Knight on E5 to push the pawn on F5 or
should Prague right now go and put a
trade with the move Bishop elf is this
the moment is the truck needs to take a
decision and the hardest thing in chess
are these moments where you need to
decide
that's right because there are many
options here F5 is it a thread or is it
just a move because uh some of the king
side squares are already vulnerable and
if you push F4 to F5 I would like to
take over the dark squares and go after
your king So F4 was played with the
intention of grabbing space and F5
likely part of the plan but is that a
good plan that's the big question we
have the benefit of the eval bar saying
well maybe this is biting off more than
you could chew and this Rook can come to
E8 in black and play towards the center
uh but pragnanda he doesn't know that
it's a new position for him he is going
to decide what to do and while he's
doing that I think it's worth talking
about Levon aronian as a four-time
champion of this tournament I mean this
is the 85th it rendition of this event
it moved to Vikings in 1968 it's been
sponsored by toddler steel since 2011
and as we look at the list of notable
champions last but certainly not least
on this list is Lavon aronian with four
titles to his name so if there's a
player not named Magnus Carlson who has
that kind of championship history in
this sort of field it is Lavon
absolutely I mean the list is the who's
who of Chess you know if you have won
the Tata steel Masters it's one of those
achievements and Milestones in here
which every great player aspires to and
Lavon has had four ships now the player
he's playing today Prague he did play in
tata Steel in the last year this is his
second run at the Masters he is the
weakest player according to rating he's
the lowest seed but imagine an event
where Prague is the lowest seed that
just goes on to show the strength of the
tournament and you were mentioning
Marcus Carlson is the eight-time winner
Lavon aronian has won it four times
vishwanathan Anand is the other player
to have the highest number of wins in
the event at a staggering five
championships at the Tata steel Masters
he is currently in white himself as a
mentor uh and as an ambassador of the
game also you see these jackets Rob
covered that the Indian kids are wearing
Prague dukesh and the Arjun they've got
Vodka written which is actually Anand
stress Academy it stands for the West
Bridge on and chess Academy and all
these three prodigies are in fact from
Waka not just them as players in the
challenges from India where Charlie is a
vaka student so that's uh they're
repping them they've got their Mentor
it's so inspiring to have the world
champion and here we see Prague facing
off a giant of the Chess World and we
were talking about what is the idea of
f4 should Prague trade on F5 Prague
decided to go Bishop F5 took the call to
trade the bishop and look at what
levon's done he's gone all out in the
position makes the move G4 he doesn't
care how weakening the king is what's
going on on the king Levon is not
backing down he's going all out
wow you said inspired and then LeBron
played the move G4 so uh that is a huge
decision by Lavon aronian but he's
claiming that his King on G1 is not
going to fall victim to an attack black
just doesn't have pieces in the face of
White's King and this queen is allowed
to F3 this Rook can come over to E1 and
I honestly think that black could be
facing some problems if this Pawn gets
up to F5 just claim that space give me
the territory that I desire and I feel
like this could be an issue for Prague
so he played that Bishop F5 move that
you mentioned not at all a bad move but
now that the smoke has cleared a bit if
white input F5 and just to go back a
second here and there's a bishop on C2
that would be a bad piece but now that
the Bishops were traded on F5 once white
plays the move F5 there's no Bishop
behind it so if Queen to D7 and
eventually Pawn to F5 you're not
blocking in your own piece so I think
white can play Move like Queen F3 Rook a
to E1 things of this nature and white
has an extra Pawn on the king side we
have three pawns here compared to two
for black so that's the side that white
wants to play on and black has an extra
Pawn in the center the only player with
the d-pawn you would like to get your
Pawn going but it's not going to get
very far White's pieces are perfectly
situated to stop that progress and on
the other side maybe there's an F5 G5 F6
if you're not looking out and Black's
King could face some problems
laughs
but you know Robert in chess every move
has its own set of consequences yes
you've got G4 Naya Bishop on C2 is not
going to be blocked anymore once you go
F5 but as we were mentioning it also
looks extremely weakening towards the
white king and yes there's an option to
go Queen D7 but in fact the first move
that came to my mind was aggressively
here take advantage of what white has
done he's gone
g43 hit that Bishop on E3 try to make
the most of the weakness that white has
created on the king's side I think what
left has in mind for Queen D3 is not the
natural in F3 might be tempting to go
for the same ideas but then that allows
black to get the Rook onto the center
not a pleasant position but if we just
go Queen D3 here white has the move Rook
to F3 and suddenly your queen doesn't
have a good Square I'm threatening to go
Bishop C5 uh right now it's not possible
because Bishop C5 would be a check but
let's say Bishop C5 is an idea in the
air Bishop D4 is an idea F5 now would
actually end up trap Queen on the E3 so
watch out for that bearing approach G4
it does weaken the king but again if
it's a game where all three results are
possible once white has made the move G4
we see Lev he's not on his chair anymore
he's walking around we can see him on
our camera looks pretty relaxed uh
Prague on the other hand knows that it's
an important moment he needs to decide
because even here he can simply retreat
with the queen to G6 again targeting
these weaknesses that white has made I
would be surprised if Prague decides to
just Retreat to D7 it just feels way too
safe to go Queen D7 just letting white
do everything that you want what's
interesting and I just want to show this
is that after G4 Queen D3 the evil bar
is happy in terms of Black's Choice was
a good one but that's such a difficult
move to play because as you were just
highlighting after Rook F3 this queen is
in big trouble so if you're not careful
white will play F5 and then move the
bishop and the queen will be trapped so
I think that it depends on prognanda's
mindset if he is fearless and he has
been Fearless beating Magnus Carlson in
the Champions chess tour he will look at
Queen D3 objectively and find the
correct continuation after it because
maybe this Knight's gonna hop into E4 uh
you know there are opportunities for
black to free up his pieces uh but
probably not saying look at how quickly
Levon played G4 he is a maestro he is a
really great champion of this game I
should just move my queen back sometimes
making the quote-unquote safe choice is
actually the more dangerous option
because you're lacking in space white
has some easy ideas to play not that
Queen E7 is a bad move but sometimes we
get a little bit scared and that
actually helps our opponent uh more than
anything so it's going to be interesting
to see how progna handles this position
will let him figure it out we'll go back
to our bird's eye view because when
Magnus Carlson is playing in an event I
feel like we should take a look at his
game but before we do take a look at
that game in the bottom left Tanya I
mean so many interesting battles thus
far I look at the game next to that
Wesley so and Arjuna geisie on the
second Road there second from the left
the black king is still in the center
right it looks like black has barely
developed so that one will be
interesting as well
yeah that one looks like soon any game
where one side hasn't castled you know
it's going to be fireworks uh and I'm of
course happy to jump to that as well and
we see in that game you've got Queen
unseated Bishop on e4 already lined up
so very end game of course the Levon
board in the center is it's all eyes on
that right now on our screen I also see
Wesley having a little think and a
stopover on the Winston Magnus game so
he definitely found something of
interest in that one although from here
I can see that it's it's a slow game uh
it's still a slow start but Oneness is
Robert take a look at what has happened
in the Jordan Richard board I think we
should jump to that one
okay so whoa actually there's a night
Fork on C2 so you know we will get to
Magnus Carlson's game but I think you're
absolutely right that the Knight on C2
for Richard report is forking the white
Rooks but the eval bar is unfaged the
reason why is after your move Queen H3
so Props to you Tanya you uh might be
the Jordan bunt Forest Whisperer here uh
The Palms captured on C4 and now when
the bishop was distracted away from the
C2 Square in comes the Knight so I guess
the position is still in the balance
because Rook to D1 can be played
attacking this queen on d8 but that's
not the end of the story so you can take
on A1 I think this will not be very good
and the reason why is that this Knight
is likely to get trapped over here it
might not be able to get out very easily
so that is not what you want but instead
perhaps black can just slide the queen
over to C8 offering a queen trade
because the Rook on A1 is still hanging
so the engine Chloe doesn't hate White's
position Italian but it's an extra Pawn
for black and if the Queens could come
off the board I feel like then you're
not so disappointed if you're Richard
report
when I was talking about Queen H3 I have
to be honest the fact that even if
Falcon CD was possible will did not even
occur to me but thank God for the move
Rook D1 otherwise you just end up losing
material so that's a nice spot you take
advantage of uh the tempo that you have
with hitting the queen
I'm just wondering if Queen C8 this
position that you have in front of us
Robert offering the queen trade like you
said if the Queens get traded it's very
well possible that black just has an
extra pawn and it's a reasonably healthy
Pawn yes white still has compensation
because it isn't over and you know your
king is in the center no Harmony all of
that stuff but knowing Jordan I'm just
wondering if after Rook D1 Queen C8 he's
actually considering some crazy stuff
like Queen G3 Queen G7 as well and the
only reason I say that is because we all
know the style of the player who plays
with the white pieces right now
we certainly do this could get
interesting maybe the queen can
intercept on G4 but then it feels like
black is just moving the queen around a
bunch of times and with the King still
in the center there will be issues
especially if the pieces are not
harmonious so it's an interesting moment
we tuned in with a night Fork I think it
can be sidestepped with Rook to D1 we'll
see if Jordan does that uh but for now I
believe we are gonna head towards our
first break this is the second round of
the 85th edition of the Tata steel chess
tournament the action will continue
after the short break so do not go
anywhere we'll be right back
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is round two of the 2023 Tata steel
chess tournament you see the grand
Masters pacing around thinking about not
just their position but those of their
fellow competitors so it is all action
underway and yes Tata has the best
playing haul of any tourney this is the
second round of action I'm Grandmaster
Robert Hess alongside me is
international Master Tanya Tanya to this
point uh you know this action remains
relatively tame it might spice up at any
minute but with the time control being
so long right these players have the
time to sit and think because the game
is played in different time segments 100
minutes 40 moves 50 minutes for the next
20 all with a 30 second increment and
then finally last but certain not least
if they get to move 60 they get those
extra 15 minutes
Robert this is as classical as classical
chess gets the only other event which is
longer than this in time format are the
world championship and the candidates
that have got this kind of format
usually open events also have classical
time controls but way less time than
this so the players really have to come
in with a well thought out approach in
the opening but also make sure that they
navigate the middle game and the end
game really well very often in Rapid and
Blitz format you know one gets the
feeling let's just play this move we'll
see what happens you can't have that
approach In classical chess because if
you go for the moves that look fun but
are not the only person who's going to
be having fun is your opponent so it
requires anal accuracy it requires
absolute precision and finding the right
moves and this is what makes classical
chess beautiful
yes they have the time to consider all
possibilities well not all at some point
our brain stops working and we can't see
everything otherwise we'd be defeating
mittens in our games but as but as we
look across uh the seven games we have
here uh we have not looked at world
champion Magnus Carlson's game against
the young German Grandmaster Vincent
kymer so why don't we head directly into
that game uh where only 10 moves in so
it's not like the players are nearing
that time Patrol that we're mentioning
but they still have plenty of time on
their clocks we're just getting underway
not even hour into round two but a lot
has happened in this game Tanya we see a
position where white temporarily has
these double pawns so uh I think we
should start from the beginning but at
first glance even material but not the
same Pawn structure for each side
it's a really crucial game for both
Vincent and for Magnus Magnus uh
traditionally in this event often starts
really slow he doesn't seem to have the
greatest thoughts but then goes on to
pick to pick up some points and at least
while eight times has gone on to win the
championship on the other hand Winston
is making his debut here so it's a big
moment for him he had a great first
round where really he got a good
possession with the black against Barham
didn't manage to take a full point home
but has reasons to be pleased with the
way the tournament started now he's
against the world a huge matchup for him
and I see that it started with the croon
field but let's take it from the top
okay it was a grenfeld indeed Knight C3
D5 and instead of capturing on D5
allowing the Knight to capture back in a
series of Trades we saw that opening in
the match between prognananda and Arjun
yesterday instead we get Knight F3
Bishop G7 and Bishop G5 so try to remove
the guard of this Pawn on D5 so the
Knight hops into E4 and this is all
opening theory if you take this Knight
on e4 that would be a bad decision
because your opponent D4 would fall
that's just out of the question and if
you start taking the pawn on D5 you have
to look at your Bishop on G5 so the
bishop slides back to F4 the Knight
captures and we see a position unfold
where the next few moves seem very
logical Tanya uh where white has just
played Bishop E2 so if we take stock of
the position we have double pawns but
they're not bad because at any point you
can undouble your Pawn with C takes D5
what I like for Vincent is he has more
pawns towards the center when you have a
double Pawn like this it's away from the
queen side and closer to the center so
at any moment we can see a trade and the
next Pawn going to C4 once the white
king castle so I I do like the Contours
of this position for Vincent but Magnus
chose this opening for a reason we don't
see the group felt from him every day
no you don't and that just means that
Magnus wants to get into Muddy Waters
against Winston go into some kind of an
opening that he feels that perhaps
Winston wasn't expecting himself and we
know that grunfeld as a response to the
Queen's Pawn opening again is a very
Dynamic choice so Magnus wants to take
his chances in this game uh playing
against the Winston gamer and the
position as you pointed out Bishop E2
has been played very often this provokes
black to be the one to capture on C4 now
that white doesn't Bishop want you sort
of say you know what I win a Tempo you
move it once you've got to move but now
to take the pawn on C4 but it has its
own drawbacks because you open this A2
uh to G8 diagonal and very often you
have to watch out your tactics on that
so it's a really big moment for Magnus
here and that's why he's slowing down
because this will really decide the tone
for the middle game does he the pawn
structure is what determines the
positions in chess and how the games
progress allow Winston to capture on D5
and pick takes the center like that or
does that seems more flexible and
liquidated by capturing himself uh we
Magnus decide on that like you said
there is hot action across the board
let's get an overview of the games that
are going on and we'll come back to this
rabbit
for sure because one uh very interesting
thing has occurred in the middle of our
screen there if you look at the bottom
row middle game Queen D3 was in fact
played by prognanda so he is showing
that he is not afraid of Levon aronian
he is just going to find the moves that
he feels are best and that's a big
Choice by him allowing Rook F3 but it
might not be the end of the world so as
we do a tour of games we haven't even
looked at the game between Wesley so and
Arjun eregaissey we haven't looked at
Anish giri versus gukash so I personally
believe the game between Wesley and
Arjun looks a little bit uh more
tactical in nature so that's where my
attention is drawn so why don't we start
there and then go to the niche game
against gukesh so
um your compatriot Arjun erag I see he
had a good solid game one and now
against Wesley so who has won this event
before this looks like anything but a
solid that's just kind of up in the air
the thing with these youngsters is that
they know what the style of play of
these Elite established players really
what where they Thrive and the kind of
positions that they like and they share
their best to play something different
to create a mess on the board of course
that said players like Wesley are super
Universal you can't really say that they
have a particular person so a particular
weakness Arjun said a very interesting
thing in an interview uh at the Tata
steel at the Tata steel rapid and Blitz
in India
he saw that he believes that he's very
Universal and he doesn't have a
particular strength which also means
that he doesn't have a particular class
and I I think uh that's one of the
characteristics to be one of the best
players that you need to be able to play
any kind of position and sure we've gone
on to know Wesley as a player who enjoys
strategic battles where he is a great
player in pretty much any position the
thing that Wesley does is he's he waits
for instance the moment he gets an
opportunity when he gets an advantage
his technique is it's impossible to come
out of his crutches then but very often
he's not the first player to go get a
mess on the board thing that we see
right now is just full of fireworks
already Queen on 62 black hasn't castled
uh Robert do you want to take this from
the top just to see how we landed up in
this position to start with
uh for sure and but before we start from
the top I think we should mention that
these two have never faced each other in
classical chess so that is important to
note they have play each other online in
the rapid and Blitz formats and Wesley
being a former champion of the Masters
event and Arjun winning the challengers
last year it's an interesting storyline
is Wesley the favorite because he has
proven himself the highest level or is
the teenager our generic geiste who has
defeated all the top players in the
planet at this point in quicker time
patrols can he prove his strength in
classical as well he did gain 90 rating
points uh in the last year or from 2022
into 2023 and the year before it so uh
it you know Arjun he's showing that he
is a great player uh but
um Wesley so has been around for quite a
while so let's take it from the top uh
of this game you you know noted some
interesting characteristics of these
players Wesley so is a very calm
positional player often he could find
tactics with a percentage but he doesn't
want to have fireworks from the early
going but look at this I say that and
he's the one who plays a position that's
about to blow up in the center
someone who's had perhaps the most
spectacular rise seen in the Chess World
in recent times he was around 25 50 and
within a year and a half he was touching
2700 and that is often considered in the
Chess World as the most difficult rating
bracket to actually flee many points in
so in a very short period of time he had
this skyrocketing rise which took the
World by by storm and in fact his
breakout moment Robert was a writer
where he is playing against Wesley when
he was playing the Tata steel
challengers in 2021 he won that event
with a round Despair and booked his spot
for this year's Masters he faces as you
mentioned one of the most established
player of the Chester obviously so he's
pretty much done and this is going to be
a big fight it's going to be about who
we got positions that they like to play
more I think Arjun wants to try to
create a mess he doesn't want to go into
a strategic faculty so you were
mentioning this move d4 this opening
approach I don't think arjun's
disappointed with it I think he's also
going to get what he wants let's take a
look at how Arjun reacted after D4 in
the center because there's a lot of
things look at those four pawns facing
each other who's going to Blink first
who's going to capture which Pawn
it was Arjun decided to take on D4 now
the main move here is Pawn to E6 which
keeps all the pawns staring at one
another instead of his C takes D4 after
Knight takes E5 striking in the center
very quickly and the reason why people
don't play this very often is because
after this series of Trades and Bishop
G2 you do have a problem on the D5
Square If you ever push that pawn your
C6 Pawn is hanging behind it and white
can put Bishop G5 to remove the guard
and go after this D5 Pawn but Arjun
aragaisi he is as well prepared as
pretty much any player on the planet we
keep talking about his 30 plus moves of
preparation where he astonished
bishopath and Anand when Vichy was
talking to him about his game from the
India uh India wrap it in Blitz here he
goes Rook to ba he says please have this
Pawn I want you to take it because after
the capture is on the D5 Square white
does in fact win a pawn but after Knight
takes D5 the queen will take back on D5
because if you take with the bishop up
there's still this bishop B4 check move
and the issue for white if you play
Bishop D2 after the capture the B2 Pawn
will be loose so your King has to move
so the big question is it worth a pawn
in the center if your king can't Castle
Wesley says that's not my style I don't
want any part of that even if the engine
says equality please get me away from
this so instead in the game he says all
right I'll castle and now D4 is played
Wesley could have captured this Pawn on
C6 Tanya but it's a stylistic choice if
Bishop C6 Bishop D7 you have to take and
after Queen takes D7 it's not really a
position that Wesley wants this queen
will later come to H3 maybe H5 H for
Alpha zero style so Tanya I would like
the look of this for black
100 I mean imagine Queen H3 Knight G4 in
this position and you're already giving
Checkmate on H2 you definitely don't
want to capture this pawn and allow a
black to trade these Bishops and that is
a key idea for because black is able to
get rid of the lights quite this
position arjun's going to be super happy
with that so instead of the Knight E4
the night uh the knights got traded on
e4 94 Bishop E4 and now with jumping
into the attack from G4 as we were
pointing out in the other line black
goes on to defend the C6 pawn queen C7 a
developing move as well and I like
Wesley's next move we see both players
have burnt quite a bit of the clock in
these uh last well they've played 12
moves so there's been a lot of time
taken to come to this position it's sort
of a new position for both of them and
now the big question for Arjun is how
does he can't development because the
bishop on f8 still needs to find a good
spot very often one that's there is not
in the develop it on the f8 A3 diagonal
but instead of fan Shadow to it where
you also block White's Bishop on e4 you
go G6 you blanch the bishop on e4 you go
Bishop G7 you're already dreaming Robert
in a far away world to go shot Castle F5
expand your Center make sense of D5 uh
D4 and E5 already this is one way that
Arjun could be considering to finish his
development by fan tattooing going short
Castle expanding on the king side
yes now that is definitely a plan of
action but the problem is if you delay
your casting for too long maybe white
will be able to strike in the centers if
you play G6 it looks like a very natural
move I think that E3 also feels natural
let me take on D4 open up this e-file
and if you don't get castled soon you
may never castle and that's a big issue
for black so you want to move this
bishop but you'd really don't want to
move it to any one of these squares
that's not a useful diagonal and you
can't Castle very easily as you were
pointing out the bishop on e4 with that
Queen C2 staring at H7 so I like G6 uh
from the perspective that it blunts that
Bishop on e4 but I am worried about how
much time it takes to keep moving upon
and not developing your pieces but as
soon as I say that I'm thinking Alpha
zero Style again can I go full Alpha
zero can I play H5 H4 my king is under
attack just because in the center so I'm
wondering if you could throw the pawn to
H5 because that defends the pawn because
now I can Castle quickly without hanging
it and maybe I'm threatening to push it
forward
I mean you point out this idea a very
Alpha zeroesque and I love it already
and once again we see Arjun not looking
on the board he's looking out so this is
very classic Arjun uh very rarely
actually it is very special you know
where you don't seem to you don't appear
to be actually looking at the board but
all the variations the positions they're
running through your mind don't be
fooled by this complete focus on what is
actually happening and I think one
example of this that comes to mind
somebody who does this a lot is
evanchook I don't think I've seen him
play in Gibraltar and Vasa levancic is
one of those players I I feel you just
never looking on the board he'll be
looking everywhere else and then
suddenly he look and make a move
so all that while he's just been
thinking about what to play
is my favorite ever chest interview was
that you interviewing ivankuk in um
Gibraltar where he talks about his game
for like you know half an hour but every
single variation in the world that he
was calculating so uh you know vasil may
not be looking at the board but you know
he is calculating uh and right now these
two players are doing just that they're
looking they're calculating they're
trying to figure out their plans and for
Arjun this Pawn H7 that is his problem
he may in fact play G6 it's a perfectly
good move but he has to look out for a
moves like E3 just trying to open up the
position against the King still sitting
on E8 we'll let Arjun figure it out
let's go back to our view of all seven
boards because every single game is
still underway and as I look across the
screen here Tanya I'm looking in the
bottom right the Queens are off between
Jordan Von force and Richard report and
the eval bar is in Richard's favor he is
up a pawn that's very bad news for the
Dutch fans out there and I'm also
looking at the middle of that bottom row
there the queen is still on D3 for
prognananda and Lavon is just operating
around it he made the move Pawn to F5 so
the queen could be in some danger it
doesn't have any safe squares at the
moment uh but we might see some trades
as well so uh I don't even know where to
take us the game in the top left
abusatara and karwana also looks uh
pretty interesting to me with black
shadow Pawn structure so I'm just gonna
let you take your pick we haven't looked
at goo catch I said we would do that so
I am sorry I know I just gave you the
option but we didn't look at a niche yet
we could go
that was exactly his situation yesterday
against West and then he just kept
everything on and managed to save half
of finally with the white pieces this
position if he's not able to Define
enough initiative that's going to be
tricky for him but right now let's get
an update on the Anish gukesh Ford uh
kukesh is the youngest part of the
thought of sisters this year he's making
his
meanwhile I say the youngest woman he
follows 17 Robert and he's already
27 25 I think is his current live rating
and that is insane think about it
Seventeen how are you two
uh I wasn't so I can't answer that
question uh but you cash you know he's
had an absolutely blistering last year
he in the Olympian won a gold medal on
his board uh but you know something else
that's pretty amazing is anishagiri's
clock management I asked the team
because I couldn't believe it my eyes
are looking at more time than he started
with you start with a hundred minutes he
currently has 100 but nearly 103 minutes
on his clock which means he is within
his opening preparation that must be
scary for gukesh and that's the problem
with being young is that you don't have
experience and Anish is saying I'm gonna
get rukesh out of his comfort zone play
an opening that he has no experience in
and he's now has well more than doubled
the amount of time that is really a
surprising lead on the clock
is also the ambassador of the event he's
played it several times he's come close
to winning it ever has really won it so
uh we saw him in round one played a
fabulous game against Fabiano
um a little bit of an initiative some
great sacrifice in that one but didn't
manage to convert it and uh an exciting
game so I think Anish finally ambitious
in this one this play is I mean look
look at the prince kukesh is at 45
minutes even though Robert this line
radical it has been played before and
I'm just wondering what was the point
which made cookies slow down because if
we just quickly take it from the top the
live board
we see that it's an opening
quapular currently
it is
played quite frequently in fact in this
round we saw no deerback play it against
carwana and H6 played he'd take an F6 so
instead of C takes D5 first which is
what Abdul sitarov chose he takes place
Bishop G5 takes an F6 and as this game
continues here it's a position where
black has the bishop pair but white has
a lead in development look at this three
different minor pieces already developed
the Rook on the opening C file the white
king is castling as well so white has a
lead in development and Knight E4 is
played attacking this queen getting a
tempo
another Tempo gain A3 hitting the bishop
taking on D4 so not B4 to overextend but
taking on D4 and Rook C2 that was the
new idea that in previous games players
chose bunch of different options there's
Queen C2 there's Queen E2 there's Bishop
A2 uh there's you know ideas where you
play B4 as well but sit in each plays a
rook C2 and just by the look of it Tanya
when I see someone play this move I'm
like what are they actually doing what
is the aim are they gonna dump on the C
file and he showed us that he was
lifting his Rook to E2 because the Rook
could go to E1 but that's such an a
deceptive move
I think the aim is also primarily to
really just confuse your opponent with
this shift in the way you place your
pieces you know it's not the first way
that comes to mind to go Rook C2 rookie
two and as we see if we just go a little
ahead with the way the game developed
and looks to C2 in the end
uh The Rook from A1 finds itself on the
E file black has a queen as well on E7
so black always has to be like full of
tactics along that The Rook from Afghan
comes to D1 as well to defend the D4
Pawn as vikas's last move Bishop B6 uh
threatening for Pawn but even though
it's hard to believe that this little
dance around with the Rook to E2 it is
an idea that's super scary or anything I
don't think it's any anything like that
it has managed to confuse okay seem to
burn the clock a little bit trying to
understand the subtleties Anish is known
as one of the most well prepared chess
players of all time so when you're
playing against somebody like that who's
anyway blitzing out when he makes the
slight small different unique way of
continuing a game it makes you take a
pause kukesh needs to be careful Robert
because we remember from his game
against thing the clock really mattered
in the end he fell for a trick he had to
save a difficult position so he to make
sure he doesn't land up in the same spot
because the game is just starting up
Bishop B6 played he's hitting the pawn
on D4 I'm expecting to move Rook D1
would you be uh would you be worried
about Bishop D4 and ignore it or do you
think
I think Rook D1 is a very logical move
and the main question I have is how much
time will Anish giri spend on this turn
because if he has more time than he
started with if he's at his chair you
have to imagine and that it is accurate
he does have more time than he started
with that is crazy he's up nearly an
hour on the clock it's only 16 moves in
so the position isn't scary it's kind of
like what you were saying before Tanya
that's not like it's a tactical sequence
where good cash is going to get
checkmated or there's a sacrifice
nothing of that sort but the top players
they often win by causing their
opponents little problems because they
add up you can't just beat somebody by
having them blunder their Queen I know a
lot of you out there that happen to you
I'm so sorry uh but for good cash in a
niche they don't typically blunder that
kind of material so you have to just
cause these little problems get a lead
in the clock and if we remember
yesterday dingley Wren beat gukesh and
he was helped by his big lead on time
Google cash gotten time trouble and even
if the position could have been held
with optimal play you're not going to
find moves in a tricky position if you
just have minutes on your clock so Anish
is seated there he is thinking Tanya to
answer your question Rook D1 looks very
logical you could play that move pretty
quickly but because anisha's thinking it
leads me to believe he's out of his
preparation and perhaps that means that
the pawn on D4 isn't actually going to
be captured uh let's say I make some
just move like Rook to E1 can this Pawn
be captured that's the big question
because if that's not a threat then what
do you have to be scared about and the
eval bar is going very high I made a
random move Tanya so I'm gonna make
another move bear with me does this work
it does okay I'm help because the Evo
bar went up oh my God I said this
yesterday Robert you should be there and
not here right now I mean no no no no no
this is an insane idea so wait let me
just get my head around this you first
sacrifice a Pawn on D4 and then you're
just giving me a night
I'm giving you the night because I'm
gonna try to blast things open against
your King The King on jit does not have
pieces defending it and I didn't spider
so I made a random move asking if Bishop
takes D4 works and because the eval bar
went up very high I'm like oh there's
something here and it if we just go back
for a second to this position it doesn't
look like anything what Knight takes D4
Rook takes D4 that's not it so by
process of elimination I quickly figured
out there must be a tactical sequence
and with the threat of Checkmate on H7
you take the Knight and Rook takes E6
Pawn takes E6 Rook takes E6 your king is
just wide open there will be discovered
check mates if you move your queen
somewhere that is mate because double
check to this King the H7 squares under
White's control and if you have to give
up your queen in this way your king just
doesn't have pieces around it to help
out I believe that you can play Knight
takes D4 because Queen C5 check will
pick up the Rook if you take back and it
just game over this is a bombshell line
I mean this whole sequence you first
give up a pawn then you give up
and just all of it based on the fact
that blacks if you just go back to the
live position is in fact all the forces
are on the Queen's side and the thing is
I think what you pointed out that Anisha
slowed down Rook D1 just felt like such
a natural response to defend this but
the fact that he slowed down he's of
course looked at this position so he
knows that all these Dynamics and these
tricks do exist whether they exist in
this particular move order in this
particular position these ideas are
already in his head and Robert I think
you're on point with your judgment that
he realizes that that D4 Pawn can very
well not be on pre in these positions
with these tactical motives the most
important the key of the position is
that black is still underdeveloped with
that Knight unbeat The Rook on it
doesn't have a piece close to the king
is Anish giri realizing the importance
of that and will he play in this manner
putting these sacrifices out you know
what he did yesterday against Fabi
Robert I won't be surprised if we see
something similar rookie one I love it
if Bishop D4 doesn't work you won that
Rook on E1 and not on D1 you want one on
E6 you want to x-ray that Queen on E7 so
rookie one would be amazing if blackcon
would pick up the pawn on D4 yes and I
wonder if Anish uh is out of preparation
or if he's setting up a trap because if
you sort of act like I'm figuring this
out on my own but in reality you have
that engine prep up your sleeve that
could really be a problem for good cash
now max volume won a really nice game
yesterday and Max and Anish they're uh
compatriots they play on the Dutch team
together I believe they've worked
together as well he plays it kind of H4
Knight G5 stuff but H4 makes a little
bit too obvious and I didn't see Knight
G5 in advance I'm going to be fully
transparent I did not see that idea but
now that I know about the idea I'm
thinking oh can I just play H4 so I
could play Knight to G5 but it's way too
obvious there's no way that goocash will
take on D4 if Anish plays the move H4
because it's obvious that he's setting
up Knight G5 but Rook E1 which if Anish
has this prepped out and he's just
pretending like he doesn't he can make
this move rookie one and just try to
claim compensation but gukesh wasn't
born yesterday right he's not going to
play takes D4 unless he calculates it I
don't know what the engine is doing
because just before we show that it's
completely winning for white I think
that it will do it once again
um yeah it's just you know going back
and forth but uh you know it's clear
that this is a problem for black so good
cash is not going to be fooled but I
think a niche has a chance in this game
and well he's had many chances in tata
Steel's past Tanya he's a five-time
runner up so he is looking for his first
championship in this event uh will he be
able to get it that's the big question
for all the Dutch fans
wow and I he hasn't made a move yet
right uh Robert he's still having a
thing he's still having to think and
very Scott on camera while it was his
own move and the clock is running he
just got up put off his jacket came in
and sat down again took a sip of water
and continues to think and analyze the
position and we saw gukesh give him a
little bit of a look like wait a second
why are you getting up it's your move
this is a normal but it just goes on the
show that Anish feels something in this
position I like this part of a play
where he wants a good okay leave that
he's not familiar with this or is he
actually
thinking and he realizes that there are
some tricks in the position but that was
interesting to watch just like it sits
down again and calmly thing right now
he's not even looking at the board you
know when your opponent does stuff like
that as a player I know it has a
psychological effect on you
for sure I mean you look at what your
opponent is doing it can be distracting
and right now it looks like Anish is
sleeping and we don't want to wake up uh
you know Papa and Nish from his nap you
know having kids you don't often get to
sleep too much but Anish he's trying to
figure this out and we mentioned one of
the big story lines is Anish seeking
that first title in Viking Zay uh Magnus
Carlson looking for his ninth title and
to break the 2900 rating threshold even
though he said that that goal is put on
hold but there's no prize pool and I
always find that fascinating and maybe
tell me you have some thoughts on this
as well because when there's a big first
prize and then it shrinks after that uh
the players I mean they have no choice
but to fight for first off in or if they
can secure a certain prize they'd make a
quick draw and don't take the risk now
if you're paid up front and you're happy
with that payment I feel like then you
should be free to do whatever you want
like why wouldn't you try your hardest
and I think Viking Zay has a great
history of that we have the young
players playing against the older guard
and when the young players are there
they're not taking quick draws why in
the world would know dierberg Abdul
satara make a quick draw against Jordan
Von Forrest and why would gukesh want to
make a quick draw against the likes of
Levon aronian so these players are ready
to fight and I wonder if it's in part
because they received their appearance
fee up front and there are no prizes at
stake for each and every game
that's a really good point I think Robin
what makes the top of us is the why
can't they event so unique is that
it goes so much more beyond the prize
money it is this historical tradition it
is prestige it is Gloria at stake and
for these players who are fighting here
to win the event the opportunity to play
against each other the best players in
the world mixed up in a mix with the
biggest talents today
it's also just a love for chess that
comes together in this game and they
want to give it their best uh of course
there is the appearance-free factor and
like you mentioned that you know we
don't see quick Berlin draws in these
kind of uh uh in these kind of events
just simply because everyone wants to
give their best it is all about glory
and prestige in this tournament Magnus
he's won the tournament multiple times
he's been critical about classical time
formats he's clearly shown his
preference is towards faster formats yet
he comes back year after year to why
kanze to win it again uh prize money you
know thousands of dollars very often is
it's not even the biggest motivation for
a player like Magnus to return to
something that he's had eight
championships in but it is that with the
Tata steel Masters that keeps the
players motivated to give it their best
and to play games that are in nature not
just that what makes it super unique and
I think this is up to the organizer uh
you're on Vandenberg is the kind of feel
that he puts together you know you've
got these elite players you've got the
a-listers playing here but alongside
them you've got the biggest talents the
biggest prodigies who are looking this
new God uh who are looking to shake up
the World Elite the world champions of
the future and uh one more thing I think
which is so unique about the event is
that even during kovid the tradition
went on Tata steel Masters happen and
that is to say something Euro and
Vandenberg even without this we see our
tournament hall right now we see the
spectators they're all jam-packed
looking at the elite event right now but
even without them the tournament went on
so it really comes uh with so much more
than the money when it comes to Tata
steel Masters
uh well said Tonya and the players they
do give it their all and we see so many
chess players not just the grand Masters
playing on the stage but so many players
from many different backgrounds and ages
going to Vikings a each and every year
in fact uh one of the years that I was
commentating on site uh there was a man
in his 80s who told me he'd been coming
to Vikings since he was a child and he
really looks forward to the festival
every single year but uh Anish giri in
this particular game the Dutch fans they
root for him and for Jordan Von Forest
uh Anish now he's thinking and one last
note I'll make before we go away from
this game is if you're in gukesh's shoes
you actually might be even more nervous
than anisha's thinking because when he's
not thinking you know you're probably
playing the best move and so you're just
he's playing the engine line the top
choice but now that Anish is thinking
who cash might be wondering did I just
make a mistake because this bishop B6
move might not be in the top three that
the engine was spitting out so right now
a niche has a lot to figure out I don't
think he is that good of an actor and is
trying to trick Google cashier I believe
he is thinking he is calculating and
we'll leave him to it as we see part of
maksuda in the background we'll go to uh
bird's eye view look at all of our games
at once uh because
the game in the top right there's a
knight on G5 that can't move except to
take on F7 so why don't we actually look
at that one uh because the Knight on G5
is stuck there and that means that
dingley Ren's hand is forced
but I see your revalbar seems to say
that they're doing absolutely fine in
this position with H6 let's get a stock
of what's going on so as you pointed out
the Knight on G5 is in fact trapped I
don't think there's any confidence if
you allow H takes G5 even if you pick up
the G5 pawn it doesn't feel like it's
enough you were mentioning the idea of
giving up the two minor pieces this is
seven or at least starting with Knight
F7 and Rook F7 I'm just wondering why
does our valbar like the white like
White's position so much it's kind of
hard to understand here
that's the big question and if the
clocks are accurate and we've seen that
they have been that Parham is actually
ahead on time so zero pieces have been
traded I'm not a single Pawn not a
single minor piece everything is still
on the board where 16 moves in and H6
has trapped this Knight so ding the rent
sees that he's going to take on F7 he's
probably calculating do I throw in D
takes E5 then we can trade on A7
potentially a lot is happening there but
the end of the day Knight takes F7 will
likely be forced The Rook will take back
and the question then do I have to take
back immediately I don't think so
there's a pin here so there could be a
useful move you would love to pile up
pressure on the pin piece I don't see a
way to do that just yet but perhaps
sorry go ahead Tanya
no I I wasn't the same thing that do you
need to rush with Bishop maybe you can
start you've got this Intermezzo of
capturing on E5 Robert and we should
take so many things are hanging
currently on the board I'm attacking
your knight on F6 uh the first thing
that's very clear is that for example if
you pick up the pawn on E5 let's say you
go five simply recapture I can go Queen
d8
I can trade on d8 and once again after
Rook d8 your Knights overloaded it's
defending A7 it's defending E5 you take
on A7 97 and the idea that you were
mentioning you reinforce the attack on
the Rope that's pinned and the 95 looks
like this is going to be a lot of
trouble
let's just back up to our initial
position
and after Knight F7 Rook F7 D takes into
meso before you capture on F7 might not
be easy for black to respond to and I
see that Knight F7 is on the board so
ding has gone in for it while Parham now
needs to find a way he of course has to
capture back on F7 he does that and ding
immediately picks up that pawn the
Central Pawn on E5 the other thing that
strikes me is that if you can't take on
E5 maybe you pick up the bishop on E3
first let's say you go Bishop E3 but
hold on Robert again we don't need to
rush we don't need to recapture the
bishop on E3 because the Knight on F6 is
hanging as well and this is ding's idea
I don't think he wants to capture
anything he's going to go he takes F6
and the problems continue with paparham
the E3 Bishop hangs The Rook on F7 still
on the fire Queen D5 can be a big idea
at some point once the king comes on F7
so it looks super weak black is in
trouble here
oh my gosh the bishop probably has to
retreat to A7 and just because the
bishop you know is safe and sound
doesn't mean that black is safe with
sound because the king is going to be in
trouble you can even take on G7 and say
your king will never have full shelter
but there may be more in this position
than just starting to swap off material
so it looks scary the eval Bar says
black is fine and Parham I mean he looks
like he knows that and he is a great
calculator para maksulu is an amazing
tactician and because he plays so much
speed chess he's always playing in title
Tuesdays uh he was a Mainstay of the
junior speed Chess Championship he tries
to qualify for the main speeches
Championship he was in the rapid Chess
Championship he knows how to make moves
in shorter time patrols and so he still
has an hour and 16 minutes and if he can
make great moves without time on the
clock with over an hour there he is
going to be able to work his way through
what look like Muddy Waters so Parham he
is played in Vikings before not in the
masters section he played in The
Challenger section four years ago now it
was a plus performance 7 out of 13 but
he has grown as a chess player since
then so he's a much different person now
than he was when he was 18 playing in
bike and say Challengers
and we'll see for Parham you know how he
intends to handle what looks like
pressure against his King he moved his
Bishop back to A7 uh but yeah it's uh
going to be a messy affair right now
with the black king in some trouble but
black currently we just do a quick count
three minor pieces for black two for
white and it will be a bishop capturing
a rook and a king capturing back at some
moment and that means it's a rook for
two minor pieces with the black king
exposed
and I mean that's the that's the thing
right about this position it's just not
easy to figure it out especially with
the material imbalance and uh Parham he
is great I was just saying that but he
will need to give it his all right now
uh we do have some tech issues just to
be transparent with you so I'm gonna
steer us uh right now uh and I'm gonna
go dive in a little bit more into this
position as we fix those issues as uh
the king is pinned uh the bit Rook
excuse me is pinned to the king and one
idea that we can point out that Tanya
had mentioned earlier is an idea with
Queen D5 check because if that King is
venturing forward with King takes F6
that would be too much I think your king
is going to get checkmated uh with Queen
F5 check King only is E7 and then Pawn
to E5 looks like it just rips open this
King on E7 and Tanya I hear that you're
back thank you for saving me
I think so I hope so can you hear me
Robert well
I can hear you perfect okay awesome
music to my ears some internet
there so we were
we women I think this is getting
but it looks like the outcome is going
to be that Barham is going to be in huge
trouble right now so I see some moves
have been made he took on F6 the bishop
falls back on A7 and we see the eval bar
seems to like this tactical Skirmish for
um uh for white right now I have to say
about Parham though he's extremely
resourceful you know he's a tricky
player we saw his game against Winston
where again it looked like he was in so
much trouble and then he found this
tactic uh this tactical idea in the end
which managed to save the game for him
so ding needs to be super precise even
if the position is better for him right
now and it's not clear does he take on
F7 immediately does he first pick up the
pawn on G7 lots of uh lots of good
options here for ding in this position
yeah I was liking the idea of taking on
F7 and playing Queen D5 check but uh you
do typically want to keep the tension
alive and this pin isn't going anywhere
so there may not be a rush necessary to
capture on F7 uh but it's a really messy
position at dingley wren look at him on
screen here he's fully concentrated
we've seen dingley Wren have some great
highlights in the past year he was
second place in the candidates he beat
Hikaru in a really nice game in the
final round he beat youngest of Duda in
a nice end game as well uh but then he
had some you know lows he lost round one
to Yana palmchina candidates where he
just kind of looked out of place I think
that he had some jet lag he wasn't
really feeling the environment just yet
but that's dingley run he's 2800 only
player not named Magnus with that rating
but there are moments especially in
these tactical skirmishes where things
can go wrong from like they did against
Timor of a job of as well he lost like
25 moves with the white pieces
um but we can't speaking of the
candidates he did lose the first round
to Yan and then had a series of draws
there came a while to recover from that
but then also Robert he went on to fight
it out and finished second uh in the
candidates and thus qualifying as a
Challenger for the world championship
match uh also just seeing him start on a
high note in this tournament it does go
on to show that he is feeling his form
uh I was watching his interview
yesterday at the event and he mentioned
that he's not taking the Tata seal
Masters as a warm-up for the world
championship match he's going all in
here he wants to have a good event he's
not going to be experimental with his
openings trying to keep a vision of the
world championship match and is
important for Deng he wants to win the
whole thing he wants to give it his best
and once easy to forget just how strong
because of his modesty but this position
itself
if I had to predict the outcome of this
game right now I'm calling this a ding
game
okay wow so you believe in being the ren
you said he wants to win this event I
believe that to be the case and he wants
to keep increasing the rating he's at 28
around 15 after yesterday's win and if
he could reach 28-20 and new heights I
think all of China will be proud of him
and are rooting for him in the upcoming
World Chess Championship whenever that
actually happens but let's take a step
back from this game we will of course
look at it in more detail a bit later
but as we you know head on to break
shortly let's just you know take in take
stock of the positions it looks like in
the bottom left Magnus Carlson did in
fact take on C4 still early in that game
in the top left I see a king on E2 or no
dearbeck Abdul sitarov the Queens are
off the board Black's Pawn structure is
maybe the ugliest Pawn structure I've
ever seen with doubled bee pawns double
isolated f-pawns and I said H Pawn and I
said D I can't even look at that
position so we're just gonna go to break
I can't talk about the chest anymore
looking at that position we'll be right
back for more from the second round on
the top seal chess tournament 2023 do
not go anywhere
interested in becoming a chess streamer
like your favorite creators such as
Hikaru Gotham chess and the botan
sisters come on look at this
chess.com is excited to announce the
community streamer program
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
trust.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream
and your stream will be linked to your
games on our play server type command
Community streamer in chat and start
growing your stream today
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun and look at
the intense focus on magnus's face what
a performance it has been
once again vikon Zay starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th taught to steal
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back the world's number one looks to
further cement his legacy in this event
and the game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
the tournament and it is yours and fun
for race winning the dramatic Armageddon
don't leave out those poised to capture
their first Tata title
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom
Magnus one here as a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps
the Dutch refer to Tata steel as The
Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steep in Prestige and Legacy and does so
again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mine Brendan it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament and it
starts right now
and we are back from the venue in
Vikings day you see all of the
participants still playing their games
some Spectators watching the masters
section it's a great environment it is a
true chess festival and well people like
watching their favorite players and many
of the people that are participating in
the tournament right now will be playing
in the Pro chess League the wait is over
after a two-year Hiatus the protest
league is back the 2023 season begins
with a qualifier week starting February
1st with 16 teams advancing into the
main season pass protesting participants
include Magnus ding nepo Fabi Hikaru mvl
and Anish giri so we could not be more
excited for the League's return and with
over one hundred thousand dollars on the
line it's looking like the 2023 season
will be one for the history books use
the command PCL and chat to learn all
about it Tanya protesting will be
exciting but this second round already
is exciting and when we left I couldn't
keep my eyes on that game in the top
left I mean it is just a really ugly
Pawn structure for Fabiano caruana the
evaluation bar doesn't seem to hate the
position as much as I do but I can I
really can't look at that pawn structure
very much and we will have to dive into
that position at some point but which of
these games catches your eye the most
you were talking about the pawn
structure and I was thinking about it I
want to just say a little bit about it
Robert because yes it's very surprising
that why is it that black has got well
how many Pawn islands is that that's one
two three four and that just goes on to
show how much of a weakness it is but
our eval bar seems to say Black's doing
just fine and I want to make a little
sense of that really quickly the problem
here for why it is that sure black spawn
structure is bad but just imagine if
black captures that Knight on C3 after
that white spawn structure also breaks
down you can double up on the a file the
A2 Pawn will be hanging and I think Fabi
has his own trumps so I know the
position looks absolutely ugly right now
for black but I think the problem is
that white also needs to be careful
about his own weaknesses I'm expecting
Fabi to go for a trade in that one but
you're absolutely right that isn't the
most fiery position on the board
currently it's got to be the Magnus one
that we have to get an update on I mean
take a look at that C4 was traded off
right now the bishop and C4 is hanging
B5 has been played Magnus is taking a
thing lots of pieces lots of Pawn
currently let's bring that up on our
board let's get the world champion and
Winston gamer on our screen and get an
update on this one
and I'm just gonna say something very
quickly that Anisha did play Rook F1 to
E1 after a sizable thing so either he is
a much better actor than I gave him
credit for or he found it on his own but
we are going to focus in on this game
for the moment uh the pawn on C4 was
captured and then black decided to
strike with B5 going right after this
bishop here on C4 so the bishop in all
likelihood will Retreat to E2 and the
reason why E2 looks better to me is
let's go to D3 I'm already looking at
some kind of C5 trying to make C4 happen
you're in forking territory whereas
Bishop E2 is just a little bit farther
away from the pieces and I think that it
gives white a few more options so I do
expect the bishop to retreat but then
Tanya the question is the E7 Pawn is
black gonna strike with E5 at some point
you have to defend the pawn uh what's
going on with this Pawn structure is it
weak is it strong will white Adventure
be able to play Move Like A4 or C4
what's the king castles so they're big
and structural questions at play here
and Magnus started to strike with B5 and
if Vincent hasn't responded yet he's
trying to figure out the best place for
his Bishop
I have to say that B5 is super
commercial you've made C6 a weakness for
quite a while I mean unless you're able
to break the center with a move like C5
which will be pretty hard to achieve
considering the B5 Pawn will be a
weakness I know aravalbar says that
black swing fine but I kind of feel like
white should be happier with the opening
outcome it just feels like a more
flexible Pawn structure black has got
more problems to solve here I think
Winston is pleased with the position he
has whether he goes Bishop D3 or E2 I do
like the E2 square a little more uh
Robert and that's only because I feel
that the bishop on E2 just feels a bit
more compact you know far away future
you're imagining things like Bishop on
B7 maybe C5 you want to keep the Knight
on F3 defended in those kind of
circumstances it just feels like you
want the Rook on T1 to be on an open
file keeping all these things in mind I
like the move Bishop E2 quite a bit here
I think it would be a move that at least
when it comes to Blitz you would make it
instantly when you've got a little more
time for subtleties here we'll leave it
to Vincent to come up with an idea but
again excitement across boards uh let's
get an overview because even The Tingler
and far humble let's see let's get our
bird's eye view on the top right we see
the line that has been played uh it's an
exciting middle game not just that one
the Wesley so the bottom left the second
board that we have it's just so much
action going on with the f-file open as
well
wow yeah that game is very interesting
uh the game in the middle between Lavon
and Rooney and prognanda it looks like
the Queens are off the board many pieces
have been traded uh so we are in an end
game in that one and on the bottom right
Jordan Von 4S is still down upon but has
the bishop pair that does prove
compensation and it looks like he might
get a bishop of opposite color ending
where he's down a pawn if that sounds
familiar to you it's because that was
the storyline yesterday and if Jordan is
able to survive and draw and get one out
of two that's a good result on paper two
draws it's high rated players but his
play has been very shaky he's been worse
throughout both games and he is not
playing his best chess and how do we
know that he won this very event in 2021
so uh Tanya I still have my eyes on the
Anish giri position he played Rook F1 to
E1 I wonder if he's setting go cash up
or if he just found it on his own but
either way
Oh I thought the guess was about to move
like he looks like he's staring at the
D4 Pawn right now and I'm worried for
him
I just don't pick up that default on I
mean let's uh get that board up rookie
one was the line that you accidentally
just mentioned to check whether D4 was
hanging or not and we saw this crazy
tactical idea Robert that you spotted uh
let's show that again to everyone
because rookie won for a second it feels
like D4 is hanging but actually dukesh
cannot make the big mistake of picking
it up because the sacrifices don't stop
no no no we showed this earlier we'll
show it again we were asking the
question of what happens if Bishop takes
D4 and The Rook was an F1 so I just made
a random useful looking move and it
turns out that if Bishop takes D4 is
played uh gukesh has to be you know very
careful not to make this move because
Knight E4 to G5 giving up a knight
you're threatening Checkmate so the
Knight should be captured but once the
Knight is captured Rook takes E6 is
slammed on the board and this King on G8
is in trouble now there may be better
ways to Stave off the attack and survive
but if you take a rook the next Rook
takes there's a problem with this King
on Jade I showed this before I'll show
it again if the queen moves somewhere
this is not just double check it is
double check and check mate because the
queen takes away the Escape Square while
the king can't go to F7 because the
bishop is checking on the diagonal and
if you take this rook and try to get out
of danger this way if your king goes to
the H file you're gonna get checkmated
anyway every King goes to f8 then Knight
takes D4 is simple and strong Rook takes
D4 is met by Queen C5 check thank you
for the Rook now white is up a ton of
material and going to Checkmate this
black king so good cash is in big
trouble it looks like he made a move
and it was King AJ he did not take it on
D4 yes but I saw the eval bar shoot
right up even after he played King h8
when he was
with the move Robert I was just
wondering don't take on defogesh super
dangerous but he just psyched
what's wrong with it and first thing
that
still make the move threatening on eight
seven going for Knight G5 sacrificing on
E6 or has that lost its poison because
if not that then what's wrong with King
h8
Knight E to G5 is the move again that is
unbelievable we have to show it night oh
my gosh that's it the Eva bar did not
change that is the correct move and if
Pawn takes G5 it looks like the attack
rages on like we're looking before Rook
takes E6 Pawn takes E6 Rook takes it
even though the king is not G8 you
thought you were getting out of danger
the points of this queen moves somewhere
like Queen of D7 Knight takes G5 happens
and I am going to Checkmate you your
king just doesn't have Defenders and
many in fact all of White's remaining
pieces are going for the attack uh if G6
I will just grab this Pawn I'm going to
Major King in the next couple moves so
that means after Rook takes E6 you may
have to sack your queen and even though
this isn't check which is very important
because that doesn't give you the
follow-up Knight takes G5 black takes an
F3 white takes back on F3 the problem is
this king is in checkmate's zone Bishop
covers G8 which means the queen is about
to run over to the H file this looks
like a very bad situation he tried to
avoid this Rook takes Knight G5 Rook 66
but it looked like he walked right into
it anyway
this is Andrea will Anish giri find this
idea of Knight G5 I think the answer to
that is going to be a resounding yes
because he took his time to make the
move rookie one so clearly having these
motives in his mind already again it
just comes down to that Queen side that
underdeveloped Queen side with the night
still on B8 Rook on it and this is what
allows all these ideas on the board this
is a big moment uh I look at a niche I
think he feels it he sees it he took
about 30 minutes to make the move rookie
one he knows these motives exist Robert
predict at this moment that Anish will
go all out with the move Knight G5 yes
it's clear that he saw the idea when he
played Rook F1 to E1 giving up the D4
Pawn uh and he doesn't have to play
Knight G5 I think his position is better
if he makes a move H4 he's not hiding
his intentions the move H4 says I will
play Knight G5 next if you allow me to
because now the square is extra well
defended it may Force Bishop takes E4 to
get rid of the attack but it will
continue The Rook will come up to E4 and
I feel like there's a lot of pressure
against the black king along the E file
and so H4 would still leave white with
an advantage but a niche should be able
to find Knight to G5 that was his plan
after all I mean once you spot this idea
of Knight G5 H4 just feels way too
docile I mean I've give black the option
to grab that Knight on e4 and gkesh will
do it with both hands because H4 would
make it so clear what white wants I want
to see Knight G5 on the board as a chess
fan as a commentator uh I think Knight
G5 is the kind of stuff that we want
right now that said is there a way for
black to fight because the positions
that we were looking at after the line
just looked like they were clearly worse
for black so what happens after Knight
G5 is that something better that black
can do all right we can bring up the
analysis board and you know just look at
it a little bit as we have the live
position on screen uh rookie six maybe
there's some way down this variation
where it's not
completely hopelessly lost but it's
still bad so uh the bishop is too strong
we might have to eliminate it so Rook E8
comes to mind if you play Queen G6 then
I'm gonna sack on E6 and if you take I
get to develop but I feel like black has
just too many pieces against the queen
there's an immediate draw with uh draw
by Perpetual check and repetition and
that means that if you have it minimum a
draw if you're a niche that entices you
to make the sacrifice you know that the
worst that happens is you get a half
Point here but I think after rookie
eight I would put the move D5 if you're
gonna take my piece on E6 I'm going to
get a pawn here and if you go Rook E6 I
might even have Queen C8 check
Intermezzo and the good thing about this
is I pin your knight it's an eternal pin
and I'm gonna take back and maybe get a
new Queen so the attack just doesn't
stop Tanya that's the big problem here
is black can make a move like Knight A6
hoping that next move is Rook takes E6
but I don't believe that Rook takes 6 is
you know going to really equalize when
this Pawn gets to E7 and at minimum I
keep saying it's a minimum white has
this draw so if a niche sees this far
there's no reason why he should not go
for this line because he can't possibly
lose
yeah that bone on E6 would be absolutely
frightful Anish is taking his time we
see uh the clock says well kokesh has
got about 30 minutes Anish with an hour
and 11 minutes he blitzed out the
opening
managed to get exactly what he wanted
this is our live board King h8 played at
first it looks like gokish had
sidestepped all the troubles in the
position but in analysis and our eval
bar we can see that he might have just
walked into what he was trying to get
out of
I if Anish plays Knight to G5 uh that
would be an absolute tragedy for gukesh
he lost the first game with the white
pieces it looks like he could you know
get blood off the board in game two here
he doesn't have that much time he's just
under 33 minutes and they've only played
17 moves so 23 moves to make in 33
minutes but that position we've been
talking about you'll make the next five
or so moves quickly after take on G5
that's one move take on E6 that's two uh
Queen takes E6 Bishop takes F3 those
moves uh bukash will spot but then after
that it's not easy at all because your
king is in danger there's gonna be a
past pawn and the material imbalance
whenever there's a material imbalance
the positions are not easy to calculate
so um Anish has great chances here he
does not want to spoil them we saw a few
players lose their advantages yesterday
in disappointing ways Anish will be
disappointed if he plays Knight G5 and
doesn't win this game sorry I thought I
saw him raise his hand and I was waiting
for that move but uh no move yet
I think the important thing for Anish is
going to be whether he is able to
evaluate the final position of the line
that we just showed as better for him
that's often the big challenge is
evaluating the end of the line it's a
complicated long line where you end up
sacrificing a lot of material for the
for the queen and
I get the feeling often with Anish uh
Robert he is one of the best players in
the world he's super strong super
accurate but the thing which I often
find is that he underestimates his
position sometimes a lot
um I say sometimes a lot which is great
but he does tend to underestimate his uh
his position and if that's the case if
that's what happens now then he will
probably decide to go for this
alternative that you're mentioning with
H4 which also is very tempting because
you just simply feel that you know what
I have a pleasant position it's a
long-term Advantage but that's the thing
at this level if you don't finish and
wrap up when you've got this chance to
go Knight G5 slowly the margin of
Advantage keeps disappearing and I
really hope that Anish is able to
evaluate that perfectly and then make
the spectacular move because he's done
everything right up till this point I
think that was a great way to frame it
right the you may still have the
advantage but it might become Slimmer
it's not as forceful that margin is
getting smaller so uh Knight G5 just
looks very strong and If This Were A
Blitz game I think he would play H4
instantly right you might not see Knight
G5 you play H4 it's just a good
improving move setting up Knight G5 and
if black is ever to take on e4 there may
be D4 to D5 to follow because you want
to open up the e-file for your Rook so
the plans are actually quite clear for
white even if you don't Checkmate the
black king H4 is a very useful move so I
think we'd understand the move if he
doesn't see that clear advantage that
you're talking about if he thinks that
Knight G5 leads to maybe at best a draw
for him or if he's not careful and
continues to play he might lose then
it'll take the safer route and Anish
Geary is one of the best chess players
in the world like you said but sometimes
I don't think he trusts his calculation
like other players do
um it's not that he can't see in a very
far it's assessing what happens after
you see that position in your head and
the lines that we've been looking at are
not that clear so to be fair to him if
he doesn't play it it's because the line
doesn't exactly show that it's an easy
win or anything like that and it's not
an easy win but if he feels like you
know it's too much to ask for right now
let's just make the move H4 and what is
good cash going to do the next moves for
black are not easy
I feel like I keep staring at the board
because I think he's reaching about to
make his move with all these Shadows
falling on the board in his surgical
moment uh and absolutely it's not just
about finding Knight G5 but calculating
sacrificing The Rook after that as well
with Rook E6 the thing is if you play
Knight G5 you have to give up The Rook
next and then you have to go on to
evaluate the line it's not that you sack
sack and then there's a checkmate at the
end you just have to feel that you're
better in that position and that's hard
that's a hard evaluation to make uh
you're playing against so many pieces
for a queen uh Robert we're gonna come
back and see what eventually Anish
decides does he go for a slightly safer
approach
a huge chance a critical moment to
actually get a big Advantage with Knight
G5 does he go for H4 or will he find the
killer blow here uh will he be able to
play this move Knight G5 calculate it
till the end you know what yesterday he
sacrificed the piece against Fabi I'm
gonna again say it he's going to do it
again against against
we're going to see 95 on the board but
we'll wait for a niche uh and see if he
does go for that let's get an overview
and there we see we see him on the board
that was a nice shot of him
calculating his head on his hands
currently often that's a pose when
you're in trouble but it's not about
trouble in this position Anish is just
deep in thought it's that moment where
you need critical decision turn out to
be a difference between a win
and a losing of a half a point
and he's definitely calculating 15 moves
down the line and that's why it's so
much to take in for him and we see Arjun
Eric icy walking uh on screen behind a
niche and passed him at the moment and
Arjun he's second from the left his game
against Wesley so uh that hasn't changed
all that much but the game that is
petering out is the one in the middle on
the bottom row Lavon aronian with the
white pieces against pragananda it's a
rook and four pawns against rook and
four pawns so we're not gonna stay in
the game long but I do think we should
pull it up because I believe the game
will conclude shortly the 30 moves in at
this point and I believe that the draw
is near and the reason why despite
Black's bad Pawn structure that this
position should likely be a draw is that
Rook C5 for white goes Pawn hunting
let's attack both pawns at the same time
but black has used moves like Pawn to B4
if you take on D5 well a rook will help
out and we just start trading all the
pawns off if you take on B4 I can make a
move like Rook to B3 where I hit both of
your pawns as well Rook takes D5 Rook
takes B4 hitting B2 hitting G4 so all
these pawns are about to come off the
board and what white ideally wants is
something like this where you give up
the G4 pawn and get your Rook behind
your pass Pawn because these are double
pawns double pawns are not ideal in the
end game the problem is getting roof
behind the b-pawn is slow this Rook can
come to F4 to go out for the pawn the
king can also go up so uh The Rook can
help with the B Pawn the king takes care
of the F Pawn there is not going to be a
winning chance for white so I think that
Lavon understands this he might just
make the next bunch of moves to play out
the position of Rook C5 is on the board
but if B4 is played they're probably on
a definitely will hold this draw
so he just needs that last bit of
accuracy with the move before but
knowing Prague I think he's super good
his ideas would just liquidate
game immediately
these youngsters Robert is that they're
so precise in their calculation and so
Concrete in their approach they don't
really play a feel of a position
concrete ideas which is why very often
we see the lines which make no sense at
all but simply because they've
calculated it and B4 is one such move
you sacrifice a pawn but you just
calculate a couple of moves ahead it's
the fastest way maybe there are other
moves as well in the position but it
just feels like the simplest way a
liquid to liquidation and and in a draw
we see a lot we saw Prague not be on his
board earlier uh I know Prague a little
bit and I'm pretty sure when he's not on
his board he's watching over his
sister's game in the challenge where
Charlie is playing that she's raw and
and start a very interesting game as
well a very aggressive player as well so
it's kind of nice when you've got a
brother sister Duo playing in why can't
say yeah it's great to see that family
Thrive and uh come to Vikings a and you
know they get to play and everyone gets
to see these talented uh Duo uh take
part in the Masters and the challengers
but probably don't have played before I
think we should head back to the bird's
eye view just because I'm very confident
that you'll hold this draw uh we can
update everybody when that draws reach
but I'm looking across the positions you
mentioned in the top left five minute
karwana did just take that night on C3
so Abu star of will take back and when
he gets back to the board and then we'll
get an end game with a terrible Pawn
structure for black uh but black can
also go after some Targets in the top
right we were looking at dingley Ren and
para maxudlu it's still
crazy position with chances for both
players dingley Wren not seeming very
happy I actually like parham's chances I
just believe I know I'm interrupting you
but you don't have to see what just
happened on the Anish board oh my God
he's gone for it he has indeed let's go
right there we've been talking about it
now we don't have to predict it anymore
it has been played Knight E to G5 was a
mysterious Choice H takes G5 Rook E6 F
takes E6 and I don't think Anish will be
sitting and thinking for long because
Rook takes E6 is the only move white is
currently down a rook and a bishop for
one Pawn so that's so much material but
he's going after this black king the key
to the king's defense is this queen on
E7 if the queen had to move even if
black had the free turn Queen D7 would
be up by Knight takes G5 and the king
would fall victim to a checkmating
attack so Anish will play Rook takes E6
here he doesn't have a choice I believe
he's still calculating Tanya like eight
moves from now that's why he's pausing
not because of this move he's still just
in his head the wheels are turning and
he's calculating variations in the
distance
this is inspired played by
and you're absolutely
is uh
evaluating the different positions he's
with the hottest spot the sacrifices
because it reminds me of this game
between chakriar and Anita Anish was in
the receiving end a multiple sacrifices
where basically chakra sacrificed the
house and simply went on to meet
anisha's King and that's a similar
motive but this time it is a nation
driving seat he's given up as you
pointed out an entire night and a whole
Rook for a couple of Pawns but it's not
about that nobody cares about the pieces
right now it is about that King on h8
once the queen will land on G6 uh
threatening a check on the H5 with the E
Pawn gone and the diagonal open it will
be Checkmate rookie 6 is the only option
Anish is slowing down right now I
completely understand that because when
you sacrifice so much you just have so
and you have time on the clock you want
to make sure that you kind of just take
it easy and don't rush into things
sometimes you can just have this lip and
you play one move before you're supposed
to play the other one I like that he's
taking it slow rookie six Knight E5 is
the other move that comes to mind
threatening Knight G6 but it's not
looking powerful enough you need to open
the a to G8 diagonal
Anish gospel he picks up the E6 Pawn
picks it up with his Rook rookie 6 on
the board kukesh in big trouble with
just 30 minutes on the clock
I am curious why he spent so much time
for rotates E6 it might be what you're
saying just you're maintaining composure
uh trying to find the next sequences
after this he's picked up that Rook on
E6 taking it with his Queen the bishop
will take back of course uh well Anish
hasn't taken it back right he is
certainly going to play Bishop takes E6
he does not have another Choice uh but
there it is he has captured that Queen
on the Square and that means the King on
h8 not fully safe and Bishop takes F3 by
gukash and he's trying to get up go away
and go cash says get get over here you
are sitting right back down just like
they're doing Mortal Kombat dragging him
back over and something I'm thinking
about Tanya I know I defaulted to G
takes F3 because you'd capture my piece
I should capture yours is there
something to be said for Queen F5 can
you go for a Checkmate immediately is
this king is being hunted
I love it I mean we've been talking
about opening up the diagonal and
putting a queen on the H file Queen H5
you've got a massive thread of Queen H3
one defensive idea that came to my mind
instantly was
is there an option to go Rook D4
well but I'm getting mated let's just
show that line Rook D4 the I was trying
to be clever that Queen H3 is Rook H4
but it's not just this Checkmate that
you've got on the board you can go Queen
f8
and after King 87 there's Bishop F5 as
well
this should be just game over King h8
runs into Queen it's six and uh G6 runs
into Queen F7 so that is uh the end of
the end
Queen F5 I kind of love it and we saw
Anish
get up leave the board gukesh of course
made the move instantly because there's
nothing to be done you can't leave the
Knight alive uh the knight's gonna just
deliver Checkmate so he has to go Bishop
F3
but Anish I love it I like making his
time as we were talking about it he's
not making moves fast even the first
obvious ones just keeping everything
under control this is a critical moment
again when he comes back will he just
quickly grab on F3 which also looks very
tempting but suddenly Queen F5 and I'm
still struggling to find a defense
because let's say you go Bishop H5
and you can just grab on G5 as well
right if the bishop moves away you just
give the Checkmate you've been aiming
for if you play G6 you've opened up a
new Square the H6 square and that's
Checkmate the king can't run away the
bishop covers this the queen covers the
remaining squares that is check and that
is made so Tony after Queen F5 we need
to even find a move here
most these movies look bad because Queen
H3 is Checkmate so we need to stop
checkmate
um
that Queen F5 is a strong move we see
Anish come back to the board he has to
be a little careful because grabbing
back the bishop on F3 just seems like so
natural and you just make it really
quickly but if he slows down if he goes
into a think right now then I think it's
clear he's got the idea of Queen F5 as
well Robert if he doesn't rush I think
he will find it uh if we just look at
the position if we count material
actually gokish isn't doing too badly
he's got he's actually doing great
materially he's got two Rooks currently
and two minor pieces for a queen that
would be completely winning if it wasn't
for the king stuck on a chair so Queen
F5 a massive alternative to picking up
the bishop and yeah the big question is
how does black fight it have you been
able to find a way to do that yeah while
you were talking just by process of
elimination I guess that was Bishop E4
because if your queen comes back to H3 I
was saying Bishop H7 but there's F5 and
I
think I like like G6 G6 you take and
it's a rookie seven
like this is barely holding on but you
we're talking about it black has so much
material but look at the eval bar it's
still saying that white is doing pretty
well and black has a bishop and a knight
and a rook for a queen and three pawns
you do not see that kind of material
imbalance every day if we just do you
know a point count a rook is five night
and Bishop is three you know three each
that's six eleven total and a queen and
three pawns is worth twelve so I guess
by point value technically white is
better but the reason why you never just
do that everybody is that pieces can
team up a queen is just one piece but
you already see pieces are able to team
up and keep going after the white Pawn
so Queen a bunch of Pawns is not
typically going to be as good as a rook
and two minor pieces because the Rook of
the minor pieces will you know be in
harmony with each other and coordinate
to attack but why is this position still
better for white I guess this you take
and you take back Quincy check see it
and if King G7 Queen takes B7 check
and then you lose the Rook over here on
A8 but it's still saying black is very
much in the game because of all the
material but I really don't think I've
seen a material imbalance like this
in the last I don't even know how many
years
and usually a rook can do pieces for a
queen is is quite good but white has got
a bunch of extra pawns and black is
still uh struggling with finding rhythm
with those three pieces well we see that
Anish hasn't rushed with recapturing on
F3 we've seen that both these lines give
a good good Advantage so Queen F5 G
takes F3 are the two options that Anish
has Robert we'll come back and see which
lights I would love to see Queen F5 on
the boat it just feels so much more
aggressive to go for the mate and then
gokish has to be super precise but I
also have my attention on the other to
get an overview because you're gonna
love what is happening
and take a look right we were talking
about this game Parham versus dengleren
and it looked like Parham was in trouble
but I see our eval bar first it's a
crazy position white has landed up with
a Pawn on G7 already writing there's a
massive pin on F7 white has sacrificed
currently a piece an entire piece uh The
Rook on F7 is spin but one gets the
feeling that Parham has the worst is
behind him he's managed to navigate his
way and I think it comes down to that
move that you were talking about you
pointed out to not take on G7 and if you
just back up a couple of moves you
mentioned this idea of not taking on G7
but instead taking the rook and putting
the queen on D5 with the check would
give Tingler and a huge Advantage
because King takes F6 you pick up the
pawn it runs into Queen F5
and this looks like big big trouble for
black but instead ding went for the idea
that I had mentioned that looked very
attractive to me as well to grab on G7
and turns out that's not the accurate
way to play
a great lesson from Parham maksudlu is
when somebody takes a piece you do not
have to immediately capture in fact this
Pawn is often called an umbrella pawn it
Shields the enemy King because you would
like to be able to use the G file with
checks to go after it but Queen F6
played Queen D5 what's the threat if we
gave white a free move Queen takes F7 is
already defended so it's not like you
have to worry about that I probably
would just bring my pieces towards the
center Rook to E8 makes a lot of sense
I'm at some point worried about the
movie E5 I'm not sure if it will be
available but I'm just looking at it and
I don't want to see it on the board and
by playing Rook to E8 you might play
Knight d8 next protecting your Bishop
over here and protecting your Rook so I
just feel like black is coordinated
extremely well and ding might need to
find a way to liquidate and find a draw
at some moment and I'm worried about his
chances I think Parham is actually out
playing him here and just what how ding
has been hold holding his head
throughout most of the game I I really
don't believe he's comfortable with the
Dynamics
and joking it has been played it's on
the board as you were mentioning that
now if white goes on to grab the F7 Rook
all these trades actually end up
favoring farham and you're absolutely
absolutely right the body language of
the two players does seem to say that
Parham is feeling very comfortable while
Ting realizes that
somewhere he's messed up a very
promising position out of the opening
yeah this is nicely done by paramaksudu
didn't expect E4 today but still playing
great chess so uh for Parham it would be
an amazing result to beat dingley around
with the black pieces I think as you
said the worst is behind him so he can
really start believing in his chances
now I don't see a way that he loses so I
think that you know he should be feeling
quite good so let's uh you know leave
him to it he hasn't played rookie 8 yet
but he very likely will and he has great
chances uh to claim an advantage but as
we look across the boards and we will
dive right back into all of them uh so
many fascinating positions the game
between levanov Ronin and prognan that
looks like uh most likely to
did you see that it finished as I said
that as I was saying it the most likely
to finish it said not most likely we're
done we're out of here it is a draw
between these two I don't think the game
has too much to offer in terms of uh
potential variations that game is drawn
so like the players who are heading out
of the playing Hall will do the same
very quickly and win return we'll dive
right back into all the action here in
the second round of the Tata steel chess
tournament 2023.
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the World Chess Championship
to the candidates the speed chess
championship title Tuesday and so much
more chess.com events has all of the top
chess tournaments played both over the
board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
and compete by voting for your predicted
results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is a long one it's grueling there are 13
total rounds so today is the second
round as you see on the schedule in
front of you it goes all the way through
January 29th so if you get off to a slow
start there is time to come back if you
get to hot start you have plenty of
rounds left to continue improving your
results and Tanya I mean these events
they last a long long time you need to
kind of keep your stamina it's such a
long tournament and that's what the
players keep saying as well you know
whenever you watch them on that you just
cannot think about your previous round
every day you have to come fresh on the
board uh it's a good thing that they've
got three rest Days Robert they've got
one on the 19th as well sorry on the
18th and then on the 23rd and the 26th
it's a much needed rest for the players
because not just of the number of games
but the time format as well every game
lasts sometimes more than five hours up
to six hours for the players it gets
extremely grueling stamina counts a lot
uh you can't be bothered by one day one
result and I think that's especially
going to hold true for good case you
know he had a tough start it looks like
he's got a tough game against Anish
today uh the tournament doesn't get easy
the players feel this such that there
are no underdogs there's no target
you're not gonna have an easy round and
well we mentioned this yesterday you
know this is the starting of the chess
calendar the this is the tournament that
kicks things off for the Chess World we
bought our vishwanath and anand's tweet
and I think that just summarizes it I'm
gonna say it again Robert the other
January not invite is not a January at
all
it is true and it kicks off the year and
we'll kicking off the results in the
second round here in Viking say was the
draw between Lavon aronian and
pragananda and we didn't have much left
we departed at this moment thinking
about B4 instead the move d4 was chosen
by Prague understand that if politics D4
happens he was probably just going to
bring his Rook to the G3 Square he can
also play Rook B3 bringing this Rook
back here and then run around Rook D3 to
attack this one and I think you're just
gonna drop your pawns but I was also
just looking at Rook G3 you take D5 take
G4 G4 is under attack you push it
there's uh Rook F4 check just to pick up
this pawn and at the end of the day
these Rook end games look like they
should be drawn and the eval bar is a
testament to that so with two draws in
his first two games I think pragmena
should be quite optimistic earlier in
the week he was interviewed about his
expectations for this event so so why
don't we tune in and listen to prognanda
yeah it feels great to be back
um last year was a great experience for
Me overall on and off the boat and yeah
it's it's uh it's good to start the year
with uh with such a strong event
you already have that experience of
playing in the Masters here last year
what are your Ambitions your goals for
this year
um yeah last year I learned that you
just have to be focused through the
tournament because it's a long event
so that's one thing I'm trying to
um do and no just to play give my best
and see how it goes
all right Tanya it sounds like you know
he's happy to kick off the year with the
elite tournament and I like that he
seems very modest but you have to think
that given his victories over Magnus
Carl's in the Champions chest tour and
all of his successes you know he has to
believe in himself and he can do it
right like he must be feeling it after
what was a very successful string of
results
frog definitely has a lot of confidence
in his ability one of his very strong
points is in fact his the way he
calculates and how quickly he does it
but Robert even though he's established
himself amongst the World Elite in
faster time controls this uh this event
is special because this is over the
board classical with the very best in
the world like he mentioned he's had the
experience of it uh last year as well
when he was just 16 years old this time
at 17 he returns with a massive rating
of 2684. it's a massive rating but that
still makes him the lowest seed of the
event and that just goes on to show how
strong it is Prague also recently won
one of the biggest Awards in India a big
a big national award it is the second
highest sporting honor in our country
given by the president of the country
it's called the Arjuna award and after
that he played in the Tata steel India
event
it's been a really good run for the
Indian youngsters youngster as well as
at the Olympiad but again I think he has
that maturity to know that he has it in
him to play against the very best in the
world not to fear them but at the same
time he needs to prove himself in these
formats and that's what he's there for
indeed you know he has to improve it all
formats I think it's the best players
say about themselves even Magnus Carlson
he's the best player in the world has
been for a long time and even he is
still trying to improve and we were just
talking about progdananda his fellow
teenager from your home country from
India gukash had a tough first game so
probably has had two draws has been very
strong in the early going right now cash
is struggling and I just want to point
out that Anish giri has not moved so we
saw Bishop takes F3 was the last Choice
by gukesh eliminating that night which
is going to help deliver a Checkmate the
night is now gone and for a niche he can
take back immediately or plays with
Queen F5 and he is spending quite a lot
of time Tanya trying to figure out which
move is better and that's good news for
good cash
it really depends what a niche comes up
with and how he follows it up but that
said definitely the difference on the
clock is now not as much as what it was
just a couple of moves ago Anish has but
uh almost an hour uh in the last uh just
an over the last three moves going in
with Knight G5 he took his time for that
then taking on E6 and now a long long
thing to decide whether to recapture on
F3 or to go Queen F5 it's a big moment
here and it's really all about again
Anish believing in his evaluation of the
position well as his calculation and
that is something that we've seen a
niche doubt before but in this position
he's already sacrificed too much
material he needs to go all out he needs
to make a decision but Robert if he
decides to play it a little safe and
let's say it takes on F3 right now uh
Queen F5 is a line that we discussed
already white still keeps ontages and
the threat in the threats in the
position you want to go Queen G6 next
deliver on made on H5 you want to go
Queen F5 delivering a mate on each three
with all these ideas I think the most
important thing is
either one of the two moves both are
equally strong Anish needs to stop
taking so much time right now he needs
to make a decision
it's between these two and it's not like
you mess up your advantage with one or
the other yeah he needs to use the clock
as a weapon rather than allowing because
to equalize on time so we have looked at
this position quite a lot I just wanted
to point out that Anish Geary has not
captured back he has not played queen of
five he is struggling to make his next
move and that is allowing gukesh to feel
more confident about his chance but
let's zoom out let's look at all the
games we really haven't tuned into some
in a while in the bottom right it looks
like Jordan Von Forest is down a pond
but has the bishop pair in a two Rooks
per side end game so that's uh going to
be an interesting one to see if Rich
report has legitimate chances uh in the
left side of things we have Magnus
Carlson he's trying to strike in the
center with his last move E7 to E6 that
might open up the position favorably for
him we see the evaluation bar Tanya it
is in magnus's favor but I did want to
get to the top left because we've been
talking about the carwana game against
satara I think we might as well just
show it a little bit because the pawn
structure remains unappealing at least
to the eye but Bobby clearly believes
that he has no problems or at least his
problems aren't that significant in this
end game because it's a knight versus a
bishop right now it's five pounds per
side but none of Black's pawns have a
friend near it I just want to back up a
few moves because where I first started
talking about it was here and I
seriously don't think I've seen a
position with a war spawn structure
you were very critical of it and
rightfully so and I think in these kind
of positions it's so important to
understand that if you're black you
can't just start Defending Your Position
you need to take action because
strategically you're dead lost you need
to change the Dynamics of the position
and that side of course a player of
fabi's caliber realizes immediately and
we were mentioning this option of
trading the Knight on C3 saying you know
what my Pawn structure is bad I'm gonna
ruin yours as well because the one Trump
that Fabi has in this position is the
control of the a file and the eight I
love his next move as well he jumps in
with the Rook uh he made the move Rook
to A3 attacking C3 but it also has a Sly
idea of doubling up on the a file and
putting pressure on the A2 Pawn it's
going to be really all about the
activity white put the H1 Rook on B1
counter attacking I think he played Rook
HP one now
you did yes attacking the B6 Pawn with a
double up on the a file the Rooks were
traded and after the pawn goes on Basics
the pawn gets picked up on A2 and now it
doesn't look as bad despite still having
a horrible Pawn structure and Robert the
reason for that is peace activity black
snide and black stroke on A2 compensate
for how terrible the pawn structure is
that's true and one thing that players
of this caliber know is they think what
end games if I lose material are still
holdable so what Fabiano wants to do he
wants to trade Knight for Bishop and he
can lose these two pawns for this one
Pawn so I'm gonna Force this I I know
it's gonna be a little bit strange but
just let it happen everybody I'm just
trying to make a point here that if uh
let's just make King G7 Rook takes here
I'm going to force this takes here here
Rook a three Brook takes C4 this
position still is within the draw
balance because we have these three
pawns that look bad the king will always
sit on G7 and the four on three is not a
theoretical win so if you study your
devresky and game manual and just do
your tactics and study positions
regularly you look at this and Bobby
knows in the back of his head if I can
get here I'm gonna make a draw and
comfortably do so so that's what Fabi is
probably aiming for if he can make it
happen
but I'll tell you one thing about Abdul
satrov he has immense technique his
technique is so strong we saw a display
of that in his game yesterday against
Richard rappo so if he's able to get
that slight Advantage if Fabi doesn't uh
is not doesn't play accurately over the
next few moves this can turn into a very
difficult end game to save but I think
right now the piece play versus the bad
Pawn structure maintains a sort of a
dynamic equality in the position and
we'll see how this one develops but we
also have their head-to-head score and
it's really interesting to see Robert
that they have only played one classical
game against each other which in fact
Abdul satra one
that was a very important game and I of
course remember it because I was there
in Chennai and I'm going to start
playing a great game so Fabi uh he
stumbled in the opening he made a
careless move Notre back had the
advantage it was not a winning Advantage
it was a slight Advantage he played a
great game and Bobby sacrificed the pawn
had some compensation but it wasn't
quite enough for full equality and then
at a critical moment I think no deerback
played phenomenally he just brought his
pieces to an attack his King was out in
the open but he knew he wasn't getting
checkmated so all credit to the Uzbek
youngster he beat Fabiano on board one
in the Olympiad he led his team to the
gold medal and you know Fabiano he has a
great history he was the challengers the
World Chess Championship 2018 is won so
many events including this event in the
past but some people have questioned is
Fabiano's success a thing of the past
his last year was very bad he lost many
rating points he's 27 66 six Tanya most
people haven't seen Fabiano with a
rating under say 2 800 in quite a long
time but in the last couple years his
rating has taken a bit of a nosedive he
would love to right the ship and be able
to get back on track and raise that
rating uh back towards 2800.
I think 2018 was fabi's golden year he
won every event that he played in it was
that one time when Ashley actually
Magnus Carlson's position as world
number one was threatened by Fabi they
had barely any rating difference between
them Fabiano was world number two he was
playing as the Challenger for the world
championship match Magnus was not able
to win the match or uh to get anything
much in that match in the classical
segment and had to go on to win it in
the tie breaks I think a lot of the
critics had a lot to say about fabby's
faster time control play and he answered
it in the best possible way this time at
the world rapid and Blitz championship
in Kazakhstan winning a medal in both
rapid and the Blitzer section he had a
phenomenal run I think he's actively uh
put put in work for that but of course
classical has been his big Forte he
calculates like a machine his
preparation is super strong and uh yes I
think this tournament is really a very
crucial start for Fabi
he is still one of the best players in
the world Magnus himself has said that
he would make a great world championship
Challenger uh as well but uh I don't
know if you're gonna see that happen
again a Magnus Fabi world championship
match
I wonder why we won't see that is it
because Fabiano hasn't qualified for the
match or is it because Magnus Carlsen is
stepping down from the throne but either
way I mean Fabi he has struggled if
we're being honest and he's been honest
about it he has had his struggles he's
ventured into faster time controls with
success he did get third place a bronze
medal in the world rapid Championship
where he tied for second with Vincent
Heimer uh he has started a podcast he of
course has played many of the online
events he won the U.S Chess Championship
so he has had some good moments in the
past year but a lot of them I think left
him with a sour taste and he would like
to draw this game and then with the
white pieces strike but we'll leave
these players to it it's an end game no
dear Beck you know he's up on time he'll
try to press his Advantage but I'm with
you I think the activity will allow Fabi
to hold this game and uh I think you
know we should look elsewhere we haven't
looked at the game between Wesley so and
Arjun eragisi in quite a long time so I
think we should just head on over there
without even oh queen of five by the way
played by any scary so he did finally
bring that Queen up and it looks like he
will have good chances but let's go to
the game between Wesley so and Arjun
aragaisi because it's a really
fascinating battle between these two
with a king still on E8
you're not castled maybe not going to
Castle and
kind of pieces place in odd ways The
Rook on B4 which is doing an important
job of keeping D4 defended centralized
Queen but what's this Pawn doing out on
G5 like I feel like there's so many
different problems in the position and
wait a second his last one was Queen E5
giving up this Pawn with check I cannot
make sense of this position at all it's
just too complicated Tanya
this is absolutely insane I mean Arjun
just goes on to play with the king in
the center and queen E5 giving should we
just back up and see how we got here
because we left it quite early on and to
make any sense of this we really need to
see where we are coming from
this is where we last looked right with
the queen coming to C2 we're talking
about the diagonal and Arjun this with
Bishop E6 just don't go full Fisher
don't get your Bishop trapped over here
and lose that piece you see the
evaluation tank it would not be a good
decision you may get three pawns but
it's not worth it so it said F4 played
by Wesley it makes sense it's principled
there's a king in the center let's
strike uh but Tanya I mean after this
capture and the trait of Bishops this
Pawn on D4 looks like it might be a bit
stranded but white also has compromised
his own Pawn structure
100 percent and it's still a really uh
it's really a dynamic position because
White's King on G1 isn't super safe
either Black's got this active Rook on
B8 uh attacking the B2 Pawn I'm really
curious to come to the current position
that we've got because let's just play
on A5 to just try to cramp down the
queen side I like to move Rook before
Robert it defends the D4 Pawn uh all the
pieces are playing but that Rook on h8
needs to come into the game and this was
the moment that took me by surprise
after B3 black went on to play G5 hit
that Rook on F4 Wesley falls back with
the Rook to F3 and now the super
mysterious move by Arjun just putting
the queen which is nicely and happily
defending the pawn on C6 he centralizes
it with Queen to E5 giving the pawn not
just giving the pawn but giving it with
a check and one thing that could make
sense of it is that Arjun doesn't care
about material right now he wants to get
the Rook on h8 as quickly as possible in
the game let's say you do Google Bishop
C6 check
he's going to move up the king and now
threats like Bishop G4 and Rook C8 and
that pawn that you were talking about
which is the C5 weakness suddenly starts
to show and that makes me feel that
perhaps Arjun thinks that the C6 Pawn is
actually coming in his own way to get to
that weakness and if that's the case
this is one creative way to play this
game yeah I'm looking what happened to
the bishop Retreats because if you do
play Rook to C8 that pawn goes up to C6
and well that looks like a protected
past Pawn so Arjun has a lot to prove I
I he's getting active he's bringing his
rook in the game he centralized his
Queen he does have threats but a pawn is
a pawn and it looks like it could be a
pass Pawn so that is why I am personally
surprised by the move Queen E5 not that
it's a bad move but it's such an active
move playing for dynamic chances versus
sitting passively and defending and
arjun's not really a player who enjoys
sitting passively he's a very active
player himself he likes the complicated
positions attack tactics he also is
versatile and can play some very solid
uh strategic chess but I'm worried in
his position because I don't think the
white king is that vulnerable and that
is a protected Pawn up there on C6 I'm
as shocked as you are I mean this move
Queen E5 just voluntarily giving the C6
Pawn also as you're mentioning you can't
really pick up the C5 weakness sure it's
far from over there is compensation and
our valbar seems to agree with you as
well uh that white is doing great after
Queen E5 let's say you pick up the pawn
there are ideas that black has in that
final position that we saw as well but
is it enough one doesn't get the feeling
but the bigger question is why walk into
this voluntarily I guess it's because he
couldn't castle if we just go before G5
he can't get his King to safety because
H7 is hanging so if he doesn't have the
time to get his King out of there D4 is
a target you move the bishop out the way
down goes D4 the C6 Pawn is still loose
if the queen never moves to defend D4 so
maybe he kind of felt like he didn't
have a choice and he decides to strike
with G5 and then bring the queen out and
you know it has some Merit I'm worried
about his position but perhaps he just
feels he can defend it better from a
position where he actually has plans and
threats of his own so we'll see if Arjun
is able to manage this position uh we'll
go back to our view of the six boards
still remaining just a reminder to
everybody that the game between
lebronian and probably not going to end
in the draw it looks like Geary against
good cash still exciting Bishop went
back to E4 we were looking at some of
those lines earlier but let's go to the
game of Magnus Carlson uh no surprise
the world champion is playing it's going
to be a game you want to look at and for
Magnus with the black pieces against
Vincent kymer I feel like he has
everything he could have asked for and
more from the grundfeld when Peter
svidler and Maxine Brashear lagrav
started you know playing the grinfeld
Non-Stop and teaching everybody some
important lessons I don't think they
could have taught anybody a lesson that
would get them to this position I think
things have gone wrong for Vincent
kheimer look at the positioning of
Black's pawns shutting down the space
for White's pieces C3 a long-term Target
E6 is already threatening this D5 Pawn
as the Knight has joined in its attack
and if you take on E6 you've opened up a
new file for a rook to come into the
attack Tanya I really do not like this
position at all
I completely get what you're saying I
mean just uh looking at it it looks like
a dream ground filled for black that
Bishop on G7 monster the knight from B6
can actually jump to A4 and put on more
pressure on C3 as well meanwhile black
is already targeting the center asking
why to take a decision you can't Advance
the Deep on further it would be too weak
down the board Magnus has got a dream
position out of the grenfeld and knowing
him I think he's going to squeeze this
one out
and he may get off to slow starts but in
this game it looks like he is trying to
get up to a quick start in the turn with
a win with the black pieces would be
excellent uh well kymer he has had a
meteoric rise since playing the
challenges tournament last year he
recently got second place behind Magnus
Carlson in the world rapid Championship
earlier this week Vincent talked about
how different it feels to be in the
Masters let's listen to his thoughts
great I mean I always enjoyed playing
challenges as well but now the playing
the Masters I would say still on a
different level just and it's also a
sense of success that I got invited here
and the chance to play you're still only
18 years old you already had so many
successes but just a couple of weeks ago
you became a vice world champion at the
world rapid was that for you the
highlight of your career so far
maybe yeah because obviously I you know
a bit more top players than ever before
in one tournament which was like quite
good feeling for me but of course you
can't really compare rip it to classical
so it'll be very different here I think
tomorrow you're playing against a
certain Magnus Carlson your thoughts
going into that game
well obviously he's yeah the best player
for yeah over a decade I Believe by now
so it's going to be very tough but still
I'm really looking forward to facing him
and having the chance to play
where he is you know happy about his
recent performances he's beaten more top
players than he ever has just in one
event but he made that distinction
between classical chess and the quicker
time Patrol so it's clear based on his
answers and just based on his term in
history that he really does seem to
prefer playing classical chess with more
time on the clock
100 I think it gives them a real chance
to show their ideas a depression
strength and opening in Middle game and
end game against the world's best player
players and it's uh it's where you
really feel so much to learn and take
away from these established elite
players of the world as he mentioned
that Magnus has been the best player for
over a decade there's a lot of the
youngster the Young Generation has for
Mac Mr Hungry to get those games against
against him to play against him and I
think that's a good fact uh considering
his rating his title his 15 world
championship titles and I think that's
one of the heartbreaks that the Chess
World has that Magnus has decided to not
defend his title and uh this year
well I think in theory getting the
chance to play Magnus sounds like a lot
of fun but in practice you get positions
like this and you're like why am I
playing Magnus Carlson this guy's a
bully and in AIM right now we see the
eval bar it's sinking in Black's favor
why the material may be even Black's
Pawn structure is healthier we have
connected pawns three from a to c file
and then three from the F through H
white has these split pawns isolated
pawns are bad because you need to use
more valuable pieces to defend them you
would love to slide this Pawn from A2 to
B2 when you could just defend the C3
Pawn free up your Bishop the bishop is
tied down to the Pawn's defense in a
passive position closing down the D file
the E4 Pawn may become a quick Target as
well with Rook a to E8 on the docket and
if you want to move your knight out the
way you have to watch out because there
is a bit of an issue Knight D4 or Knight
G5 well 95 is just bad you get captured
in E2 and if you're a knight D4 I guess
you get away with it but even trading
pieces doesn't solve all the problems
Tanya if we get this position you can't
take the Rook because then you end up
down material after uh Bishop takes F1
you have Knight takes G7 but I save my
Bishop well skewering your pieces that's
no good at all for white and so you have
to take back and it just doesn't solve
anything although this is what's
happening
it is what is happening because I think
it's about
King
typical choices in a bad position there
are no good moves and I think he's gone
for Knight D4 trades off the bishop this
creates a lot of weaknesses on the
lights Quest the E4 bond is weak the C3
Pawn week A2 week white has got no
targets if you just compare each and
every piece on the board it's worse than
a black species also the pawn structure
uh this is going to be very very tough
for for Winston and this kind of
position I think Magnus just finds it
very easy to play and look at this he
doesn't even Rush with any of the ideas
that we were looking at you know and
even quickly go rookie eight putting
pressure on e4 or placing that Knight on
A4 trying to find the target Queen info
not saying nothing of any decisive
manner but just a quiet little move
keeping all the pressure on the position
because it's just so hard to play with
the white pieces it's hard to make moves
here uh A6 blade you just first defend
the B5 Pawn you're already considering
offering a queen trade with Queen A4
next and I really like that because it's
such an uh such an unpleasant decision
for white to make if white trades Queens
the pawns get even more weak so Asics a
quiet little move but very dangerous we
see on our screen magnet on his hands he
knows that he's better but he's the kind
of player who wants to wrap things up as
precise a play as possible in the
position the one move that comes to mind
for Winston here is 94. I want to get my
knight back I want to block your Bishop
is that a possibility
I was wondering if Knight D4 if Max
didn't even take on D4 Bishop takes D4
politics and your move Queen A4 and with
the queen trade well if you don't trade
Queens you lose the E4 Pawn your queen
has nowhere to go to keep that pawn
protected if you do trade Queens the
Knight jumps in E4 is loose and then so
is the C Pawn now Queen on C2 is doing a
very important task so I feel like
Black's past pawns are just quicker we
see the eval bar suggesting that black
is significantly better here and I don't
think that you want any part of this if
you're a Vincent camera the past pawns
just start moving up the board too
quickly
well if not Knight D4 in the live
position that we've got it's kind of
hard to come up with a move for white
that is active and I think this just
explains what you showed us uh Robert
the idea of A6 it is an anticipatory
move you're thinking about Knight D4 but
he's calculated that that end game after
the queen trade is huge problem for
white so Vincent can't make the most
natural looking move and this looks like
big trouble for the German prodigy
not a fun position to have being down on
the clock a worse position he knows he
has a worse position he's trying to make
music F3 at some point perhaps to defend
the E4 pawn it just feels all quite slow
and A6 it's a quiet move but it does
have some threats Queen A4 is a threat
Rook can come to d8 as well putting
pressure on the D2 bishop or trying to
get a rook into D3 double those Rooks I
think everything is going Max his way in
this game I feel very confident that he
will secure this point and you look at
Vincent here he just doesn't look like
he's having uh that much fun he likes
beating the top players but when you're
playing Magnus Carlson usually people
are on the losing end right just because
of his successful history as World
Champion and World number one yeah it
hurts it hurts to play Such positions
against them especially to land up in
this mess with the white pieces right
out of the opening it can't be a
pleasant experience we can tell from him
that it's he's not having any fun in
this game at all but that said he's all
of 18 years old and this is such a
massive experience for him as well so
there's a lot of take away from that
it's never easy to play against Magnus
Vincent will fight fight on but Magnus
has got a dream position uh with black
with the grunfeld and I think it's going
to be tough for him to save let's take a
look at some of the other boards because
the big question on everyone's mind
ish save his position against Anish we
can see on the bottom right there the
second board that there have been some
developments in that but still the king
is trapped on h8 why it has centralized
pieces super dangerous for gokish that
one
it is looking dangerous for good cash I
looking at the top left in Fabiano
caruana's game he's going for sort of
what I was saying that if he can get the
end game even down upon he feels
confident about his chances to draw in
the uh bottom right it looks like Jordan
event Forest is in this end game where
he's been down upon he may be able to
restore material equality and it should
be equal
um Arjun and Wesley so it looks like
that pawn on C6 was captured with Chuck
and the King went up to E7 the second
from the left and the bottom we just
looked at Magnus Carlson's game and in
the top right Tanya it looks like
dingley Ren now has a rook and two pawns
for those two Monster Power House
Bishops on A7 and B7 but if material
keeps getting traded I just don't think
that black has the Firepower to win a
game like that so dingley red probably
feeling confident not just that he could
hold but maybe that he could be even
better it might be worth us checking in
on that game uh because initially Parham
seemed to have an advantage image but I
think that it's ding who should be
looking at this position and trying to
play for more
it's really interesting what we have in
front of us so the last move that was
played by ding was from The Rook from A1
he got it to E1 doubled up on the E file
with a direct threat of rookie 7 picking
up the C7 Pawn that is what ding wants
now that said I see our eval bar Robert
it seems to say that white is doing well
here and uh it looks all
all great but from a practical
perspective I still think this is a very
difficult position for ding you know
those two Bishops that you've been
pointing out the B7 Bishop on the on the
a8h1 diagonal the A7 Bishop targeting
the F2 Pawn The Rook on d8 if it is able
to join and support these bishops from
Rook to D2 attack on F2 he just needs a
little time to be able to do that I get
it I get it that it's really hard
because you're threatening rookie seven
right now but regardless of what the
eval bars say I think
both players are feeling that they're
playing for three results in this game
The Rook on E1 can't move away from the
first track because then the river comes
with a check he's played Rook D7
stopping the idea that we were talking
about with rookie seven everything under
control it's very hard to imagine white
making progress because one of your
Rooks will always have to guard your own
King and once again I I just feel that
the eval bar can be a little deceptive
in this position in a practical sense
yeah it might not be winning or
opportunities for white to win may not
be uh plentiful but I do think that
black also doesn't have any real chances
something I mentioned in the gookash
game against Anish we're analyzing that
is when you have multiple pieces for
another piece those pieces can team up
right that's why uh two minor pieces
often are better than a rook but in this
case this is the inherent limitation of
Bishops these pieces cannot actually
team up and do anything to attack so if
the Rooks came off the board let's go
for Rook D2 a rookie two just to get
these Rooks off I know rookie seven
check would likely be good but just to
show you this
this F2 Pawn is no longer a problem you
can't tackle with another piece this
bishop can't really attack much of
anything the H3 Pawn is hard to get to
so I see the eval bar saying that this
gave uh black um you know right back
into the game in even a better position
but you can't actually threaten anything
and that's the problem uh with having
two Bishops they're great in an open
board when you can attack but here you
just don't have enough Firepower
remaining so Rook D7 was needed just to
stop for E7 check that would have been a
good move I was just trying to emphasize
a point and as we see Haram understands
it cannot allow that Rook up there on
the seventh ring
that's a really nice point that you just
made that a rook trade will favor white
or at least get him in a position where
you're playing for two results you're
either trying to push for a win or at
least you can't ever lose so that's a
safe option but till the Rooks are on
board I still think that Parham also has
his trumps question for thing is going
to be how does he make progress here uh
how does he improve the position and
that's a question that's not easy to
answer do you take the decision to fix
black spawns or Queen's side with a move
like B4 just simply uh not only
safeguarding your own Pawn on A5 but
making sure that black never has any C5
stuff coming in and just making life a
little more relaxing I'm gonna take away
more questions from you thing Lauren is
definitely one who's got the answers
he's the player technique uh let's check
up on this we'll come back to this one
Robert let's get an overview on some of
the other boards because uh I have to
say there is action on
there certainly is and England just made
some King H2 that's a very odd move I
wasn't expecting that but still a
reasonable one and each Geary against
gukesh that position the eval bar
suggesting that it's nearing equality
it's still a true fight uh but I don't
think we were expecting that position
exactly so maybe we should tune back
into that one of so many interesting
games Magnus Carlsen is just facing that
Knight D4 move we talked about earlier
uh but
and what we see here is
wait
it's the evaluation is Sky High because
because
is this what's happening here yeah it is
apparently this is what's happening we
talked about this line earlier we
actually went through exactly
this is different because after Bishop
F5 and he had the pawn is on G4 so you
have King 86 King G5 you're not getting
checkmated
so I I guess I'm ah you can go up
directly you're saying uh Bishop F5
checked no G6 G6 is bad queen of seven
check King here and you go check and
take this Pawn with check and you're
just gonna hunt down this King so you're
saying King H6 is available I'm already
looking at moves like H4 to create left
for the king and try to get this King in
a mating net so that's the big question
at this point is how to box this King in
and Checkmate that one other thing to
note Tanya is that this Knight can't
really move so if you just make a small
you know Pawn push you can't develop
these pieces
you know this is one of those positions
where I think Peter lecker would say if
this is not Checkmate rubber then
nothing is and I love the accuration H4
you don't have to rush on h8 although
that also looks very tempting but queen
h8 king G5 black then suddenly starts
hitting the bishop and still watch out
idea of Rook D1 Checkmate as well so
what needs to be careful a little bit
about his own back crank H4 boxing up
that black king on eight six uh looks
like a great and don't forget as you're
pointing out very rightfully and this is
what we've been saying from this game
gukesh's biggest problem throughout has
been the lack of development of the
queen side pieces he's basically even
though he's got two Rooks and a knight
against the queen he's been playing
without a knight in a row the entire
game
she asked me it's not developed and
there's background checkmates that's the
one thing that white needs to keep an
eye on because if you start giving
checks and thinking you're doing all
this good stuff as you see the
evaluation part going down because Rook
D1 is a Checkmate threat and this bishop
is under attack so black has two Rooks
and a knight for the queen that's a lot
of material the problem is you can't
develop as we've been highlighting and
your king is out in the open but I do
not think Queen h8 check is advisable
the H4 looks promising to me you could
also slide this bishop back to C2 taking
away the Checkmate square and that way
when you play Queen AJ check you could
take on G7 because your Bishop will not
be loose on the F5 Square so I think
that Anish Geary is well on his way to
picking up a full point in this game so
we saw the take on e4 Rook takes before
and the queen F3 so it was a different
move order tunnel you are correct uh we
had seen a queen coming to f8 Via F5 but
with the third Queen is 5 mate and queen
f8 you gotta stop one but couldn't stop
the other so this is really bad news for
good cash
so this is a live position King
and with the pieces of the queen side
box stop the king in a meeting net uh
this could end really quickly we see our
eval bar but let's not forget Anish of
course has got zero idea how winning the
position is but undoubtedly he feels it
but take a look at the clock rabbit
Anish was had more time than what he
started with he was ahead by an over on
the clock apparently he's burned so much
time that he's down to just 13 minutes
Mukesh is the one who's got twice more
than twice the amount of that time so
needs to be a little careful on the
clock here
he does because if you start burning all
of your remaining minutes 15 moves to
make you may make an inaccuracy down the
stretch when you can put the game away
but I think that Anish knows that he is
winning he senses it he just needs to
prove it over the board so I I really do
believe that he is going to secure this
full point so let's uh zoom out for a
second uh we'll just look at all the
boards as they currently sit just uh for
a moment in our bird's eye view it looks
like a niche is contemplating a move but
he has not made one yet
and that's the hardest part right you
can feel your winning but to prove it
over the board is what chess is about
and that's the most difficult thing
about 13 minutes we will jump back to
that uh but Robert this is getting very
exciting now
it is and Anish will see if he finds out
that knockout blow uh in the bottom
right it looks like your invent for us
is equalized material that gets Rich to
report in the top right dingley Red's
Advantage is growing that move C5 looks
like it might have been an inaccuracy uh
Magus Carlson in charge and Wesley so
our generic guys don't know what's
happening there we'll find out but first
we will go to a break and win return
it's more from that venue you see on
your screen invite on Zay
when I say chess what's the first word
that comes to your mind uh the musical
and of course the board game
fantastic okay it's just a sport
absolutely very competitive known
worldwide uh battle of wits to the
highest degree I imagine this is the
best interview I've ever given howdy sir
I'm doing great are you an important
phone call
okay that's not the first time I've had
people hang up for me thank you
it's chess a sport intellectually yes
okay
kind of like the same type of sport
physically that NASCAR is okay does that
make sense I've actually never heard
that comparison as a guy who's been in
chess my whole life that's a great
comparison hi sir do you play chess
oh speak French okay on poisson
hey that guy was walking on passant
chess chess yes like the gates yes I can
beat you in chess if you beat me I'll
give you ten dollars tan ten if you beat
me uh a bit
okay I love it okay I'm gonna move my
Pawn out I don't know what you're doing
I do know what I'm doing
all right
it's all right I don't know what I'm
doing in life
okay
all right bro this Checkmate oh fools
mate who's made bro I will unbelievable
you got 30 seconds for me quick
interview come on you look like a chess
player you play chess if I haven't
played chess okay when I say chess
what's the first thing that comes to
your mind winning
of these three things one of them is
real
chess dancing chess climbing chess
boxing chest climbing just climbing
chest dancing climbing chest climbing
chess books chest boxing chest boxing
you nailed it okay am I right for real
you nailed it seriously yeah of of the
two of us one of us is a World Chess
boxing champion which one do you think
it is
him with him the guy with the camera
yeah I'd like to say you but I'm gonna
go with Mr Man over the back okay easy
no he's not I mean he does get he tried
to hit another guy earlier so
oh my God she didn't even hesitate from
now on will you stop making me do things
in New York
and Toronto where it's cold can we do
every on the street episode from here
from now on
my Lord
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
who is next is the question that
everyone wants the answers to we will
find out on January 29th but right now
it is round two of the Tata steel
Masters so many participants in that
playing venue many Spectators as well
and we have six games still in progress
some of them electric tactical
checkmating positions others are end
games that uh you know may be familiar
to some because I'm gonna bring up the
game between abusitarov and carwana I
don't want to say I told you so but to
everybody watching this video I Told You
So Fabiano knew what end game he wanted
to reach and we are in that end game it
is three pawns for black four for white
but this is a theoretical draw so unless
Fabiano blunders horrible this game will
conclude with the players splitting the
point
you called it out Robert you predicted
this that this is the understanding that
these stuff
s not enough it's just not enough for
the full point and Fabi knows it you
know it and we all know that you were
dying to say I told you so and
congratulations on this one but this is
this just shows high class defense and
high class end game technique by both
you and by Fabi the big question that I
think Fabi will answer very soon and the
only one that's important in this
position is where does he want the H
Pawn will he eventually go King G6 King
H5 or does he keep the structure as is
and allow White Spot get to H5 I think
that's the last finesse that one needs
to get to and Robert
just before we move on to the next game
I want to ask you you were black would
you go for King G6 H5 here or would you
still
I would do this King G6 King G7 do a
whole lot of nothing uh because the the
issue with double pawns and particularly
with isolated pawns is that they're
susceptible to attack but when there's
only one rook and a king remaining those
are the only pieces that can attack the
pawns because how would a pawn attack a
pawn that's offering a trade if you go
e45 I'll just take you and then that's
an even easier draw so no deerback is
trying to bring his King up potentially
but then your Rook is stuck this Rook on
A2 is very active your Rook needs to
stay in the f file otherwise you'll lose
the F2 pawn moves the g-pawn is loose so
perhaps they'll try to push his pawn
something like this all of his pawns and
try to bring his King up to H5 but even
then he still can't make progress so
there isn't really much that Fabiano
needs to do he could sit with his King
on G6 you can bring it back to G7 you
can just slide his Rook back and forth
and that is what you need to do in this
position if white ever pushes E4 E5 even
with a pawn F4 you simply keep swapping
pawns there will not be enough material
remaining there are no past pawns as a
five and a car water is going to draw
this game
I love it so just don't
it all and that is good enough for this
position well there is a one player who
needs to do something about his position
let's get the overview uh that we've got
going on because my eyes are on the
Anish gakesh board that has the game of
the rounds so far for me great tactical
blows from start up until this point and
with gukesh having his King stuck on 86
we see a few moves have been played
Robert I want to start from the point
where we left it just before the break
uh Anish went into a long thing he's
down to about 12 minutes on the and
after giving a check on F5 King 86 he
comes back Bishop C2 you were mentioning
uh let's just have this on the board you
were mentioning the move H4 which looked
so strong as well to create a lift for
the king and also a boxer Black's King
but I also like anisha's approach he's
moved the bishop back to C2 uh he's
guarding the D1 Square which is super
important and he has a nasty little
threat now he wants to go Queen H5 Queen
H it and after King because the bishop
on F5 doesn't hang anymore he's
threatening to pick up the G7 pawn and
of course still black is able to uh not
develop uh the pieces on the queen side
the nightmare continues for kokesh I
like Bishop C2
this is a tragic position for him and
you know he kind of looks alone in the
world in this camera angle it's just him
Anish has left the board uh but anisha's
Gonna Leave This game with a full point
and some precious rating points he's
working his way towards 2770 I mean a
niche used to be nearly 2 800 his rating
took a bit of a hit as well but you play
these kids it's tough but right now it's
tough for the kid in gukesh's king is
not going to last that much longer we're
talking about Queen hhx there could be
Queen coming to G6 at some point with
Checkmate uh Queen F5 30 Queen G6 or
queen H7 I just don't think that there's
any defensive method here you can't move
your knight you lose your Rook now this
one's over Tanya
yeah it is it is a bit of a side and
this just shows how how
alone and lonely the game of chess is I
mean we see it on our camp cookies on a
screen uh on the board a very difficult
position to defend he's all of 17. he's
had a tough start to the tournament and
this game doesn't look like it's going
to go his way he won't be able to save
this one that King on 86 is a lonely
King uh and this is gonna be a tough one
and you can see kukesh realizing and
feeling that it's all over
and we feel for him he's such an easy
person and player to root for uh you
know always working very hard at the
board and behind the scenes uh you know
he has a team behind him he really is
giving it his all at the Olympian I
remember when he lost that game to abusa
tariff he started eight wins in a row
and then he lost a heartbreaker to abuse
the tarab and he cried he cried uh you
know their photos of it and I don't want
to you know bring up a sad memory for
him but he also was able to rebound and
it's not like it broke him it was a
tough result in a match that could have
gone his team's way it was a game that
just got away from him down the stretch
nerves and stress but he is here and he
may be losing his first two games
against dingley Ren and Anish giri but
any player in the world can lose those
first two games to those two opponents
so he needs to keep his head held high I
know you were talking about this Tanya
that the last stretch of 2022 was not
what he was hoping for he didn't
continue going up the rating letter but
that's not the end of the world he is so
young he's the youngest player in this
field it's his first time in this
environment he'll be okay
he'll be okay but not for right now
handshakes and that is it a gokish
realizes that he can't save this
position we see the two players on the
board a niche with a fantastic game a
fantastic win uh Robert
what you were mentioning I think this is
what makes this young Brigade of Chess
talents Champions and gokish is no
exception to that the ability to get
over these things it happened at the
Olympia as you mentioned the round
against Uzbekistan against Abdul satirov
and I remember it was Rishi Anand who
was telling the story that after that
loss he was mentoring and he was a guy
to the Indian team uh he would need
their help and need his help and his
support he went to see them but the kids
were just busy playing table tennis
after that match they were upset of
course but it didn't take them long to
realize that you know what it's fine
it's happened we've got to get back to
the board the next day and this is what
we see right now of course super
disappointed with the way the game has
gone but sportsmanship he sits down to
analyze because what is important for
these youngsters is also to learn from
these losses and to come out stronger
from them
for sure and a lot of respect mutual
respect between these two uh in each
Geary you know he's been to India many
times uh he did that match against vidit
I was there for it and the atmosphere
was fantastic it was superb over a
thousand people came to it so a niche
you know he is a huge friend to the
Indian scene and uh gukesh I mean these
two players know each other they will
know each other a lot better say a few
years from now when they get more games
against each other but now it's Anish
who's happy the Dutchman goes to one and
a half out of two he drew a black
against a five out of carwana he gets
the job done with white against gukesh
now
and it's so interesting to see that the
two players are so involved and
investing analyzing this crazy tactical
sequence and the Arbiters like no you
guys gotta move on there are other games
going on hurry up sign the score sheet
at a nation good case just don't care
they continue analyzing the game uh they
continue analyzing the sequence of moves
and the Habit are there forcing them to
call it a day
yes you know get out of the playing Hall
there are other people playing you know
so you know hush tones are not Anish
giri will be thrilled they can go
analyze outside but it's a win for a
niche and in the other games still going
on here we see the end game in the top
left not much has changed we see an end
game in the top right that one is
actually very interesting where ding the
Reds King is snaking up the H file and
could cause black some problems at the
bottom right we haven't looked at I see
the players are still just they're
talking amused with this I'm so amused
with what is going on that they had to
actually call another Orbiter to get
these two to move on
I think it's also hard to get a niche to
move on first of all he talks a lot and
second of all you know he's from the
Netherlands you don't want to upset the
Local Hero but at some point they will
get out of their chairs because their
game is over and all right it's about
time for them to get on with their day
yes absolutely and gokish needs to keep
this a loss behind him it's been a tough
start but again we have been saying this
it's a long long tournament and there we
see the pieces are being set back again
uh and gokish has this thing you know
regardless of the result he always sets
the pieces sits on his Board gets his
composure back uh calmly gets up you
don't see those those emotions I think
the only one time where I've experienced
it and seen it was that game at the
Olympiad against Abdul satirov uh losing
uh to Nada back
yes and uh you know he has just had so
many successes at such a young age uh
he's a fantastic player and uh you know
just looking at the positions we have
left the Arjun game against Wesley so is
interesting but my eyes are on the
bottom left Magnus Carlson he looks like
he's working his way towards Victory
we've liked his position for a while but
it's gone from even material in a better
position to one where Magnus is
technically down material
um well I guess it's technically even
two pawns and a knight for a rook but in
reality it's black just cruising because
the pawns that you have this are moving
up the board your knight is protected by
the bishop let's just see how we got
here Tanya but it's clear that Magnus
should be able to win this game
so we were discussing about a piece
landing on A4 and there we saw Magnus
reroute the knight from B6 from A4 to C5
I'm the E4 Pawn I'm the D3 Square the B4
Knight is not stable black can always
push it away with the move 85 uh taking
control of the D3 Square so a nice plan
there by Magnus uh bringing the Knight
into the game
and Vincent brought his Knight towards
the center I played Bishop G5 going for
97 check and Max said have fun with that
Knight takes E4 it looks like it
blenders a piece there are two white
pieces staring at the Knight on e4 but
after Rook takes E4 you're not gonna
take here you're gonna take this Knight
on D5 and you win a pawn and we're going
to win the game so after Knight takes C4
we said 97 check Rook takes Bishop takes
Knight takes C3 The Rook has to move
it's under attack and now we see why
Magnus is such a big Advantage it's
these past pawns with this great knight
on C3
and no one's going to stop these pawns I
mean we already see the B5 Pawn has
rolled down to B4 uh even materially
black has got two pawns for an exchange
so if you just calculate that's Five
Points each so really not even
materially down the Knight on C3 is a
total monster B4 up on the board The
Rook will join the fight A4 B3 coming in
I don't see how Winston can survive this
there are no Targets in Black's position
nowhere where the rook and the queen can
find the Harmony and put pressure on uh
this just looks like game over for white
it's truly terrible I'm wondering if
somehow you can eliminate this Knight
and if you could essentially take on C3
and then take again and give up in
exchange for a pawn perhaps you'd have
some outside chances it just doesn't
seem very realistic so Magnus he's
pushing his pawns forward with
confidence he doesn't feel like he has
any trouble converting this game I will
see if Vincent could put up some
resistance as he faced in round one
against Arham and we are nearing the
time Patrol 32 moves have been played in
this game you reach move 40 you gain an
additional 50 minutes so that's what the
players are aiming for at the moment
and it's easy to forget that you can end
up in time trouble because of because
the format of the tournament the players
an hour and 40 minutes 100 minutes for
the first 40 moves and then 50 minutes
for the next 20 moves there's also an
increment so you feel you have all the
time in the world but just this very
case that we have in front of us Winston
has got eight more moves to make Robert
and he's got only 12 minutes and it's a
difficult position to defend so even
though this is a classical format and a
classical time control time management
is still plays a very important role
it does indeed and we've talked about
that with good cash and with Vincent
down to 12 minutes ticking down tough
position for him eight moves not easy to
make when those pawns are storming up
the board so uh it's not looking good
for him we can bounce around because we
still have five games in total remaining
and I'm looking at the top right look at
dingley wren's King and also his Rook
just went from E6 and snagged upon an A6
so I feel like Parham is in some serious
trouble at this stage a dingling ran
since he gave up material and I was
saying Oh Black should be doing slightly
better It Feels Like Everything has gone
right for the number one player from
China
and the big change in the position from
when we left it last was that White's
King was stuck on G1 and it just looked
like these two Bishops a lot will create
a lot of counter play against the king
but King on H4 is super safe at any
point white can even sacrifice a rook
for one of the Bishops uh if the pawns
are Advanced enough and it's required so
definitely Parham is in a bit of trouble
here but I still think that it's far
from over Robert and the reason for that
is simply because the two Bishops have
their own strengths you've got moves
like Bishop d8 check white still has to
decide what to do with the King because
if you go King H5 then suddenly Bishop
F7 and that's not looking like it's
going to be enough to give up the rook
in this instance
you have to right it's Checkmate if you
don't take it so Rook takes F7 and if
you take back the good news for White is
you can throw in a check push your past
pawn and there are three pawns for the
bishop so in the current state of the
game it's a rook and three pawns for two
Bishops White's actually up material so
I feel like I mean things have really
gone wrong for Parham we left off here
he goes Rook D7 King H2 you can't take
on F2 this Rook F5 check picking up the
bishop that would be a blunder so it
goes C5 and there's the problem with C5
is the white king goes up sure all the
way up to H4 but this Pawn on A6 is a
target this pawn and C5 needs to be
defended and rookie six happened very
quickly if you take this Pawn on A5
thinking it's a free Pawn the white king
goes up the board here there's check
you're gonna win this Pawn with check no
no no three unopposed passers I do not
like the look of this
and my first feeling here was that it
might not be enough but I as you were
playing out the line I saw the eval Bar
says that actually white is super strong
those three pawns will tell so it does
look like ding has got everything under
control currently Rook A6 this is the
position on the board Parham thinking
probably evaluating does he go for this
line if not what should he continue with
can he try and create some chances a B4
comes to mind but it doesn't look like
it's going to be in time because you're
not able to create a passer the pawn
structure is such that black can just
never have a past Pawn
yeah I would not be surprised if Parham
loses this game uh in very shortly it
just feels like a trajectory is going
against him uh you know it's not easy to
play against dingley Wren of all people
and while we're talking about ding he
has previously scored a second place
finish in tata steel uh you know he has
not played too much over the last couple
years he is the number two rated player
in the world he finished second place in
the candidates he's earned his spot to
play against John the Palm Street in the
world championship but he kind of out of
practice to some extent and in the
online formats he lost internet
connection a famous example when Magnus
resigned because the previous game he
ding lost by his internet connection and
then of course and dingley ren in the
chess.com Global Championship he lost to
nihal sarin so his performance online
wasn't as superb as you would expect
from someone of his caliber but now that
he's back to classical chess Tanya his
rating is going up and up up and up and
it's not stopping
yeah and it's good to see ding do that I
mean we all know
all no stronger player he is uh
povert his finishes at the same field
cup defeating Magnus many many play many
of the Chess World believed that he
would be the worthy Challenger against
him as well but the last couple of years
as you've been pointing out haven't been
kind to think for many reasons in the
online format it was always the time
difference he would often have to play
at four in the morning in China at five
in the morning in China there was no
sleep uh there internet issues no
internet often getting to tournaments no
visas all these problems and hopefully
now for the World Championship uh we
won't have an issue of no sponsorship I
mean that would just be sad to see
currently at 28 11 years the world
number two
right after Magnus Carlsen the only
player to cross 2 800 uh and see him
here start the tournament showing form
showing that he is in shape he's
probably been preparing really hard for
the match in his interview that he's
taking this event really seriously not
only has he been preparing chess wise
Robert but also uh mentally for the
event where you have so much pressure
it's all eyes on you in the world
championship match there's only one game
going on and you you've got to keep your
focus on and maybe this is what we're
seeing the outcomes the fruit of kind of
preparation because it's been a great
start for him so far at the Tata Steel
yeah ding LeRon is phenomenal and you're
saying that everyone is happy to see him
back I would disagree with that because
I think the other competitors may not be
so thrilled because when dingley rent is
on form he is a scary opponent so uh we
are happy that Ding Loren is getting to
play in this event of course but I think
some of these people like Parham right
now is like can I ding maybe stop
playing classical chess for the moment I
want to have a chance and it really did
look like ding was in trouble earlier on
I thought that he was gonna have a
disadvantage but as you see him you know
he is staring at that board he's a
fighter he's staring at the board and he
is ready to take home this game he wants
it he wants to win this tournament and
it would be a huge accomplishment for
the number two player in the world to
win in tata Steel
but it's a long long way to go right now
this is just round two and things are
just getting started the one thing I
feel about the uh these youngsters and
Parham is just 22 years old himself he
is uh from Iran a super strong player uh
close to 2700 and I think one of the
biggest prodigies around yes it's tough
when You Face a player like you're
hoping and wishing that you know what
right now I'm not having fun in this
game would have been better if ding
wasn't here but for these players it's
so much about the experience of playing
against the best in the world as well
and that counts for something Barham
right now is not thinking about the
result he's not thinking about who he's
like he's just thinking about how can he
create a mess out of the position he has
and Robert we'll come back and see if
Parham manages to find some resources
currently ding looking good and strong
in this one let's get an overview go
back to our bird's eye view uh of all
that's happening and what catches your
attention in
well we really haven't looked at the
game between Jordan Vaughn forest and
Richard report and I just don't think we
will for the time being it could be an
end game Advantage for Richard he had a
pawn down Rook end game yesterday he
might get into a pawn up rook end game
today so we'll keep an outside eye on it
but what is catching my attention is the
game between Wesley so and Arjun eragasi
I think we're nearing the Finish Line in
that one there is not much material
remaining between those two so why don't
we just quickly tune into that game
actually I didn't see the Rook the Rooks
honestly so I take it back completely I
missed the Rooks on the board so I was
like oh like we're in a bishop end game
but with the Rooks there I take
everything back there's a rook on C2
behind a pass Pawn uh black has some
work to do to hold on to this game
a hundred percent I mean there's a Pawn
on C7 and it's far from falling right
now uh that is uh one strong Pawn your
King on E3 has the option black has to
make sure the king doesn't come to D4 C5
B6 protecting that pawn and that would
be very difficult to say uh to save
you've got to clear path ahead right you
want to go King D4 you want to go King
C5 you want to go King B6 King A7 black
is counting on the Move King D6 trying
to save it but then the Rook would jump
in with a check on C6 this uh I I mean
icr reval bar and it says that arjun's
fine but I would agree with what you
just said that there is work to be done
to prove that evaluation it is so much
easier to play with white right and the
King E3 how do you fight King D4 you go
Rook D1 here
you can't play Rook D1 just cutting off
the king before it even gets there but
another thing to be worried about is
Rook C5 maybe you give up the pawn on C7
if it means you can win multiple black
pawns and just to show something Rook C5
by King D6 go ahead uh
attack my Rook attack the pawn what if
white just starts taking pawns and goes
this way and that way and now you see
the white is up a pawn so instead of
having a passer you're up material and
you have a second Pawn that can go white
is clearly much better
it's a tough end game it's a tough end
game and it's the kind of positions that
Wesley really uh enjoys you know where
there's no danger for white at all
White's got nothing to worry about it's
sort of the position that you're playing
for two results and this is exactly what
you where you don't want to end up with
Wesley
yeah even if the engine says slightly
better for why nothing major I think
Wesley wins these types of end games all
the time and if you're Argent you have
to come up with a plan just like we were
talking about in the Fabiano game
against Abdus atarov are there certain
end games where you may be down a pawn
but you feel confident holding uh that
is not easy to pinpoint in this position
because there's more material remaining
so he does in fact play Rook to D1 I'm
looking at Rook to C5 I'm wondering how
he's going to respond to that move and
maybe it's not King to D6 perhaps that
move isn't quite as accurate as
something else but after Rook C5 A5 is
hanging G5 is hanging the C7 Pawn isn't
under attack it's safe and sound
um Tanya I think we need to come up with
a plan for Arjun really quickly
I think it's easy to explain Rook D1 he
has definitely seen Rook C5 but he
realizes that what he can't allow is the
king marched down the board he just
cannot allow White's King to shift from
the King side to the queen side that
would be game over so Rook D1 I think is
the right path and the eval bar confirms
it after Rook C5 I like what you pointed
out don't give the G5 pawn and I'm just
wondering if there's an opportunity to
create some counter play let's say Rook
C5 and I ignore your threats and I go F5
I I'm not going to give up the pawn
okay the eval bar luckily did not shift
so that gives me a little confidence you
pick up the pawn on A5 and then I want
to go King D6
okay you're going right for that pawn on
C7 I can see that because if the Rook A7
you're defending the pawn but now
White's pieces are extremely passive and
see one uh Robert might just be a move
here picking up the pawn immediately
right because White's not in time to
push the B Pawn so you get that pawn
right back and that's not the end of the
story sometimes we okay I'm this is a
special example but you would trade
Brooks I have the pawn back it's equal
but with white king being so active here
I think that it's likely black loses
this end game as you have this outside
passer could be used the decoy and then
you go after the remaining Pawn so you
are right that you clearly were right
the engine agreed with your analysis
that instead of bringing the king up to
G6 right away you keep the G5 Pawn
defended by making him move like F5 and
maybe at some point black can even go
after uh the H Pawn so it's a messy end
game and Tanya there are so many people
who are you know in Vikings a they're
watching uh these games look at this
crowd so that adds to the pressure
you're already playing Wesley so and F5
by the way just happened so it doesn't
feel that much pressure I guess but but
what do you think Tonya do you feel like
the younger players they might be more
nervous than the experienced players
because they're not used to having this
live audience at least so many people
just kind of hovering around all eyes
concentrated on them
you know pressure and energy it just
feels like two different sides of the
same coin here you've got all these P
all these Spectators who are watching
you play and yes it could add pressure
but to somebody who's not used to it or
somebody who hasn't played at a big
stage but with these young players as
well we call them young but they're so
mature in their attitude towards their
game and towards the experiences that
they've had playing against the elite
that this is just this is just part of
the territory it just comes with it and
they know it I think I think a managedy
uh to to go out there and to play better
you know what they say Robert you're
doing something right if you achieve
this kind of pressure if you've got
people watching you uh people fall
following it us who are clamoring down
there to see your games you know that
you're doing something right and I think
right now the players are so so games
they don't care about this I know what
youngsters this doesn't bother them at
all they've seen this happened before uh
especially at the Olympiad and at other
events there's so much fun following as
well when we were on site for the
Champions Chester event as well there
were constantly people around uh and it
just didn't seem to face them at all so
I I don't believe I think these guys are
just too strong and just to focus to get
pressurized with this the only thing
that matters is what's going on on the
board and that's the only thing on their
mind right now I'm happy that the line
that we were looking at Arjun has gone
for that defense with F5 that's always a
good feeling to caution and see these uh
world's best players agree with these
lines yes Westerly can pick up the pawn
on A5 but as you were mentioning the C7
Pawn can fall and what's very
fascinating about this particular
situation and I find it hard to believe
Robert is that Wesley and Arjun have
never played against each other this is
the first time that they meet in in an
over-the-board classical match
and playing Wesley so is something
different because he has this clinical
style where in a position just like the
one we have on the board he is able to
defeat all the highest rated players he
has impressive tournament figures to his
name he won the chess.com Global
Championship he's won the U.S
championship before he's won the grand
chess tour so Wesley so knows how to get
it done and he has one in vikon Zay well
of course Arjun qualified for this event
by winning The Challengers and it's a
challenge to get from the next step
right from Challengers to Masters
Vincent kymer talked about that in his
interview with Arjuna he's doing an
admirable job I just feel like this is
Wesley being at home in this kind of end
game he really loves to grind it out to
play a long game and to outplay his
opponent and squeeze a victory from what
looks like a Surefire draw
it's not going to be easy to squeeze
this one out I mean look at Arjun on our
screen he looks absolutely relaxed what
is uh what really works for Wesley here
is what we've been saying that it's a
position for two results Wesley
definitely feels very good about that
you're safe and there's no problem in on
the board there's no mess nothing to
worry about that's when Wesley becomes a
real monster but I just don't think he
has enough once the C7 Pawn falls off uh
that is his big Trump but after the
sequence of move that we pointed out uh
with ticks coming in A5 gets picked up
but you've got Rook C1 you pick up the
C7 pawn it just feels like there's too
few there's too little more to make
anything out of uh Wesley has won the
Tata steel Masters before but he's
looking for a good performance he's had
a rough 2022 especially in classical
chess uh he won the global Championship
High moment for him he mentioned over
there that you know he wants to focus
and improve his classical results and
this is the start of the year so the
first game ended in a draw he had his
chances against Jordan this one seems
like the same narrative following the
same narrative where I think Wesley with
the white pieces was Neville he had his
chances but perhaps never enough to take
the football Point home
that's right so Wesley you know in this
game maybe a bit better but also might
have the same fate as in game one but I
do want to take us out of this game for
a moment because uh the game that is
catching my eye is the one between
dingley Ren and Parham magsudu you see
only one Rook for white remains and
before we had two rows so it was a rook
versus a couple Bishops a white had some
extra pawns now we have a bishop and a
rook for black and white has a rook in
Five Pawns so it's a four Pawn lead for
white and well Parham is gonna have to
work really hard to save this game I see
the eval bars kind of going up and down
as it gets more depth trying to figure
out is white winning this game I just
think from a practical perspective here
there are some serious pastors here but
black is threatening to take this
opponent C3 so Tanya your first instinct
is this gonna be a win for dingly Wren
or is Parham holding this end game tough
question but my first instinct here is
that the ding has better chances of
winning this end game than Wesley has of
winning his end game I think these three
pawns here with the King on 86 The Rook
activity it's going to be a tough task
for uh Parham to different we'll come
back it's going to be a long grind here
I want us to zoom out for a moment
because my eyes and my have been taken
with what has happened left of our
screen we were talking about the game
against Winston and what other games are
all in an end game and it looks like
they're going to be quite a grind down
this will fire and uh it looks like
Vincent is on the burning end here
it's a great way of putting it and he is
in serious trouble uh look at this
position there's a bishop on C3
attacking this Rook a rook on D3
protected by a pawn all of Black's
pieces seem to be defending one another
and so that's really bad news for
Vincent who there's no way he's down to
three seconds right I mean just look at
him on camera here it looks like he's
trying to figure out okay I refreshed
you what queen to eat too so it's not
his move uh the clocks have been updated
he's attacking this Pawn H5 giving up
this Rook on E1 and I wonder if it can
be captured or if there are some checks
that white has but the answer is they're
not single check but there's a tactic I
guess if Bishop takes E1 this queen
takes D3 I say with no confidence
whatsoever and yeah okay maybe that's
available because the queen on C6 is not
protected
that is tactics everywhere but I see and
I see a reval bar it does agree that
Magnus is clearly better let's just
bring our live position up one more time
uh because I seem to have just lost you
for a moment there Robert and the queen
E2 played so Bishop B1 is the line that
you were talking about which is
it's not possible
so so which line is not possible so we
need to play it Bishop E1 would run into
Queen D3
yes exactly so that's why Magnus brought
his Queen up to D5 just getting out of
any potential pins
and now Bishop B1 is a big threat but
that is not even the biggest problem on
the board you've got ideas like Rook D2
coming in you've got ideas like A4 B3
the bonds are unstoppable meanwhile
Queen on D5 and Magnus is quite the
master of uh sort of placing his Queens
in the most active Square the queen had
to go to the it's centralized it also
defends the F7 Pawn against any ideas
Like Queenie it check uh White can play
Queen E8 rookie seven but then what
nothing is happening the queen from D5
defends all of it uh it's a beautifully
placed piece and this just feels like
it's a so I think I almost want to say
that I think this is going to be easy
for Magnus
I believe that I mean look at him he's
got his arms crossed he doesn't seem
particularly stressed out and looks like
Queen Y8 check based on that hand motion
from Vincent and well there's only one
move after Queen to E8 and speaking of
one move rookie three was played that
was moved 39 it means Vincent has one
more move after Max's reply to get to
move 40 to gain more time but time is
not the issue right here it's the
position of right now it's three pawns
and a bishop for a rook that's too much
material and the one thing that white
has going from is that Black's King is
open but it's not open enough right even
if black players say Bishop D4 I just
want to get this Rook to C8 that was my
dick
there's no Checkmate here at least one
not one that I see you have some checks
but not checkmates after D2 no matter
where your queen gives a check the black
king is going to escape and then this
Pawn is going to promote
Magnus that just adjusting his King a
little bit uh and of course he doesn't
intend to move it but as you're pointing
out that again it just comes down to
this ice queen on D5 keeping the c36
square under control and there would be
no checks to play for rookie three
played
taking his time there
mm-hmm and I'm wondering if he had to
move his King like is it that bad like
have he played King H6
I don't think it's even a bad move
and after Queen f8 you just go Bishop G7
and everything's still fine
yeah so that's the good news but he did
say he adjusts and he made it very clear
so uh he's not going to be moving his
King here I think now that we're just
talking about Bishop D4 looks very
reasonable maybe there's I don't think I
really want to take on E3 and let this
queen back to give some checks so mags
does need to be a bit precise
it's also if you just take a look at our
screen we're well into the fourth hour
of play and beyond that now we've still
got an entire hall for it's household
there uh in our playing so many
Spectators still watching the game uh
and watching the best players in the
world fight it is a festival of Justice
event for why can't they every year the
tradition continues and that's a playing
Hall Robert
yeah the festival is in full swing and
we keep saying it but it's true we love
seeing all the partitions look at that
look at the background there there are
so many people who just want to be near
the top players to watch their games uh
that is I mean a treat for them and the
the Dutch you know fans and players they
have such a rich history this is the
85th edition of the Tata steel Masters
85 years of this event and people do
come each and every year to see the
action it's really great it's really
great and we can see some of the
spectators looking up looking towards
the right and that's because they've got
screens there which are displaying the
game so it's easier for The Spectators
to follow while they can actually uh
their eye idols and the heroes of the
Chess World fight it out they can also
follow the actual games and the chess
action
yeah it's really a treat for them and as
someone who's been there on numerous
occasions commentating and getting to
interact with the people who flock to
Vikings every year uh they really love
the event it's a true uh highlight of
their year and it's a highlight of the
chess year the chess calendar is better
with this tournament and magnus's King
is a little bit better now that he put
his Pawn on H6 he gives another Square
to run to I don't think he's in any
danger regardless but he has all these
past pawns and it's only a matter of
time I think before Vincent has to throw
in the towers we're about to reach move
40. so Vincent doesn't have an easy move
to make and if he gets a move off I
think it's not going to help his cause
he's gone back with the queen to
Queen trade and we were talking about
the spectators and as I was mentioning
to you Robert the players are not faced
by they're used to it and they're
especially used to it in this
environment in this setup the tournament
is in its 81st 85th Edition so it's
quite a Monumental year uh what's
amazing to see it that after two tough
years without any Spectators without any
media because it covered week and it is
a hall full of people back to life just
the way we like it it was earlier in
beveravike the tournament used to be
held in beverwick I think since 1938 and
then moved to waikanse in 1968. it's
also trained sponsors over the years but
since 2011 Tata steel has been the big
sponsor but what has really stood out
why can't say has been home to to break
out performances to the stars of the
Chess World the champions of this event
have been the one who've gone on to
dominate the world of chess
the who's you of Chess have made their
way through Vikings a and as you said
breakout performances think about Jordan
Von Forrest he has over performed in
Vikings a each and every time he is
played in the top group he has taken
down the likes of Jana palmnushi
um mamajarov name a top player and he
has likely played them and done well
against them so uh it does give an
opportunity for players who don't always
get the grand stage to shine because of
the organization they invite a mix of
top players who have been at the top for
a decade plus and then youngsters who
will be the stars of the future who will
play in their 15th uh toddler still
Masters eventually so I think that it is
really great we get to see Daniel dubov
usually in a field like this that's a
lot of fun he's such a exciting player
one year they got him this t-shirt so at
the opening ceremony they got gag gifts
for uh players and they got him a
t-shirt that said my oh opening prep is
better than yours
so you know they like to have a good
time with things in like on Zay and one
player who is having a good time and has
a history of a good time is Magnus
Carlsen but let's zoom out from his
board they are reaching move 40 here so
uh Magnus can think spend some time
whereas maybe some of the other players
are in a little bit more of Dire Straits
so there is still action on of course
magnus's board looking dominating the
air on on those we just saw a huge
Advantage there by our adult bar and I
see Magnus has made a move it looks like
a queen trade with the end game keeping
all the trumps into position meanwhile
just next to the Magnus board we see the
Wesley Arjun game Robert where Wesley
decided his best chances to not go for
the A5 pawn and pick up the C7 Pawn he
still keeps he still keeps his chances
alive as his last one is on the board
and that's what he's playing for I still
believe it's not going to be enough uh
then we've got the Richard rapper was a
Jordan van Forest game I mean the whole
game Jordan's been on the defense
holding on he was down upon with those
two Bishops the material is equal and it
looks a lot more balanced yeah I think
that Jordan has great chances to hold
this game because of his activity uh the
B4 Pawn is going to drop we can bring up
that board if we want uh but the B4 Pawn
is about to fall and he's been worse he
was down to pawn than he restore
material equality now he's gonna lose
opponent again but he can get active
bring a rook to D6 try to go after this
Pawn on F6 so I'm not worried about his
position but what I am a bit worried
about is just the play he's had in these
first two games it's been shaky and
there could be some Rust there could be
some nerves I mean he has won this event
before so we know what he's capable of
but in game one he had the white pieces
against Wesley so he was down a pawn and
had to make a draw in game two with the
white pieces it was down a pawn and had
to make a draw if he makes this draw so
I just don't think that uh Jordan is
showing his best chess and that's
actually a compliment to him if he can
show his shaky chest and still draw
those two superstars well what's gonna
happen when he starts playing better out
of this opening
and hopefully we'll get to see some of
that chess as well I think for Jordan
he's just not been getting his kind of
positions in the middle game which
basically means messy stuff where
everything is hanging and nothing makes
sense on the other hand in both these
games we've seen out of the opening
Jordan somehow has ended up being upon
down the openings haven't gone his way
and he's been struggling but showing
Fighting Chess and resourcefulness so
far as you mentioned if he holds this
there is something to be said about
being able to defend difficult positions
and in a long tournament that counts a
lot uh let's zoom out we will come back
to this one there is action still on you
were mentioning about the Fabi Abdul
satra board and we can see that on the
top left Fabi still down upon but I
think this one he will hold this has
been your I Told You So moment uh your I
Told You So game Robert you've been
calling this out from the very start I
think this is no problem at all and it
all comes down to this last game on the
bottom on the top right tingling against
farham ding really keeping the edge
going will it be enough for him to
convert this position with so much
material imbalance currently at four
pawns for rupees
I don't envy parham's task I just see
these past pawns for dingley renin that
makes me nervous but param he's played a
pretty good game at least he's played
good stretches of this game he whispered
dingley runs pressure when there was
that Knight takes F7 and material
imbalance but then things went wrong for
him and that happens you're playing
dingly Ren all right it's a tough game
it's a lot of calculation but I do think
that he is capable of holding this
that's for sure it's just not going to
be that simple
I think the game I really want to go to
is the Magnus game and the reason for
that is I think it might even end really
soon we see that Vincent does have an
extra exchange but magnus's spawns I
mean just look at those pawns marching
down the board uh Robert I don't see a
way for white to fight them even though
the Queens have been traded and it's an
end game we've got B3 that's played
white has got no time to pick up the C3
C4 Pawn let's see if we can pull that
board up a P3 played by Magnus Carlsen
and if Vincent was
to indeed grab the pawn on C4 in this
position Magnus can go on to just
perhaps pick up the pawn on A2 is that
the idea
so the point here is that politics A2 it
looks like the bishop on C3 is hanging
but you need that Rook on C1 to cover
the promotion square but it does feel
like after Rook A4 well we get a queen
you take we get get this trade here
black is up two pawns not just one pawn
two pawns so after Rook D5 the reason
why the second Pawn is important is that
eventually if we can push our Pawn to H3
we have a second one behind it and
that's really important do not take that
for granted double isolated pawns we've
seen the mocked I mocked them earlier in
five minute carwana's position but here
it actually plays a pivotal role in any
kind of end game so uh in the start here
Tanya Rook takes C4 I'm wondering if
there's anything else besides B takes A2
I don't really think so I feel like
that's the only option your B2 The Rook
will slide to B1 and now if I can take
your bishop and take your Pawn white is
not trouble because look at this the A2
Pawn would sell and be on the board so B
takes A2 looks like a forcing sequence
and Magnus must have calculated that
this is winning
yeah it's definitely a better version to
take the A2 Pawn get rid of that one of
the things that the Magnus as his
ability to evaluate positions at the end
of lines correctly we often find him do
that he also has uh this Knack of just
great calculation I mean there are so
many strands but I think he knows that
that end game after Rook C4 you take
tornado you trade and he just knows that
this end game offers him great winning
chances and he believes in his uh uh in
his end game touch for which he's quite
famous
yeah he is an endgame wizard he has been
for a long time he has the you know the
Applause of everybody because he wins
positions that look unwinnable this
looks very winnable and I believe he has
calculated he has seen the future if you
will and he knows that that position
will be winning for him and I don't
actually don't think it's that
complicated in many ways there's some
end games you have to be very careful uh
there he's going to plant his work on D5
at the start to protect his Pawn if he
didn't bring his Rook over to G5 at some
point to keep the white king honest and
then the black king will try to zoom
over to the queen size just to show that
one more time very quickly
that in a situation like this with the
Rook on D5 let's say this King tries to
run this black Rook can sit on G5 and
pressure this Pawn so the king can't
move anymore and then the black king
will just try to work its way this way
and it's interesting because uh the bar
isn't you know Sky High or anything like
that but I wonder if uh this is just
winning for black I I really feel
strongly that it should be unless this
white Rook somehow gets active but that
takes quite a bit of time in which case
the black Rook will slide behind the
past Pawn
very nicely explained Robert and I think
we just saw Magnus return to his board
brief uh see that Winston still hasn't
made his decision and we see him coming
back with uh what looks like a glass of
water there a tough tough end game for
Winston all these
I don't even relative to Rook C4 I have
a feeling that we will be seeing this
this thing being played out and Magnus
will show us the parts the technique are
required to win it you were pointing out
the Rook G5 idea I loved it a beat three
it's a tough tough task for Winston but
it's been a dominating game Agnes right
from the opening
it certainly has an impressive display
from the world champion in all three
disciplines uh he wants to get on the
scoreboard early that's been one of the
issues in tata Steel's past is that he
struggles out of the gate he's a little
sluggish so if he can get a win early
and they keep up that form and good luck
to the rest of the field but I mean it's
not proven that this is a win we'll
watch him do it I'm excited to see it
because I'm gonna learn from Magnus
Carlson who doesn't want to learn from
Magnus Carlson that's what we're all
here for uh but Vincent he's going to
play this out because why not you know
resignation is zero points if you lose
on the board also zero point so you have
to play this out if you are Vincent
kymer and uh it's not completely game
over until Magnus shows us his plan
and we see the end game approach the one
that we were discussing played out uh it
was everything's going to be traded off
and we come into this end game where
White's dream was to have the behind the
a pawn and not in front of it in any
Rook Pawn ending what you want is to
have your Rook at an active spot and not
a passive spot and what will make life
super difficult for Winston Magnus goes
Rook D5 a horizontal defense of both the
A5 and the H5 Pawn the king always
threatens to March up the board uh this
looks like it's going to be magnus's end
game he will show us how it's done but
while he does that let's zoom out and
take a look at some of the other in
we've got going one of them
uh Robert is
the second from the bot and see Wesley
against Arjun that's been going on for a
while uh Wesley really trying to grind
this one but Archen looks like he's made
progress on F4 the pieces look active C7
still stopped not making it easy for
Wesley no he's not and so Wesley uh he
is going to try to continue pressing but
I'm not sure he's gonna be the one
pressing if the game continues this
manner black has a pass Pawn of his own
so we'll see if Arjun aragici is able to
continue this impressive display of
technique and at the minimum make a draw
but now the players have reached move 40
they have made the second time Patrol
gaining 50 minutes on the clock we are
going to take a break but when we return
it's more from round two here at the
Tata steel chess tournament 2023.
chess kit is fun Jess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest bustles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
eign
[Music]
doing poorly when he starts not so well
because the tournament is very long but
he's also won the tournament before he
used to be a world number two for a very
long time now he says some ups and downs
but if he will be informed and nobody
who will be shocked to see him at the
very top of the standing Fabiana Corona
being clearly is world number two uh
definitely one of the best players of
our times he had a very interesting and
unusual period Now with uh kovid in
China he was not traveling very much and
he was out of competitions for a long
time but he managed to play just enough
to get into the candidates and then he
managed to finish second and now he's
going to challenge an opponentry for the
world championship title so very
exciting period coming up for Ding and
we're really happy to see him back in
Vikings day he's one of the tournament
contenders one of the contenders for the
first place Magnus Carlson keeps coming
back to vacancy and that really makes a
tournament very special we're grateful
to him he's always happy he has good
memories from the childhood he's played
every year almost every year in Vikings
day and he's won a bunch of times not
always not always but he's won a lot of
times people are always happy to see him
play
certainly in terms of level this will be
the strongest vacancy tournament that I
have seen because there will be no
underdogs I'm really looking forward to
the next edition of the Tata steel chess
tournament I hope you are too I also
look forward to meet all my friends back
from all the sections amateurs
Professionals in this very beautiful
Village that I can see so see
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun and look at
the intense focus on magnus's face what
a performance it has been
once again vikon Zay starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th Tata steel
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back the world's number one looks to
further cement his legacy in this event
and the game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
the tournament and it is Jordan fan for
race winning the dramatic Armageddon
don't leave out those poised to capture
their first Tata title
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps
the Dutch refer to Tata steel as The
Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steep in Prestige and Legacy and does so
again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mine Brendan it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament and it
starts right now
three games have concluded in Vikings
while we're on break the game between no
deerback Abdul sataurav and fabrina
caruana ended in a draw no surprise
there given the position Anish giri won
earlier it was a demolition against
gukash and then levada and program to
split the point they were the first game
to finish of the round so Tanya we still
have four games remaining and some of
them are actually quite interesting some
life left in these games
a hundred percent and the Magnus versus
Vincent is one of them it is such an
instructive Rook Bond ending we see that
on our bottom left uh Magnus voluntarily
went for this uh for this end game uh he
knows what he's doing he knows that he's
got his good chances here because
White's Rook just not actively placed
but it is still a long grind and it
needs to show some good technique here
right next to him Wesley's still trying
to grind this out but I have to say that
it looks like arches do I see her if Val
bar has slightly moved up to show that
Wesley has made some progress so I think
that should be the one that we should go
to next uh meanwhile just really quickly
the Jordan board continues to stay even
Jordan really showing Amazing defensive
resources and technique in these first
two games I mean while Tingler and
Parham thing in a driving seat and it
looks like he's made a lot of progress
yeah I just want to point out something
about the uh game of dingly red versus
param so I'm going to pull that up very
quickly just because
um I think it's easy to overlook one
small little thing that if it were a
Black's move this would be Checkmate so
don't get checkmated would be my biggest
piece of advice right now whether that's
bringing the king back to H5 to take
away this check or maybe even throwing
in this Rook F5 check first these are
the big questions because uh you know
this Rook F5 check looks pretty good if
the King has to run away then the white
king also against the G6 Square so you
have different ways even Rook C7 check
of giving your king some safety and
that's what dingler is trying to figure
out
which check to give both equally
attractive as you pointed out he just
needs to make sure he doesn't fall for
this trick uh that shouldn't be so hard
for ding Lauren we will come back to
this so let's zoom out again and take a
look uh at the game that caught my
attention to Wesley versus Arjun board I
think that's a really interesting end
game because we were thinking that Arjun
was doing just fine but I see our reval
bar seems to slightly slightly like
Wesley's position in this or do you
think uh arjun's still holding on
perfectly well
it's interesting because I feel like
Arjun is playing perfectly like his
defense has been superb and yet I'm
looking at that pawn on C7 and it makes
me nervous because if you could somehow
get after this bishop on C8 you will be
able to get a queen the problem is you
have a bishop against a bishop so how do
you attack a bishop with a bishop if you
go here I just take you there's no way
to dislodge this piece from C8 unless
you're Rook somehow gets to h8 or
something like that but Rooks don't move
in that way and anytime your Rook runs
around the king can go scoop up the pawn
so I just don't think that Wesley has a
way to make progress if he takes on F3
down goes the pawn in H4 we are seeing
the pawns come off the board and if
that's the case then I do feel like
Arjun will be able to hold what he
doesn't want even though it's still
theoretically a draw is to leave this
bishop and this Rook against just the
lone Rook uh it's a draw if the king is
normally placed that would be a draw but
it's just not a fun defensive task
yeah that's no fun at all but even if
that was to come I think our techniques
and how to hold on to that and will
confidently enter that position and be
able to get away with the draw also an
interesting point in this particular
position after Rook D4 the H4 Pawn is
hanging uh you I can't trade the F Pawn
for the H Pawn but the more uh pawns
that get traded the easier it gets for
black and defend this white could look
at giving a check on C5 Rook C5 check
but then you've got to really think that
are you okay with the lying black skin
to march to F4 and all the counter play
that comes with it a rook D5 is of
course a safe option but I would be
scared of King F4
yes because you know Rook C5 check if
the king comes F4 I'm thinking oh I have
the most advanced pass Pawn let me play
Rook C4 and trade Rooks and that way I
don't have to watch out for Rook D2
check but if I take with the pawn over
here I have to watch out for this Pawn
so I take with the bishop uh the king
can go after this pawn it can also Dart
right back and take the C7 pawn and very
importantly what I was saying earlier
even if you had a couple free moves
there's no way to get this bishop to
move you don't have any Square possible
that would uh offer a trade safely so
you can promote your Pawn so I I'm with
you I think that the king going up to F4
uh looks very
um easy for black to continue his
defensive task Arjun eragisi deserves a
lot of credit because he drew game one
against prognanda with some great
preparation and then after that he
played accurately now against Wesley so
it looked worse for him but it never was
that bad it never was that big of a
problem and he is going to confidently
draw his first two games with the black
pieces that's a tremendous start for the
youngster
origins of fighter like that and I think
in this game as well regardless of the
fact that he got into a bit of trouble
and Wesley always seems to be the one
putting the pressure uh we remove Queen
E5 in the middle game voluntarily giving
up that Bond going into these Dynamic
positions he feels confident he feels
comfortable and that's his style of play
he's an absolute fighter Robert I feel
like there's something about Tata steel
and Arjun uh you know we were talking
about how this platform and this
tournament has been such a breakout
event for so many players Arjun back in
20 uh 22 won the challenges with one
round to spare he had a phenomenal
performance uh scored 10 and a half
points out of 13 and uh qualified for
the Tata steel Masters not just that
even the other Tata steel events that
happened in India the rapid and Blitz
Arjun has won both years in that he has
had phenomenal performances beaten the
likes of Levon aronian and some of the
biggest players in the world he's
Fearless in his approach in the game
he's all of 19 in in a way he's the
senior most amongst the young lot with
the kokesh at 17 Winston at 18 Prague at
17. uh Arjun at 19 but his rise has been
phenomenal in the Chess World he was
somebody nobody knew of no one was
talking off a year and a half two years
ago he was just one of the talented
young Indian boys not even very very
young at that time but suddenly within
within a gap of a year and a half from
2500 he reached 2700 currently at 2722 a
spectacularized by Arjun and I was
watching an interview where Magnus
actually mentioned that amongst the
Indian players and this wave of Indian
talent that we have he believes that
Arjun is perhaps slightly ahead simply
because he has the most universal style
and he was full of Praise of arjun's
gameplay I believe five and a carwana
said the same thing on his podcast uh he
was praising Arjun eregaissi I mean he
has proven himself over these last few
years he at first was known as kind of
like a speed demon a great Blitz player
uh who was proven himself over the
shorter type patrols but he's showcasing
that he can do it in classical as well
and you know you mentioned that he seems
to throw live in tats of Steel I heard
they're looking for a new Superman so uh
you know you can get our generic geiste
there the man of Tata steel let's get
him on the Billboards
it's not far off we will see that and
also let's not forget the huge 1.5
million dollar deal that Arjun signed a
historic one in sponsorship which is
recently a couple of months ago with a
singapore-based firm Quant box I think
and uh with that it's going to be
interesting to see how
horses are you bought to eventually go
on to achieve his dream to try and fight
for the world championship crown
yes he is capable of the highest Heights
in uh the world is rooting for him
Wesley so probably not rooting for him
in this game uh but it looks like it has
leveled out so I do believe that Arjun
is going to hold this without too much
issue so let's zoom out uh once again we
still have other games going perhaps
some things have changed uh Magnus
Carlsen in the bottom left showing off
that end game technique puts his Rook on
F5 which keeps the king stuck it's
Tethered to that pawn on F2 and if
that's the case the block King will go
to D6 and C6 into B5 it's gonna Venture
on over to that passer on the a file in
the top right still that position
dingler on has not moved he's
calculating and then in the bottom right
Jordan Von forest and Richard report it
seems like that game is quite level uh
between these two they're such combative
players but it looks like a draw is the
likeliest outcome
and games all around but definitely in
some it's even While others are trying
to defend I see that Wesley has made a
move uh he moved the origin has captured
on H4 we can see it's going to be
interesting to see how Magnus might
convert this you were pointing out that
he's simply transferring the king from
the King side all the way to the five
Pawn uh White needs to dislodge that
Rook on F5 the counter of that would be
to try and get the king to E4 uh defend
your F2 Pawn it's hard to fight can uh
can hold this together with black
finding an easy path and this is why you
want your defensive Rook the white Rook
on the other side of the board so that
he can start attacking the 86 Pawn
imagine the same position Robert but
instead of The Rook on A4 The Rook was
on A8 and then suddenly you could try to
attack the 86 Pawn the A5 Pawn but
Winston unfortunately is not only two
pawns down but also stuck with an
extremely passive Rook that's right so
we'll pull up the board as Tony was
saying a rook an 8 would be excellent
and I I want to point out something else
I already mentioned in the Fabiano
caruana game against abdusitarov you
want to see what end games you can hold
even if you're down more material so
let's imagine that the only piece
remaining are in green these four pieces
for black and these two pieces for white
so we get Rook for white and a king and
then Rook F and h-pond they're a
theoretically draws tendencies in that
ending so if somehow some way that this
A5 Pawn can be removed and one of these
H pawns are removed for uh these two
pawns then perhaps there is a draw
available to Vincent kymer now that it
looks like it should be lost rook in two
extra pawns you're taught when you have
extra material to trade but um right in
those specific end games uh you may not
be able to win them so I don't know how
you make that work Tanya that's just
what's in the back of my head is you
know even if black starts going after
these if white can take these two that
position has Josh tendencies
[Music]
yes theoretically there is uh we know
the H and the F Bond Jaws but it's also
practically really difficult to hold
those positions as well Rook Pawn
endings are just a different ball game
they just require so much precision and
it's the hardest kind of end games to be
precise in because every move changes
the dynamic we see that he's gone for
the move with F3 and uh with that the
king is free White's King on E2 is free
from defending that uh Pawn on F2 so
King E3 King E4 ideas come to mind but
G2 is a weakness as well uh Robert the
dream of giving up the two pawns and
trying to get the pawn
would be the best case scenario for
Vincent when it comes to trying to
defend this I just don't see Magnus
allowing that end game to happen
right but I think Vincent wants some
kind of King D3 so this black king wants
to quickly go to B5 but if King did D6 I
was imagining that the response would be
king D3 going away from your kingside
pawns and if the black king keeps going
the white king cannot go to C4 then Rook
F4 check trades the Rooks and that's a
winning King It Pawn end game but I
thought King C3 King B5 and then I was
hoping you know if I'm looking at this
from White's perspective the king B3
holds the balance because now I still
have my blockade my king is in front or
near your past pawn and then this Rook
is free to go to the other side of the
board and put pressure on your double
isolated Pawns
there's still technique to be shown here
but it does look like Magnus not doing
we see her if valbar uh not moving in
its evaluation it's not as if Black's
Advantage has increased which actually a
credit goes to Vincent fighting this
game out fighting this position out
after coming into so much trouble right
out of the opening and that's not an
easy task when you're playing against
somebody like Magnus so Vincent really
showing good defensive technique I still
have a feeling it's not going to be
enough
uh Magnus reaching out there ready to
make his move I think he wants to play
on with the King get the king to the
queen side I'm expecting King D6
but he is looking a bit less confident
than we saw we saw him earlier right
when he had the bishop and those pawns
going up the board so he has cash in
where he has extra material and he has
played King D6 and he very well may win
this game uh but Vincent is putting up
some stubborn defense and there's so
many different ideas
this is a very rich position because
what I'm thinking is even if this King
got to say B2 maybe the black Rook comes
to C5 to cut the king off on the queen
side and then the black king tries to
run on over to the king side it's a bit
of a long story but I'm just gonna put a
position on the board so bear with me is
that in that variation that we were kind
of just discussing is like let's say I
give this Rook C5 check and the King
goes in front of this Pawn now your king
is cut off so maybe the black king says
fooled you I'm gonna go back around this
way towards the king side and try to
push these pawns it's a long story but
oftentimes these end games when you're
up material it's not really about being
quick you're not just promoting on the
spot
um this king is just trying to work its
way over King E5 king of five King G5 so
on and try to help out as your king is
in good position for then your Rook to
slide back and go after these pawns it's
all about timing
it's all about timing and it's so hard
to defend these positions Vincent has
another approach instead of activating
the king he really wants to activate his
Rook he's gone for the move Rook to C4
we've been talking about the idea of
trying to get your Rook behind the pawn
he wants to go Rook C8 next if given the
chance place your Rook on it place your
Rook on h8 try to create some threats I
think Magnus is going to do what he can
to stop it and Rook C5 is a move that
comes to my mind yeah Rook C5 is a
really a good move I also think you can
throw in Rook G5 first if you want to
drag the king back towards the king side
a little bit since the G2 Pawn is
hanging with check and after King F2
then swing your Rook to C5 I'm not sure
it's so important in this particular
position but as we know in the end game
every Tempo can matter so uh perhaps the
king is just farther away from this past
pawn it might be important but the eval
bar suggests that it's not
I agree with you these small incremental
things no matter how tiny they are but
yes it matters that white skiing is
further away from the a pawn it's a
small Advantage you just never know when
it might play out and I think this is
the kind of stuff that keeps building
pressure on your opponent so Rook G5
Rook C5 would be a nice subtle
Grandmaster way of pulling out this idea
of stopping The Rook from getting
activated the white trip from getting
activated to C8 and we are well into the
fifth hour of the play we still see a
bit of crowd there in our tournament
Hall Robert still there are spectators
seeing the very very last moments of the
games for the day the amateurs actually
strapped up uh comes to an end as we can
see a bird's eye view of our tournament
Hall but the games are still the action
the long fight is still on in the
Masters
it certainly is and some of those
Spectators will be there to the very end
they just love uh these great games of
Chess that they have the privilege of
seeing up front and personal so Magnus
Carlsen he'll work on this end game for
a while may keep us here for several
hours so let's zoom out again we still
have three other games in progress three
games have finished four games Remain
the only winner of this round thus far
is Anish giri uh dingley Ren he's doing
his best to join a niche he would love
to win his second game in a row to win
in this round and I just wonder he
hasn't moved yet he's taking his time he
just trying to figure out what is next
uh but what is causing him that pause
that's the big question
it's been a long thing uh you met the
time control but it's still a really
long while since we saw ding make a move
and let's pull up that position that we
have in front of us now so Rook D4 was
the last move made by Parham with a
devious threat of giving a mate in one
Rook H4 check if white isn't careful so
there's no chance of there's no time to
go A6 right now uh a check comes to mind
white has to give account to check
himself so Rook C7 Rook F5 ideas were
what we were looking it just feels like
things taking far too long to make this
decision
yeah he's I'm working on it he he knows
that one inaccuracy can change the
result from what should be a win to an
immediate draw or even if the game is
objectively a draw no matter what with
optimal play some
positions are a little bit easier to
defend than others so right now Rook H4
Checkmate is the threat but let's just
bring the king to H5 just so we can kind
of understand this position a little
better I think this A5 Pawn will be
dropped because the Rook comes to A4
that's two pieces attacking only your
Rook on C5 is a Defender so the question
is what about these three pawns if we
start pushing the pawns with H4 and you
play Rook takes A5 and white says oh
three pawns that's good better than a
bishop and you trade
I don't think you're winning all zeros
at this point because
this King you know would like to help
the pawns go forward you would like to
bring your king to H7 and win the game
but not so fast I play King 2 G8 and
when you play the move say G6 I have
this check on D2 and your King has to go
back and the black king goes forward so
when you have this bishop you want to
control all these dark squares which
means that white in Ideal World Keeps
all the pawns on dark squares and pushes
the F Pawn but once you do something
like this the bishop can start attacking
the pawns one by one Bishop E1 you said
you want your pawns on dark squares well
you don't really want to bring your king
back so you push your Pawn then I play
Bishop D2 and you push this pawn and now
I believe that in this position white
can make zero progress because this Pawn
is pinned and you're going to have to
release with King to H7 and then I'm
going to win your Pawn so I'm just gonna
sit around and wait until your king
moves and then it gets your Pawn
that super illustrative of the defensive
techniques that exist in this position
with the the black pieces I think ding
has to make sure that he can coordinate
his own rook and his king without
trading it off going into this uh very
clean cut Bishop versus three Pawn end
games this is where parham's best
chances are if we just bring up the live
board uh the current situation that we
have and we were talking about how black
is threatening a mate in one
yep
I still believe that you have to give a
check it just feels so much more natural
to keep the rook and the King on the
board and even if you lose the A5 Pawn
stop thinking about how to push your
king Side Pawn the check that comes to
my mind which is more attractive is Rook
to F5 and not to C7 and the reason for
that is I'm super happy if you move the
king to the e-file your king is cut off
let's say King E6 and I go King G6 I
defend my Rook my bonds are defended uh
it's not easy for you to even pick up
the A5 Pawn because let's say you go
Rook A4 Robert with a similar idea that
you were pointing out white has a nasty
move A6
I could start with Rook F6 but I like A6
because it sets up a trap you still
can't take on A6 because after Rook F6
you lose the Rook so I end up keeping
all my pawns alive
that's so beautiful line slowly and
steadily I'll go Rook F6 King G7 G6
Advance my G Pawn find a way to actually
improve the position I have to be
careful about placing my pieces on dark
squares so it has to be timed well but I
keep all my pawns alive on the other
hand after let's say let's just go back
a couple of moves black skin doesn't get
cut up on the e-file after Rook F5 check
you have the option to go back into G8
and you might feel you know what I am
going to keep my king in front of the
king side pawns but white still goes
King G6 here
and it's not so clear how you can play
rookie 5 perhaps now and the point is
that after Rook A4 sorry Rook A4 there's
a deadly threat that white has now with
the King on G6 and the King on G8 I swap
I uh swap my Rook to the other side with
Rook D5 hitting your Bishop on D2
threatening a mate in one with rook d8
and this looks like it could be trouble
I see that you still have Bishop A5 so
maybe it continues uh but now my pawns
March down the board now that you've let
go of control I can go F4 F5 F6 your
Bishop is stuck defending the back Rank
and this is progress yeah you can't take
an F4 without losing A5 and otherwise as
you said the pawn marches forward and
it's gonna deliver The Knockout blow the
H1 can move after that as well so
um so much to work out here for both
players dingley wrench trying to be
accurate in his path forward I love Rook
F5 and king of G6 I mean after rookie
five check you can pre-move Team G6
that's the nice thing but dingley friend
he doesn't take positions for granted he
doesn't actually ever do that he is very
stoic and he like concentrates to the
last possible move of course he makes
mistakes he's human everyone does but
I've always appreciated that about his
style is that he gets these end games
that may not seem to have too much life
to them but he keeps working it's kind
of like Magnus in some ways their
overall style I would say is quite
different but he does have that Magnus
tendency in the end game to continue
pressuring his opponent
I look at it right now on our screen and
I I just don't know how much he realizes
that this position offers him winning
chances uh he's taking a lot of time
he's thinking a lot we've got the eval
bar helping us out which of course not
just us in the right direction but ding
might even just feel that this position
is slightly better and not that much and
if you have that kind of feeling then it
becomes very difficult to take decisions
on the board we see him thinking for a
long time uh between these two checks a
rook C7 is also tempting the only reason
that I felt that it's a bit less
attractive is because you lose control
of the G5 pawn and at some point that
can be a little bit of weakness
meanwhile we do have a result I see uh
the Wesley Arjun game has ended Robert
and it looks like it's ended in a draw I
see the two kings at the center of the
board uh the two players after a
marathon fight of course discussing this
very complex end game Arjun was cool
calm and composed and became Wesley just
probably had a better position
throughout but never enough
yeah never much of anything in the end
and the King went to D3 the bishop came
out to F5 with check which protects the
Rook through the king and they just
repeated moves at this point after H4
the threat is H3 and H2 and then black
could be the one who's playing for a win
so I have a Kingda D3 you're trying to
kick this Rook out so the bishop can go
to A6 I talked about dislodging this
bishop on uh C8 that is the goal and
there's actually I'm wondering now Rook
A2 just to make a bad move I was
wondering if Rook E6 check as possible
because if you take my Rook then I take
back and you can't stop me from
promoting and if you have to instead
move your king the only legal Square
then The Rook comes up to E8 and I'm
gonna at the very least win the bishop
for a pawn but I think I'm just winning
the bishop for free because there's no
way that if you're saying Bishop B7 Rook
B8 you mean your Bishop can't move
otherwise I'm gonna get a queen
foreign
and in the end this one did end in a
draw a good save by Arjun Hill uh being
very precise in his defense with this
move Bishop to F5 uh instead of moving
The Rook away keeping control of the C7
Square so nicely played by Arjun there
with that check and uh with that that
ended in a draw Wesley for the second
time in two days having a slight push
having a slight Advantage but not being
able to take the point home you need to
make sure that doesn't get him too
frustrated Robert meanwhile Arjun with
Dynamic play in against Prague and
Wesley should be proud of the way he's
handled the two okay we can see the
crowd trickling away uh as fewer people
are left in the playing Hall is getting
lonelier I also saw on our screen adiban
playing in just that section uh it's uh
it's always nice to have company and not
to be the last player playing
that's right I mean the playing Hall is
getting a bit lonelier but there are
still a number of people there and
they're giving it they're all every
single player is trying their best and
as we have three games remaining uh
Magnus Carlsen trying his best to win he
brought his King back towards the king
side sort of what I was highlighting
earlier uh with the King going all the
way to the queen side for white but he
didn't have to get that far the Kings on
D3 cut off along the e-file and so it
looks like Magnus is pressing so why
don't we go back to that ending I do
find it super instructive anytime Magnus
Carlson plays but especially his end
game technique as prowess he has cut the
white king off from the pawns here and
so I'm wondering kind of how he actually
makes progress like the king's cut off
that's great but what is going to happen
next
it's it's a tough question to answer and
I think Magnus is just gonna dance
around a bit here a bit there with the
King on the queen side and then uh show
us the way eventually you're asking for
a plan and that's
I don't I don't think it's about
concrete moves black needs to find a way
to improve the position currently The
Rook cannot jump to E1 the A5 Pawn is
hanging the king can come to G5 of
course avoiding the F4 Fork so you first
let's say uh move your Rook slightly
away then go King G5 but you're not
really advancing uh from there the
fourth rank is cut off and uh
it's kind of hard to say where you're
making progress maybe Rook G5 is an idea
Rook G5 is an idea to put pressure on G2
and then are you gonna just say that
I'll give up the G2 pawn and take the A5
Pawn Vincent will have to make a call
there yes I think that would be ideal
because let's say the King goes here The
Rook comes to G5 and the King goes back
if you take on G2 Rook takes A5 well
we're getting awfully close to the
territory that we were discussing
earlier instead of uh Rook h and f these
two pawns we have the pawn Sun F3 for
white but black has two H pawns not sure
if that's important it probably is and
the reason why normally you want to stop
a pass Pawn from behind you can't do
that because there's a second Pawn on H6
blocking the Rooks path so maybe just
King G6 and then this Rook will have to
defend from a passive position rather
than an active one it's a fascinating
end game that we're seeing here and we
keep talking about Magnus Carlson
talking about how strong he is in the
end game he's also particularly strong
in vitan's a I don't know what it is
about the Dutch winter time but it
motivates him he is an eight-time
champion in Vikings a in the masters
section he's shared first place before
they had tie breaks uh matches against
Levon aronian in 2008 but Tanya the
match scores here speak for themselves
the guy is dominant and he thrives in
tats of Steel
sad that he really enjoys playing there
it's an event that he looks forward to
to start the Calendar yo with it he's
one in eight times he keeps coming back
to win it more so he's clearly not had
enough of it he likes the mix of players
that he gets to play that it's not only
the established Elite of the world but
also the most talented ambitious hungry
youngsters that we always find in the
mix so definitely going to be
interesting to see the one thing that
we've seen in his performance in bike
has been a slow start we see that quite
often with Magnus the first couple of
rounds he is not able to get those big
wins but then once he starts scoring
it's able to stop him uh right now this
position I think somewhere can also be
slightly frustrating for him feel that
perhaps this game could have been
wrapped up a long time ago he had a
dominating position in the middle game
where he sacrificed an exchange he went
in for this end game believing it's a
win and he should be able to to win it
but Winston really putting up best
resources here and making it super hard
for Magnus and there's something to be
said about he is fighting like a
gladiator in this position we keep
talking about the Magnus touch when it
comes to end games and Robert that comes
from the time back in 2010 and 11 when
Magnus was just becoming world number
one eating in his rankings he used to
play these drawn and games which one
would feel uh that there's nothing
happening here here has to end in a draw
and then out of nowhere you would
squeeze out a win and that went on and
on against the best in the world that
Magnus was able to get those wins which
is what established him as one of the
greatest end game players of all times
uh when you're playing against somebody
like that with that kind of a repetition
and you can still hold your own still
not give up Winston putting up this kind
of a defense a young player
hold on to show the kind of talent
that's there and just how strong
the German player is
so talented and he's worked with Peter
leco for many years and it's clear that
he is improving as a chess player and he
I feel like has not been playing as
frequently as the other teenagers that
we see in this tournament because he
wasn't School uh you know he kind of a
little quiet for stretches of time but
then in the fide Grand Prix he made his
presence felt even though he was one of
the definitely one of the youngest one
of the lower rated players in that event
and he of course he just just was
shining as bright as ever in the world
rapid Championship where he got that
silver medal just under a month ago so
he is he's peeking he is ascending but
right now we look at this position we
look at his opponent it's Magnus Carlson
with the black pieces we have a cut off
King and we might have a rook G5 takes
G2 and this Pawn becomes a passer or
this King might go back at some point
towards the queen side and use the other
pass Pawn it's just so much to figure
figure out for the Long Haul it's not a
one move thing it's just where do you
place your pieces if you're a Vincent
timer he doesn't seem certain because
how could he it's not actually obvious
where the pieces should go
and they are in their fifth hour of play
there is energy involved stamina
involved and definitely Winston has to
be on top of everything to be able to
defend this one and even then would it
be possible it's always difficult to say
he's given a check on F4 so forcing
magnets to take a decision does he want
to go towards the king side or again
march with E6 and towards D6 the F7 Pawn
needs to be kept defended so it's
between King G6 and King E6 magnus's
previous move of getting the king to F6
I think he still wants to keep the King
on the king side so I won't be surprised
if he takes the call to go to G6
I think you're right just because he has
cut off this King he's brought his King
back towards the king side King G6
looked like the best choice now this
Rook would likely slide back somewhere
on the fourth rank I'm not sure if it's
C4 because you would love to get behind
the pawn we've been talking about that
and Magnus did just play Kingdom G6 uh
but we were just talking about this Rook
G5 this is a big problem you are losing
that pawn if you want to avoid losing it
you push the G4 but this is the great
thing about having double pawns is once
one captures there's a second one that
can just replace it and then we have two
let's turn that into a green Oh wrong so
there it is those are green pawns
because they're going to seek greener
pastures go and promote you can't stop
both of them and this is just a winning
end game for black
this is the dream for black right to
solve the problem of the double bonds
and create another passer and that would
be game over that's the whole big plan
here that Magnus has Vincent will not
make it easy instead of going Rook C4
and allowing this he goes Rook A4 so
keeping the pressure on the A5 Pawn
again answering our question that yes
he's okay giving up the G2 Pawn if he
can grab hold of the A5 Pawn so Rook G5
he's just going to ignore it and come to
E3 with the King say you take on G2 I'll
take on A5 I'm happy with it
yeah he also might play Rook A2 he has
that available to him but that's such a
passive defense so I'm with you Tom you
don't want to sit passively here and
just what is White's next turn that's
one of my big questions right now
um you if you move your Rook back
anywhere I'm gonna push my H Pawn that's
what I'm dying to do because one of the
winning techniques is to win the G2 pawn
and then promote your H Pawn so I would
love to get my Pawn on H4 bring my king
up to H5 and maybe even push my Pawn to
H3 just to disconnect the white Pawn so
if you need to keep your Rook on the
fourth rank something like Rook C4 would
be a logical next choice so I'm just
gonna make a waiting move I'm gonna pass
with F6 and Rook C4 just to bring the
Rook over here now what if I just go
Rook to G5
I mean at some point Rook G5 is just
going to be good I could start with Rook
G5 I'm just trying to figure out why
it's planned because if you go back here
and I go H4
I think I'm going to be able to do what
I've been talking about and bring my
king in
that's a good question that instead of
just thinking about what we want to do
to ask your opponent what is your
waiting move to keep everything intact
so you're mentioning the move F6 and I
don't believe that Winston can let go of
the problem of attacking A5 and
defending H4 which brings me to the
option of instead of let's say after F6
I'm Not Gonna Let You Go H4 and let you
go Rook G5 so easily putting all this
pressure what if I just move my king
Robert what if I keep everything as is
and say I'll go King D2
okay but then I'm gonna go Rook G5 and
now I have to watch out for this Pawn
and I see our eval bar again goes on to
drop so that means that King E3 and
giving up the G2 Pawn taking up the A5
Pawn is perhaps not going to be enough
to defend this position
just go H4 here and you just want to
push a pawn to H2 so if you defend
passively you could bring your Rook
behind your pass Pawn as well but I
don't think that's necessary you can
bring this King up to say G5 and you're
going to play H3 and King H4 if the Rook
has to sit on H1 I think you're just
gonna get zuke's Wong at some point
where I can make some kind of H5 just a
waiting move and if your king goes over
to D3 the black king will infiltrate in
the near future Rook G3 Pawn H3 King H4
and so on so as we get back to the live
position between these two we did see
Magnus start with Rook G5 and perhaps
the move order doesn't truly matter
we're just showing the plan for black
you can play F6 next after Rook A2 the
biggest difference I would say is that
the white king can start approaching the
uh kingside pawns so you've released
controlled the file that's the one bit
of good news if you're thinking about it
from Vincent's perspective
well magnets can also be key right he's
made to move Rook G5 and he wants to see
if Vincent will realize that he can't
trade the G2 Pawn for the A5 pawn and
actually defend it because Winston might
have this idea that I'll move my king
just the way I was thinking that he
could give up the G2 Pawn pick up the A5
Pawn but that's not good enough to
defend the position so Vincent needs to
accurately right now play the move
roketu Magnus will always have the
option to slide back to E5 and continue
from there or he could decide to play H4
next the problem with Rook G5 and let's
say white goes Rook A2 here and you
immediately play H4 is the line that you
were pointing out that now white has
time to come over with the king king E3
King F4 is just not as strong if the
King was cut off on D3
mm-hmm yeah you want to keep that King
as far away as possible and if this King
can just walk back to F2 that actually
gives white good chances to hold the
Rook will then come back to A4 attack
this Pawn over here and yeah this Pawn
stuck in place no other progress
immediately on the king side so Magnus
takes that sip of water and he's gonna
need to figure it out after Rook A2 are
there other options here I'm trying to
figure it out you can of course go right
back to E5 and cut the king off if you'd
like but what else is available to him
as I believe that the king would like to
Sprint back to F2 and maintain the
status quo
well right now Winston is still having a
thing so he's not sure if he wants to
fall back with the Rook defend the pawn
or give it up and try to activate his
rook and these are difficult calls to
make this is a difficult decision to
take we got the eval bar again pointing
Us in the right direction but when
you're playing a game and you've got no
idea in these Rick Pawn endings it can
be very tempting to just try to simplify
things get the king to E3 give up G2
pick up A5 and hope for the best but
that would be a disastrous path for
Winston right now he needs to figure out
he needs to evaluate correctly at his
best chance is indeed to drop back with
the rook and keep the G2 Pawn alive
yeah it's not going to be pleasant at
all it's going to be a very difficult
and long task for him because Magnus has
plenty of time on the clock nothing is
going to be settled quickly so why don't
we head back to our bird's eye view real
quick just to see how all of the games
are progressing
and we have three remaining including
the Magnus Carlson game with Vincent
kymer top right it looks like a check
was given on the seventh Rank by dingley
Wren so he went for Rook C7 check in
that position he's not getting
checkmated and in the bottom right we
have Jordan Von Forrest Richard Port
still no real progress between those two
active pieces for white uh immediately
some of white pawns can be captured but
we'll see how this one continues and we
are going to take a break here will
return for the finish line of the second
round of the 2023 Tata steel chess
tournament
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
January and Vicon say the Netherlands
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun and look at
the intense focus on magnus's face what
a performance it has been
once again vikon Zay starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th Tata steel
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back the world's number one looks to
further cement his legacy in this event
and the game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
championed here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
have the winner of the tournament and it
is Jordan Fanfare winning the dramatic
Armageddon
don't leave out those poised to capture
their first Tata title
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom
Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps
the Dutch referred to Tata steel as The
Wimbledon of chess for 85 years and
running this tournament continues to be
steep in Prestige and Legacy and does so
again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mine Brendan it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament and it
starts right now
are you trying to get your friends into
chess now you can challenge any iOS user
with the chess.com iMessage app your
friend doesn't need an account just tap
and play text an old friend a family
member or your crush who you have no
idea how to talk to head over to
go.chess.com iMessage or use the command
message in chat to learn how we are back
here at the second round of the Tata
steel chess tournament 2023 we still
have a few games remaining in the
Masters Tournament it's been an exciting
round thus far we had Anish giri with a
great Victory a smashing success against
goo cash so Tanya three draws in that
Victory with three games still left in
session that was clearly the game of the
round so far and I'm not just saying it
from the result perspective but also
because of the attacking chess that
anise showed he sacrificed the night he
sacrificed The Rook he went for the most
combative move Queen F5 I think that was
just a beautifully played out attack
after the inaccuracy that gokish had
from the opening never gave him a chance
to come back uh so big win there by
Anish after missing well some chances at
least against uh in the first round in
his game against Fabiano caruana so
Anish currently with the only win in the
match but it looks like that's not how
the day will end because Magnus Carlson
also continues to grind down the Rook
Pawn ending that we've got uh let's take
a look on our all our boards that we've
got going on right now bottom left we
can see Magnus slowly trying to make
some progress and we were talking about
this position we've seen it before
Magnus testing Vincent a little bit here
then a little bit there eventually the
pawns will start moving because it's the
only way to make progress in the
position I love your idea of going F6
trying to get H4 and eventually Robert
we'll see how that goes meanwhile Jordan
van Forest has been hanging on to this
game for a really long time and we
haven't really checked it out on our big
analysis board maybe we can't go in a
little bit and take a deeper look at
this and see if there are any chances at
all for Richard rapper in this one
well he would love to bounce back with a
victory here in round two after he
stumbled against Notre back Abdus atarov
late in a rook end game that was very
tough for him but in the current
position he can capture a Pawn on H4
that is hanging but so is this Pawn on
B5 now the good thing is this is an
outside pass pawn it means it's harder
to get to the good thing for white on
the other hand is you have a bishop a
bishop is a long range piece that can
cover against a past Pawn from very far
away a knight can't do the same so if
this B5 Pawn is captured and then the
Rook moves back and this Pawn starts
rumbling up the board that could spell
some trouble for a night as compared to
a bishop but I mean Tanya we look at
this position right it's going to be
even material both sides will have a
pass Pawn where could those winning
chances come from do you think
I'm not gonna decide who will have the
better chances you're asking where the
winning chances are the winning chances
will either be with the H5 Pawn or the
B4 Pawn once these uh H and B pawns get
swapped I liked the line that you're
showing us Robert pick up that thought
on H4 it's what you you need to create
your own pasta let's say you go Rook
takes B5
and the good news here is that white
doesn't have a killer check at least a
discover check which gives black a
little bit of time to get the Knight
back into the game and start pushing his
own H Pawn Knight F3 or Knight G6 and
let's say you move the bishop give a
check I'll centralize my knight on E5
and now my H Pawn is save it safe it
will also roll down it will also go
rumbling down the board as you said H4
H3 coming in I'm loving black snide on
E5 I don't think Richard has anything to
worry here uh if anything white might
have to be slightly careful yeah I
actually just realized F4 hits a pin
piece for the king slides out of the pin
with an attack on the bishop on E3 and
yeah you're right that white would need
to be a little bit careful even in this
variation it looks like it should be a
draw by force I would imagine after this
sequence if you take this Pawn on E5 The
Rook takes on E5 and we just liquidate
the black king goes after the white Pawn
the white king goes after the black pawn
and all the pieces will be off the board
and that looks like equality so the
chances may be available for the players
Bishop E7 by the way played instead of
taking on B5 going after two separate
pawns so this is a bit of a mixed bag
both sides will continue here but
getting word that dingley Ren uh he is
in big big time trouble he needs to make
about 15 moves and only has a couple
minutes to do so so we talked about this
before Tony he was spending a lot of
time now it looks like he's down to his
final minute and he needs to find the
correct path
and meanwhile Parham has over 40 minutes
to figure this out as a defense as being
on the defensive side it's somewhat
easier for Parham because the moves are
kind of almost forced while ding needs
to find out where he can create his
chances H4 played defending the G5 Pawn
you want to match up the board but the
big question is what happens if black
just starts checking let's say you go
Rook to A6 check where are you hiding
with the King up here
and this feels like progress because now
if you go for the idea with the you
don't have time for rookie 6 Rook E7
because the pawns are way too advanced
King on 87 that's a nice spot for the
king
yeah and then it helps the pawns go up
the board some of the king is safe over
here looks like it could be checkmated
almost but not going to happen
um and I think many of these variations
it shows that the position is supposed
to be a drug with best play but best
play that's not easy let's say you make
a quiet looking move at Bishop E5 is the
pawn F4 because you have Rook F7 check
maybe there's helping the white pawns
move forward and that's not a very good
sign so
um I still don't envy parham's task but
he has played exceptionally well we left
off around here where that check
happened on C7 The Rook came to D7 he
put his Bishop on C3 and then once the
king went up he finally took this Pawn
so uh interesting by the way that Ding
didn't push the F Pawn like I think I
would have led with the F Pawn because
it creates checkmating threats against
the King on f8
it's definitely going to roll down the
board at some point one of the lines
that came to my mind is let's say H4 I
give a check on A6 you're happy with
your King on 87 looks really scary you
want to go G6 next and I go Rook A5
suddenly you've got to be a little
careful because hold on with that g Pawn
Robin if now you rush with G6 suddenly
those mating ideas that I was trying to
set up uh actually become a reality with
Rook H5 but you don't need to rush with
G6 and this is the moment that you can
also start thinking about getting your
f-pawn into the game F4 comes to mind
you want to go H5 next now that the G5
Pawn is defended uh it all looks still
everything to play for but they just
needs to take care of the clock I see
that he's got a couple more minutes now
okay he's up to three minutes I guess he
made a couple moves
um and he gained time on the clock so he
is doing okay at the moment on the clock
and some of his moves are actually quite
easy right playing uh if he gets a check
bringing his King away so I feel like
with three minutes and 11 seconds uh you
know he will be able to manage his clock
but Parham guy's got an eternity left
over 38 minutes just playing at a
lightning speed
close up of the clock 3 minutes and 11
seconds for ding parham's got a lot of
time to try and figure it is a difficult
end game for black he is going to try to
pose questions which are hardest to
answer for thing so perhaps going for a
check is not the smartest idea because
Rook A6 just makes things life easier
you know he just lets us out the move
King at seven so if not a check how else
the H5 Advanced Bishop D2 is not
possible because the Rook on D7 defends
that square so I can't run the G5 Pawn
either
that's right and that means the H Pawn
is going to keep making progress it
strides up the board F4 is available as
well you would love to play F5 F6 and
get that pawn all the way up so it's not
easy for Parham the good news is he has
so much time to work through the
position it is within the drawing
territory and he you know he's got this
I feel like he has been pretty confident
throughout this game and the opposite of
how he was in game one where he's very
shaky a borderline lost at some point
but in this one you know he had an
advantage with black he let it slip but
he's never fallen into losing territory
and that's really important when you're
playing someone like dignity Rent
he's fighting this one out he's been
fighting for a long time trying to keep
his chances alive uh and that's the
status quo that we are in right now
going to be interesting to see if Parham
decides to give a check if not I think
ding wants to push on with that F Pawn
and the H Pawn at some point you have to
try to displace the king from G6 and I'm
seeing someone from our chat said ding
shows a really high level play in this
tournament I couldn't agree more with
that I think so far round one against
with the black pieces a brilliant win
there from start to finish the game that
was us picking up that sacrifice in the
end Rook takes E4 finishing the game in
style and then today however this game
ends even if Parham manages somehow to
save this one it's been a ding show so
far
yes it has indeed and I think some of
the other players in the field would
like Parham to hold this game they don't
want to see ding run away with a couple
wins to start because uh you know he is
not going to slow down it's very
difficult to stop dingley Ren Magnus
Carlsen and others of course will have
their chance at him across the board but
a laser focused dingly Ren is looking to
win his second game in a row but if we
zoom out back to the Magnus Carlson game
uh quickly just because I was seeing
that in that one
um we can actually analyze for a second
uh he did in fact bring his Rook back to
the e-file so he went Rook G5 The Rook
went back to A2 and he realized his
mistake that he doesn't want to allow
this King to run back to the king side
so he goes Rook back to E5 Vince I'll
gladly repeat please let's make a draw
three-time repetition no Pawn to F6 and
it's kind of like a zuk Swang here
because if the Rook leaves the fourth
rank somewhere then goes H4 if the Rook
stays on the fourth rank here you lose
your control of the a pawn so The Rook
C4 Rook G5 you're gonna play Rook C2 to
defend but now the a pawn is free to run
the H Pawn is also free to run you know
the Rook on A2 was better situated here
A4 you can bring your Rook behind your
pass Pawn at long last and that means
the black king will then walk up the
board
and you were pointing out this idea of
F6 Robert it has happened uh and the
whole point as you mentioned is to keep
the king cut off and eventually make
progress with the King side pawns uh not
waiting for that to happen Vincent makes
the move G3 so he has taken a committed
decision of pushing that pawn but the
problem with this move is that now after
Rook G5 it's impossible to defend G3
with the Rook anymore you don't have
rookeru so you will have to go into
positions where you trade the a pawn for
the g-pawn and we weren't happy with
that no and I don't think this is gonna
be very happy either because this Pawn
goes up to H4 and the very important
thing is you cannot get your Rook behind
the pawn you would love active defense
but there's this silly little Pawn on H6
that is blocking the rook's path and if
you go King F2 thinking that you're
gonna stop the pawn with your king first
The Rook goes back to G5 The Rook of
course can't take the Rook has to come
back to A1 and then the King goes to H5
so I'm trying to go H3 bring my king up
to H4 and Slither my way in and if you
go over H1 to stop the Pawn's progress
then this Rook goes to the other side of
the board Rook A5 I would like to give
you a check over here and then I can
eventually kind of get you in a little
bit of a zoo song Maybe Rook G3 is also
possible because at some point the king
will likely have to move otherwise you
play F5 F4 and H3 but it's just a matter
of time before Black's pawns make the
progress they need
first the white skin was cut off on D3
now it's cut off on F2 and Black's King
is going to help in the advance this is
this is looking like it's gonna get
scary for uh for Vincent but also he
couldn't sit still after F6 it's
impossible and we see Magnus clear out
the board a little bit you were
mentioning that Magnus realized his
mistake when he went rip G5 comes back
with the Rook to E5 to cut off the king
but Robert I don't think it's about that
in these kind of end games and with
these top players they always want to
test their you know you make a move you
know you can always repeat but you want
to keep putting maximum pressure Winston
very well could have not defended the G2
Pawn but just asking constant questions
you keep asking questions and eventually
uh that's how you win a game that's how
your opponent crumbles Under Pressure I
think Magnus very well realizes that he
has to play F6 he's gone for a G3 on the
board as we see and now uh the idea of
sliding back with the Rook is what we're
expecting yes going after the Pond
Spring free a passer on the H file and
Magnus is trying to make sure that that
will be winning it looks like Magnus he
did play Rook to G5 Vincent in all
likelihood would bring the king back
around trying to stop the H Pawn uh it's
a very odd Pawn structure you don't
typically see double isolated H Pawns in
an end game uh but it is looking very
promising for Magnus Carlson and he
would like to catch up to players like
dingley Ren and also in each Geary
because Anish won his game and after his
game actually he spent some time taking
questions from the media so while we
have a moment while the players here are
thinking about this end game let's take
a listen to Anish gears answers
finally how highly does this game rank
on your list of favorite games played
here in vacancy well I mean I've played
many many uh satisfying games and I can
say also many bad games I just played
many games like I say so uh
um yeah no it's it's a great uh great
feeling to win this way and I'm also
always proud to show some preparation uh
even though now in Rapid and Bliss it's
less of a thing but still you know I'm
always happy to get preparation
especially when it works out it looks
pretty nice and I think it was a very
nice idea I was very happy with it with
this Rook C2 idea it's a very cunning
one and it's really not on the surface
and I was really happy to um you know
not only to show it but also that it led
to a nice picture
any scary there and I think wanted to
change his cards to say very happy
because I'm pretty sure he said he was
very happy on numerous occasions and
well Tanya he should be he just won a
really nice game he showed good
preparation with this Rook C2 lift over
the e-file and he won a beauty in the
end
and he pointed out that it's not a
surface idea it's not a first thought
idea there is a lot of depth to it and
this is exactly what you and I were
talking about in that moment Robert that
uh you know it looks harmless you put
the Rook on C2 get it to E2 Shuffle
around with your queen it literally five
moves later and Anish giri was
demolishing okay she was completely
winning it all worked out to Perfection
and when you put in that kind of work
you come up with this little this little
opening idea and it turns out so well it
is a moment to be proud and in his words
to feel happy about
yeah I mean really an excellent game
that's one to be proud of and he said
he's played so many games in vikingsay
that you're gonna have great games
you're also going to have poor games but
it seems to be the case that he has many
more good games than bad because he's a
five-time runner-up and I know a lot of
people give him grief about not winning
tournaments but to get second place on
five different occasions against these
types of fields that is an exceptional
performance I mean he should be proud of
that and maybe this will be the year
that he breaks through and wins first
place
he has so far shown quite inspired chess
in round one and round two it could very
well be Anish guricia we've seen him
make it to the tie breaks but
unfortunately lose out on that talking
about results we do have a result on one
of our boards Richard rappo
yeah they drew their game one ends in a
draw
yeah no surprise there we saw the rook
and minor piece end game uh the players
you know they split the point and for
Jordan Von Forest he should be happy
with the result but not with his play I
mean after getting a tough position he
happened to play well I just think two
times he's had the white pieces at two
times he's been worse with the white
pieces that's not what you want and even
if he won both games I think he still
would be a bit flustered by the fact
that he is not getting good positions
but one player who is getting good
positions is Magnus Carlson in the game
one against levonne aronian he had an
advantage that didn't amount to a win
but here in game two against Vincent
kymer well he's up two Pawns in a rook
end game looking really good
and he's gone for the idea Rook G5 has
been played on the board and now that
the g-pawn cannot be defended there will
be a trade with the A and the g Pawn uh
which Vincent cannot avoid King E3
played Magnus just having a little thing
uh he can't really allow King F2 so I am
expecting him to go Rook G3 because once
White's King makes it to uh F2 then it
just becomes all the more difficult to
break uh that position Magnus captures
the Jeep on Winston will go on to pick
up the A5 Pawn we were mentioning the
move H4 keeping everything under control
and then slowly the F Pawn will advance
the king moves forward and that is
progress Magnus mentioned after his game
against Lev where he did have I wouldn't
call it
a bigger huge Advantage but he had a
pull in the position Lev defended it in
a creative Manner and managed to draw
that game Magnus mentioned that he feels
he's not in his best shape but today's
game and technique definitely shows a
refreshed Magnus and the long games have
a positive effect on you because you
feel that you're ready for the grind
you've got the energy you can convert
difficult positions uh winning with the
black pieces that's a huge confidence
boost and Magnus with his secret recipe
of Watts I think that's what worked for
him Robert last evening he was there for
the AFC game
and uh we've seen him do that oftentimes
uh during tournaments to go watch some
football uh while we were in San
Francisco he went and saw hockey as well
as basketball then went on to win the
tournament yesterday it was uh
I'm gonna butcher the name but I don't
know how exactly you pronounce it I know
that in Dutch it's it's a hux but uh
yeah I'm not sure a hawks or iaks
but I remember that God no no you go
ahead sorry I was gonna say that I do
know that it's named after a character
from Homer's Iliad and when we start
when we started that I started a bit of
literature when we started that it was
iax but I always thought that in the
Netherlands uh it's a hux but maybe I'm
wrong no I'm American I don't know
anything right come on don't ask me for
pronunciation and things like that
that's too much to ask for me but uh it
is clear Magnus Carlson rejuvenated he
went to that match uh he got a jersey he
received one from the team that was
really cool to see because Magnus has
transcended the game of chess he's
become a you know a figure right he's a
person of popular interest and it's
great to see him you know loving the
game of football he loves basketball he
loves hockey and well he loves chess and
will continue to perform well in the
Chess World but he's not the only one
playing right now he is facing off
against Vincent kymer also you know
still going is dingly Wren against
Parham magsudu so Magnus and Vincent
have reached move 60. so let's go and
check in with dingly Wren and parm see
what move number they are on and as I
pulled it up they've only made 50 moves
so dingley Ren he has a few minutes
remaining on his clock uh he's just
pushing his pawns up the board but only
a couple minutes for him and he has 10
moves to make or eight moves I should
say now
and this is what we keep talking about
right even though it's classical and you
got so much time to start with the clock
really does count and in this kind of a
critical position where the difference
is massive it's the difference between a
whole point or just drawing this game so
uh thing down to just three minutes on
his clock can he find the precise way to
move forward F4 has been played to me
just comes across as a position that's
equally hard to defend for Parham so
it's not just ding who has to be
accurate but Parham as well he can't
just allow the pawns to March forward uh
F5 F6 King coming to G6 it would just be
game over just give white three moves
and blacks busted yeah you're
threatening checkmates you're trying to
promote that if the King goes to G6 the
H Pawn can go and the reason why the
king is on H6 is because just a moment
ago The Rook checked it off of the G
file and you want us active of a king as
possible and what's interesting thing
Tanya is that if you give a check on G7
first and the King goes to G6 and then
you give a check on C6 over here the
king can actually go safely to H7 and
there's no mate because the H6 scores
under White's control and if you think
you're getting clever with a move like
Rook to C7 you're actually not
threatening anything whatsoever and
after Rook check the King has to slide
up to the seventh Rank and if you make a
move like King to E7
then at this point oh they're making
moves uh at the moment but they I was
gonna say that the white king and Rook
are too active with those pawns but we
have seen the move
Rook C7 check played after the king went
to H7 so it's now time to bring the king
to G6
that's it just on Q Robert as
otherwise that would be a repetition one
too much he's gone for King G6 and after
Rook to C6 he just wants to step back
with the King to F5
and often what players do is they repeat
a little bit especially if they're in
time trouble so Rook C6 check was played
if this isn't a three-time repetition he
might do it just to gain more time param
has an eternity the clock isn't parham's
issue uh for dingley Ren it could be so
King to H7 just repeating another time
makes sense you can also just slide his
King back to F5 and the problem with
King F5 is how do those pawns push up
the board you're block hating your own
Pawn from getting to F6 and what white
does not want to do is love this bishop
to sacrifice the self for a couple pawns
because that would likely just result in
a drawn end game so you want to keep the
pawns close to each other and have the
king help them out
you're right it's just been it's yeah
it's been repeated just once so he very
well could just go backing at seven uh
gain some more time and then come back
to eight six because if you move back
with the King uh it does complicate the
matters a little more
but
it's still looking complex still ding
having a think of what he wants to play
which goes on to show he's not very
confident of his plan currently
it's not easy to know what to do because
King F5 you see that move and I can play
H6 next am I gonna bring my king back to
G4 I try to push the F Pawn but if this
king is on G4 and you push to F6 the
black Bishop can just take there and we
know that those end games are going to
be a draw so King goes back to H7 just
repeat again King can go to G6 here
oh it goes to H6 what does
it's a rook C6 he wants G6 I guess
because King hm would be a three-time
repetition
um
Bishop G7 you can go King G6 King at
seven so
yes yeah the king is is sliding away so
this check King HF would be a draw by
three-time repetition but this is not
Checkmate because the king slides away
and you see the oh King goes up to H7
what am I talking about it's just
terrible move I'm like it's I thought it
was like almost check man the king had
to run back but no the king runs forward
and we are seeing that G6 played and
Tanya the King on f8 Pawn on G6 we're
coming to d8 at some point
I feel like ding is getting closer and
closer and the eval bar is doing uh
pull-ups right now just like up and down
it's like a bench pressing
this has been such a marathon fight and
a marathon game of footing you know he's
had the edge throughout he showed some
great opening preparation in this one uh
sacrificing on F7 uh allowing that
Knight to get trapped on G5 and just
really nicely played middle game the end
game technique that he's shown and I
just wonder you know Robert even in the
previous game with the black pieces that
he had against kokesh he showed great
opening prep
how much of the leave actually comes
from his ideas for what he wants to play
on the world championship match because
you really want to save the best for
that
yeah I think you kind of answered it
there in a way that you don't want to uh
if you're learning new openings you need
experience in those openings but you
also don't want to let your opponent
know that you are playing them so when
Magnus Carlsen playing against the on
the palm machine he started playing the
Catalan more and more but imagine if
he'd start playing the Catalan in the
tournament beforehand then John's team
would say wait a second we need to study
that so A few things are helpful knowing
somebody's opening but also knowing
somebody's team of seconds that's why
they often are kept private because if
you knew that Magnus is working with
Daniel dubov which was quite public you
think all right Catalan dubov is one of
the best in the Catalan he plays all the
time has so many creative ideas now I
know what to expect so as little
information given as possible is
probably the best thing I would imagine
and I wonder for Jana Palmer she if he's
just gonna sit out tournaments until the
championship that way he can work on his
preparation maybe learn a new opening
things like you did the Petrov for the
match against Magnus he probably will be
looking at new stuff for dingley wren
one thing's for sure at the start of the
day when dingler and moved the King's
Pawn as the first move and this was a
bit of surprise for all of us it's not a
move that he's never played before but
it's not something that he employs as
much as the Queen spawn opening or with
one C4 so this uh definitely gives an
idea to janapamnishi's theme that they
need to look at E4 they need to look at
these lines as well and take it
seriously if ding has employed it in the
Tata steel Masters it very well could be
a weapon that he'll go on to use at the
world championship match
that's right and so I ding he's pushed
his Pawn up to G6 I'm wondering what
parham's even going to do here I think
this individual move could make or break
his game uh the move F5 looks like it's
happening next so Rook C5 comes to mind
to stop it but I also am acknowledging
that this Rook is going to cause some
problems for Black by giving a check or
playing Rook D7
uh Tanya this is just so difficult
I have a tricky idea here that black
could perhaps try let's say I make a
little move like Bishop B2 you know you
mentioned that you want to go F5 and I
want to try to set a trap if you do that
and the point is that I want to go check
Bishop C1 now that the diagonal is
cleared force your king to eight seven
I'll give another check with my Rook
Rook C7 force your king to h8 and
suddenly my Bishop will jump back to B2
and I see her valbar seems to say white
is fine but I would be worried for white
hair
yeah it looks like Checkmate the King
has no moves but you you have G7 and
after Bishop takes G7 you have King H7
and your king runs away to the square
there's no good Discovery all of White's
pieces on light squares that's a dark
Square Bishop that's a miracle and after
Rook takes G7 the fact that this isn't
completely winning for black is shocking
so
I guess Rook F7 is a mate in one so you
were mentioning Rook d a check
yeah just to try to save the day because
if King goes to F7 then I check and take
it if the King goes to E7 well I don't
really know what to do would probably
Chase your Bishop around and then I Rook
B7 check okay that's clear it's very
fortunate that black uh is not winning
right you know white is almost lost here
all right so well at least at the
current position a black plays Bishop B2
it stops your threat of going F5
immediately which was very annoying so
how do you make progress after Bishop B2
because let's say you go King 87 I still
have Rook C7 check
right so the king cannot make progress
up here but what if I just use my Rook I
go Rook d8 check
I'm just kicking your kingdom you have
only one square and now I will have King
H7 at the right moment so I can play
Rook B8 just to attack your Bishop gain
that Tempo and I'm trying to play King
H7 and then push my Pawn up the board
very tricky stuff and you're absolutely
right white has made so much progress in
the position well instead of going
Bishop B2 he returns with the bishop to
F6 so still trying to keep it compact
trying to make sure that white isn't
able to push too much ahead and dig not
going for F5 goes Rook A3 so he really
wants to give a check on it
yeah he sees a check he likes a check
and that looks really strong because if
the King has to go to E7 the white king
goes up to H7 the pawn to H6 the next
Pawn to G7 you're just getting a queen
and from the start of this kind of end
game whereas a bishop for a handful of
Pawns it looked unpleasant for param to
defend and what move does black play
here that's the big question because
rookie a check King H7 H6 G7 looks very
obvious to Me Maybe Rook C8 but I always
hate passive defense because this Rook
could come up to A7 which already
threatens to win a piece threatens G7
check and King H7 all sorts of stuff uh
this just doesn't look fun for Parham if
he survives this I will be unbelievably
impressed
it's looking more and more difficult now
now that white has managed to push the
pawns up the board the King on A6 some
really great technique there by dingler
and and I think the kind of form and
quality we're seeing in this game and
his first game it comes from the work
that he's been putting in for his match
as well uh a really good fighting
technique in this one Rook A3 a nice
move found pretty quick down to four
minutes but he looks confident of his
chances uh now Robert and I think this
one is going to take home meanwhile I've
got my eye out on the other game as well
the only other game remaining where
Magnus Carlsen is trying to squeeze out
the win from that Ripon ending for a
long time he has been having the upper
hand in the game throughout and this is
what we have this is the idea that you
were talking about uh for quite a while
with the pawn on H4 Black's King
advancing on H5 we can see that on the
bottom left of the screen and maybe we
can pull that up because we see our eval
bar indeed black has made massive
progress in the end game
that's right because the white king this
has been the theme of the ending has is
cut off if you're King F2 you stop the H
Pawn from going because the Rook needs
its defense but you can move your Rook
Back The Rook doesn't have to stay on G3
let's go back Rook G7 and H3
H2 bringing the king up behind it that
seems to be the threat so if you bring a
rook all the way back still H3 if you're
bringing a rook over here King H4 and
it's only a matter of time before I kick
your king away bring my king in push my
Pawn bring my Rook to the last Rank and
you're not gonna be able to stop my Pawn
from promoting
we were talking about technique and
what's the way forward in this end game
uh I guess Magnus showed us the way
forward as we were expecting knowing
that this end game should be winning for
black uh is one thing but then proving
it over the board and he's it looks like
he's on his way to do that
and he figured this out all on his own
right he started this end game uh better
of course with a couple extra pawns but
it was really a case of two separate
extra pawns one on the a file and then a
doubled H Pawn and I think a lot of
people would think it was Rook G6 here
uh maybe just keeping all the pawns
protected and doesn't make a difference
where the Rook went via G7 and G6 but
what I was trying to say was he
recognized that you know double I say
pawns typically are bad but because of
the pawn structure the way it was from
White's positioning
um if I just pop that position up just
very quickly uh when we got here I think
that if this Pawn were like on H2 or H3
it'd be a bit of a different story
because then you just keep your King
close to the pawns for White and the
black pawns can't go forward and
challenge The Pawn One Pawn here stops
two of Black's pawns but when you have a
Pawn on the G file you're essentially
trying to trade one and then you have a
second passer behind it so that's the
bad part it of double pawns and that's a
thing of the past now because right now
the Bell ponds are excellent Rook A5
check well hard move to predict you only
have one move because your king is stuck
Rook G5 played H3 next king H4 to follow
the the rest of this game is
straightforward
I think what white wants to do to try to
make it a little difficult for black to
advance with the King Robin is to place
the Rook on A4 let's say you go Rook G5
I think we've got to move already he's
gone
H3 and at some the problem is that if
you go Rook A4 they're still H2 and
you've got to come all the way back with
your Rook to defend the pawn from
queening so you really can't stop the
black king from advancing that's right
the King goes up the board so we saw
instead Rook A3 and F4 Rook G2 check I'm
guessing a handshake will be happening
pretty soon because the white king is
cut off uh after Rook G2 check King F3
King H4 is still good there it is
there's the handshake Magnus Carlson
gets his first win in the 2023 Tata
steel Masters and Tanya it was an
excellent display of endgame technique
what a big fight a marathon game and a
wonderful conversion there by the world
champion showing why he is known as the
greatest end game player of all times
once again proving that he indeed has
the best technique in the game Vincent
tried his best
uh kept on playing played resourcefully
but it was just never enough I think
from the very beginning Magnus got a big
Edge and when he went into this respawn
ending he believed that it was indeed
winning with the black pieces and went
on to prove a bit and with that Magnus
uh wins his first game Winston loses his
first game of the tournament but there's
so much to take away from it playing
Magnus is never easy there we see
Winston he's definitely disappointed
it's been a long hard day
yeah he was worse pretty early on and he
tried his best but Magnus Carlsen too
powerful in that end game and for
Vincent kymer it's just you know one of
those days where you're playing the best
chess player of all time uh what are you
gonna do about it it's frustrating
especially because he had the white
pieces I think if he had the black
pieces Tanya he'd feel like all right
Magnus played well he had the first move
advantage that happens but the fact that
he had the first move Advance himself
and really from an early stage it felt
like Magnus was able to take advantage
with that D takes C4 Pawn B5 and making
progress from there but we do have just
that one game remaining between dingley
Ren and Parham maksudu so Tanya what's
your call here is ding Loren going to
win this game or is parham's defense
going to hold
I'm calling this a denguin I'm calling
this a ding getting more and more tough
for Parham to keep things together in
this one uh it's not over yet and I
might be proven completely wrong and
then it's you know what am I even
talking about but as of now it does feel
that thing is in the right path Rook A6
attacking that Bishop where are you
moving with it Bishop G7 runs into King
87 you never have the option to go Rook
C7 after that because I have a check on
it so I'm not worried about sorry Rook
C7 and rookie check will win the game on
the spot so this is nothing to worry
about besides that if you don't uh
what's your Square you move somewhere
else I go F5 F6 yeah where is this
bishop going let's go to I don't know D4
you can play F5 F6 no but that there is
Bishop E3 so you have to be a little
careful actually Bishop D4 does run F5
does run into this idea that we looked
on earlier but there's F6 that's the
difference this works as well wow
amazing The Rook is perfectly placed on
A6 so he went all the way down to C3
with his Bishop here and you know he
probably was asking the same question
does it matter where my Bishop goes the
doll does the same thing and there are a
couple options here there's F5 uh for
white there's some kind of passing move
like Rook E6 or something and there's
King G5 a king H7 doesn't really make
sense because now Rook C7 check forces
the King right back so King G5 that
frees the path for the H Pawn and I'm
wondering which direction dingley Wren
will go
but King G5 you've got a again sedan and
look at all these checks with Rook C5 F5
Bishop D2 check where's your king
running I like this idea of the clear
line yeah let's just show that that you
know there is something to calculate
here there are a few checks I see our
eval box in advantage to White so it
probably all works out but Robert if in
our live board in the position that
we've got if F5 has a direct line works
I think it's time to go for it
yes and just to point out again Bishop
D2 King H7 Rook C7 it looks scary in
that other position because the King has
no squares but there is F6 with
threaten's Checkmate against the black
king it's an amazing position you don't
see some of this very often but the pawn
would block and threaten at the same
time so uh yeah F5 very interesting
choice because you're pushing a pass
Pawn forward and maybe it's time for the
black king to scoot on over to G8
because if you play F6
check maintenance one that would be a
shame
and Ding Dang getting a bit fidgety a
bit
ner croning low he needs to
need to go F5 might very well be
thinking of coming back with the King
opening up the way to go down with the H
Pawn but he needs to take a decision and
he needs to do it fast
and we have people rooting for dingley
Ren he has many fans around the globe I
think he earned many fans at the
candidates where uh he was just such a
kind person I mean he came in for the
interviews uh I was particularly
enjoying when he came in after his win
over Richard report and he was asking
about these crazy variations like why
were you even thinking about that he
just thinks about everything he is such
a strong player that's obvious with his
2800 plus rating but the way he just
calculates the game is fascinating and
extremely impressive
it's the only player in the world apart
from Magnus to be currently 2800 he's
reaching out and he has taken a decision
I've gone for Rook to A7 so a different
approach here by doing uh what he wants
to do is place his King on H7 and
threaten G7 so after King 87 G7 the game
will be over and that's his idea he
controls the seventh rank so that black
has no checks with Rook C7
so I think that means king G8 would be
the only move because just to show
Tanya's point if you make a move like
this then you go King H7 and the g Pawn
is about to promote so that would be uh
winning for white you see the Eva bar
reacting and agreeing so if that is the
threat then the King has to go to G8
that's the only way to stop the white
king from going to the H7 square but
then Tanya I think it's the second
option King to G5 Pawn H6 and there are
mating Nets against this King you want
to push your F Pawn as well it seems
that it's still within that drawing
territory but still feels very tough and
the best news of all for param is his
clock management has been stellar
but the best news for the ding fans is
that the 60 move control has been made
as well so they will get some additional
time on the clock which is why we see
him get up and leave the table he's made
the 60th move it's now time to just
freshen up get get your drink wash your
face start afresh you know you're close
to it but you still need to wrap it up
you still need precision and the thing
will get some extra time on the clock
he will and he's going to need to use it
wisely because a sudden Pawn push may
find your King checkmated on the spot
we're just talking about that the King
on G8 takes away this very important H7
Square the bishop's still covering the
length of diagonal if you ever push this
g-pawn you allow a check on the sixth
Rank and you'll drop this Pawn where it
was sitting so both players are gone
from their board right now they've
reached move 60 maybe they're you know
using the facilities washing their faces
just getting fresh because we're on the
final stretch of this game and while the
players they're going away from the
board I think we will do the same we're
gonna take a quick break because when we
come back it is the finale of this game
between dingly Wren and parmax Sulu in
the second round the Tata steel chess
tournament
laughs
dude it's impossible to not hear you
just breathing super loudly okay fine I
will hold my breath for three minutes
all right let's go okay let's go right
now just claw cap right here almost
there and you did it
what can you do for three minutes my
wife says not a lot but I can plank keep
that big butt down dude nice
two one you did it wow I feel better oh
yeah oh you were timing me yeah you were
in there for 30. oh man let's play some
chess and get some dinner let's do it
time lapse yeah okay you bring a clock
oh I left my clock at home dude you
idiot I told you to bring it let's just
go get somebody okay
oh
download the new chess.com clock app so
you can time yourself playing chess or
whatever other dumb stuff you and your
friends do
[Music]
around
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
just one game remains here in the second
round of Vikings steel chess tournament
2023 dingly ran with the white pieces
against para muksulu we've had two
decisive results a tremendous attacking
display from Anish giri and then
fantastic end game technique from Magnus
Carlson so Tanya we have four draws two
wins and now it remains to be seen if
this seventh and final game will have a
winner
and the two wins that we had were in
such different styles one with the white
pieces one with the black pieces the
Anish wind was just an absolute
bombshell of a game completely explosive
sang and then going for caucasius King
meanwhile Magnus Carlsen showing
impressive end game technique a marathon
of a game and eventually winning The
Rook Pawn ending to beautifully played
out games with in completely different
styles of chess
very very different indeed but the same
result when all is said and done and
dingley Wren has a chance to be the sole
leader if he is able to win this game
but Parham maxulu is not going to go
down without swinging he has a bishop
for three pawns and in this position you
need to get those pawns mobilized push
them up the board try to get a new Queen
but that's why parham's defensive task
you know what he's done is perfect he
has put his rook in contact with his G6
Pawn so if you ever want to push the H
Pawn you lose the g-pawn if you push
your Pawn to F5 you have created pawns
all on the light squares which means a
bishop can kind of dominate them and
that is a problem just to show this F5
uh well I guess it's Black's move first
but I'm gonna make some kind of random
move like Bishop B2 and if you go F5
then I think you can bring the bishop to
C1 The Rook controls this Square the
bishop controls the other and you're not
going to push your Pawn so what move was
played it isn't fact Bishop to B2 that
was parham's choice and he's waiting for
the pawn Bush to stop the pawns on the
dark squares
in position your pawns have advanced on
the board your Rook is on the seventh
Rank and you've made maximum progress
and meanwhile black has managed to find
a sort of a fortress making sure that
you can't Advance through the very last
line of defense yes you can get your
bonds onto the fifth Rank and a G6 Pawn
but you're not gonna get eight six in
you're not going to get F6 in uh and I'm
slightly surprised that ding's King has
fallen back to G4 from when we saw it
last the players think Robert maybe we
can just back up and see what happened
in these last few moves while we were on
a break
sure the king
had been on age six the problem with the
G6 and Bishop F6 played by parm covering
the d8 square The Rook went to A3 we saw
this point
Rook A7 so I'm looking at the eval bar
off the side of the screen that seems to
be a move that gave away a healthy
portion of the advantage it looks like a
pretty natural move but black put the
King on G8 to stop the white kid from
going to H7 the king went to G5 and
after this check he probably came back
to G4 so Tony I guess uh Parham would
have been okay seeing F5 because the
bishop checks on D2 and where is this
King escaping to You Can't Hide anymore
because if you go King F6 then this
bishop comes back to C3 King E6 runs
into Rook E5 and the F5 Pawn Falls so
the King has got no defenses at all uh
it it really does feel like a case of
making all the improvements but not
being able to cross over to the very
last hurdle that's right I mean it's so
close yet so far the King goes back to
G4 The Rook went to C6 The Rook just was
sliding over to D7 and after Bishop B2
it's dingly red on the clock he has 11
plus minutes remaining plenty of time
it's not like he's in any danger but he
doesn't necessarily have a plan and
that's the hard part because in an end
game when you have pawns against the
bishop you often want your pawns on the
same color as the bishop the reason why
is pawns well they attack and capture
diagonally so if your pawns are all on
light squares they're not going to help
your pawns push to dark squares so
that's where black with that dark Square
Bishop is able to contain those pawns by
playing Bishop C1 covering those very
important dark squares so you know what
the best move is Tanya G6 back to G5
that would be great but unfortunately
neither will the computer allow you to
make it and it is illegal so that's not
possible you can push the pawns we are
not gonna happen Robert uh but this does
look like Parham
has managed to create a sort of a
fortress in The Possession now we also
see the eval bar has dipped a little low
Advantage so that does goes on to show
that there are defensive resources in
the position the extra 15 minutes which
was the final time control has been
added to the clocks so tingling has got
10 minutes but it's going to be
frustrating Robert to play this kind of
a game you know you have a feeling that
you've done everything right you
sacrifice in the op in the middle game
right out of the opening play a
brilliant game you know you give up your
piece for for pawns you advance you make
progress but you're just not able to
convert it and that can be so
frustrating and right now dingler and
sitting alone in this playing Arena at
why can't say all the games are over
they're just uh not even a handful of
Spectators they have just a couple of
people in the playing Hall uh ding
trying to convert this one chess is a
lonely and he's feeling it right now
well Tyler how many Spectators do you
think are watching this game right now
good question I can see
a little behind the bar I would say
maybe
or
I don't have the answer but oh we do
know
quite a few I think
wait a second I see people sitting down
it looks like so I think we see four
people nope five people standing and
then there are a couple people sitting
there so it looks like seven eight at
the moment
and that's pretty awesome I mean this is
the sixth R of play and uh there are no
more games remaining that's our
tournament haul we remember at the start
of the day just how bustling it was and
just filled with people and energy and I
just won Marathon game remains
everyone's fun game they're off to
dinner probably to that Italian place we
keep bringing up in this little Seaside
uh Village uh in the Netherlands why
can't they and Parham and ding battling
it out in the comments of their game
so I cheated
um Tanya I looked it up I Googled
Italian restaurant Vikings a and it's
Tarantella that's the name of it that's
the one Rob it's some really great
memories there it is if by the way if
anyone from our chat ever finds
themselves in vacancy then definitely
check it out and you should go when this
tournament happens because it's such an
honor to even witness it's such a
celebration of Chess and then usually
all the chess players do go to that
restaurant to wind down to unwind
there's a lot of chatter there there's a
chess board set up usually to analyze
games and it just feels like there's no
such thing about Chess and I can't say
in January
no and a lot of the you know
accompaniments are free you know the
parking uh the you know atmosphere is
for the chess players so they want to
welcome as many chess players as
possible and it isn't just Dutch people
who go I think in the amateur sections
I've seen people from all over the globe
it really is a festival and it's the
closest that some people are able to get
to these Superstars the Magnus Carlsons
the dingley rents so it's really an
awesome experience because they're not
just watching a lot of these people are
playing so they are playing their game
they go up and look hey what's uh Magnus
doing over there they go back to their
board and then you go to the restaurant
because there are like five of them it's
pretty small uh town and you're eating
you know where you are and over there
are those super GMS so it's a really
nice atmosphere I think everyone is
quite peaceful there
I can agree more it's just a great event
to be a part of and right now of course
at the very end of the day we've got
just one game remaining uh but I can
imagine these two players being really
hungry right now and I'm not even
talking about points anymore
yeah I'm also very very hungry because
this broadcast started at 8 A.M Eastern
and now it's nearly 2 p.m and I have not
had food so a ding has to be careful is
what the feature chat said before it
says ding is the kindest GM
um I don't I don't know yeah I don't
know what the rankings are but uh you
know ding is very kind and I became a
dink fan of kittens when he requested a
regular chair instead of the thrones
that is very funny because I remember
those chairs they were out of control
they were massive
they really weren't I think that was
like a different one for each of the
players and it was really random but I
completely agree ding is indeed one of
the most modest and the kindest uh
guy this person not even just like not
even just amongst jazz players he's just
so humble and that's the one thing about
his personality that stands out and
makes it so easy to forget how strong he
is his willpower to fight it out till
the end is what we're seeing here right
now but Parham as well he's a really fun
guy to hang out with he's always jovial
he's always laughing cracking a joke uh
he's super entertaining and his chest
you know it's got that style it's got
that aggression in it and it's always
fun to watch him and be around him
and
our Parham loves basketball he loves rap
um you know how much time have you spent
around like do you know Parham
personally or is just from interviews at
tournaments
interviews with tournaments we played a
lot of tournaments together as well
where I've met him and uh yeah I met him
several times so it's and it's always
been fun to chat with him he's been to
India quite a few times for the Tata
steel rapid and Blitz as well he loves
playing here he really enjoys it he's a
huge crowd favorite in India by the way
uh simply because he's always laughing
and smiling and always makes time for
fans uh and that's always a nice uh a
nice quality he's all of 22 uh at 27 19.
that's that's a massive rating he's a
top player from Iran and his best finish
at wykanze was in 2019 and the
challenges where he finished seventh he
is a last minute replacement in this
year's Masters when yantry stuff Duda
had to withdraw due to personal reasons
of course happily stepped in which meant
that he's not coming with massive
preparation but he's come in with
eagerness to fight
for sure and he fought hard for his
country at the Olympia he gained a bunch
of rating points there
um you know I remember him I'm sorry to
say this but I remember him taking down
uh Hari Krishna in one of the later
rounds when he uh I think around 10
maybe they were on one of the High
boards so not to bring up bad memories
for your country please forgive me and
it seems like India has already forgiven
Parham and seems to love him but he had
some you know great results at the
Olympian and that helped him go from I
believe high 2600s now near 2720 and he
is on the upswing he is a very very
talented player and if he can draw
dingley around with the black pieces in
this game it would only help him
increase his rating further
increases reading and I'm sure that's
not even the main motivation for Parham
just the ability to play and the
opportunity to play against these top
guys in this Elite event he mentioned
that it's been his dream to be in by
Kansas to play the Tata steel Masters so
for him to have this opportunity just
means so much and here he is with the
black pieces playing this Marathon game
where he's been defending for the last
five and a half hours Robert and it
looks like he's getting closer and
closer to that half point
yes and now you know he has you know a
bunch of time remaining on his clock and
ding Loren that's all the time he gets
we are in the final time control so for
dingley Ren there's no more 15 minutes
or 15 minutes adds to the clock he needs
to find potential progress now and he's
not going to gain any more time except
for the 30 second increment that's a lot
right if he just makes a quick moves he
gains a few minutes that'll be nice for
him but you see ding the ren I think
he's bothered by the fact that he
doesn't see a win for himself I think
he's at this position it's like honestly
I think it's just a draw and he doesn't
really want to admit it especially
because he's had the advantage for so
long but that's what happens when para
maksudu plays excellent defense
this indeed has been a master class on
defending a difficult position at one
point it feels like white made so much
progress advancing the pawns and the
pawns were just going to overpower and
we're just too strong for black but
indeed what Parham had the plan was to
let it advance to a certain point after
which is when it gets really difficult
you let white get the maximum that they
can with the last line of defense cannot
be crossed and that's what we see Parham
has set up again let's just take a take
a look at why it's impossible or at
least it seems impossible currently for
white to make progress the G6 Pawn is
under attack so the H Pawn cannot move
forward you can't go 8-6 yet what you
can play is the move F5
and uh trying to defend the Jeep on to
push the H Pawn but that invites so many
checks and suddenly white skin loses a
lot of cover there are ideas with Rook
C4 and then Bishop C1 so instead finally
ding we're just two minutes left on the
clock repeats twice gains a little time
but he's got to have some idea now he's
got to change it up yes he gained a
couple of seconds but he's already spent
a lot on the clock
there's no real reason that he should
repeat the moves and make a draw on the
spot but I think it's quite clear he
knows this game is going to be a drawing
great defense from paramaksudu and the
best move I keep trying to do it I think
Dave will have an easier time doing it
is bringing the pawn back a square to G5
and you know in all seriousness if this
Pawn were on G5 you could push the pawn
up to F6 and this was the H6 and you'd
have the pawn protecting them both and
the King could sneak in so you lose out
a lot by having your Pawn on the
opposite color of the enemy Bishop on
one hand your pawns can't be attacked by
that Bishop but they can be slowed down
very easily as we've been seeing in this
position
it's a blockage it's a fortress you move
them you put them on the white squares
whenever you push a pawn to a white
square the black squares around it gets
weakened and now it's very difficult for
white to make progress I'm just
wondering if ding is actually just the
goodness moment because he played a
check and I think he played it twice and
now uh he again goes into a bit of a
thing
I wouldn't be surprised if he makes that
repetition he doesn't need to he can
move his Rook anywhere he can't possibly
lose this game unless he blunders a full
Rook or he somehow checkmates himself so
that's the good news which allows him to
prolong it but when you have respect for
your opponent as he does for Parham and
he understands that this game's not
going anywhere he might just say I have
a new game tomorrow I need to eat I need
to rest and then I need to go play round
three so of course preparation is
involved as well and yeah dingley ran
here it's not the look of somebody who
feels like they're winning
it's really not you can tell from the
body language here and
Robert I think we are going to see Rook
the eighth here and that would be a
check a repetition thing down to seconds
reaching out he decides not to repeat so
he's still fighting on I think he made a
king move he's gone King to G5 so the
game goes on
he goes King G5 I think
well checking the king allows the pawn
to push to F5 but he does it anyway and
if King H6
made his Bishop F6 to cover the
checkmate
oh it's
more interesting I think you've got
Bishop C1 so you don't want to intercept
the check with the pawn because that
last checks with the bishop so King 86
is the way to go as you're pointing out
king 86 played now Rook d8 is a mate in
one
right so that's why I was looking at
Bishop back to F6 uh to cover that
Checkmate we've seen positions like this
uh before in fact the bishop was on F6
earlier
let's just see let me see if I can find
that position because we might have
another repetition of moves just in a
different way yeah here
the bishop was on F6 but the Rook is on
C5 now whereas in this position The Rook
was on C6 so getting back to the game it
looks similar but if the King goes to H6
and the bishop to F6 The Rook is on C5
not C6 I think we have seen King it six
already by dinking it's it's on the
board
it is yes
he brings his King up and now Bishop F6
feels mandatory what else can you do
besides cover the square
this is most likely a draw now until
Parham messes up again uh I you know I
think it is most likely a jar but the
the second part of that until he messes
up again I don't think he messed up I
think he's shown intense defensive
technique in a very difficult end game
uh so it's been brilliant play by Parham
holding on one
yeah and I don't know what the again
means because it seems like he's
steadily held uh throughout this end
game he he did you know make some
mistakes right he had a better position
and now he's been defending a worse
position but since they got to this end
game it seems like he's played pretty
perfectly and Parham he is studying the
position he's moving quickly when he
feels really confident and knows what to
do but he doesn't want to blunder now
that we're a move 67 that would be a
true shame if he lost because he just
got checkmated he wasn't paying enough
attention
that would be a heartbreak of a moment
uh Robert it also comes down to how much
Parham believes that this position is
actually holdable you know we have the
eval bar guiding us again but Parham has
no idea and it can look like a really
position your opponents got a Pawn on G6
the King on 86 threatening a mate in one
uh it can look extremely scary so it all
comes down to whether Parham in his mind
realizes and knows that he's actually
set up the Perfect Defense
right and Rook C8 stops Checkmate Bishop
F6 stops that same Checkmate I'm not
sure there's any thing else to even
consider besides those two I I like Rook
C8 a bit less I would say because I like
the active Rook here and stops F5 but we
have shown that F5 isn't available even
after Rook to see it if you go F5 you
checkmated with Bishop to C1
I agree with you I would want an active
Rook but I'm just wondering after you
play Bishop F6 yes you defend the mate
on d8 what if white moves The Rook to B7
or to A7 and I'm still threatening a
mate on the background let's say Okay
seven and I'm going to go okay I think
at some point you have to come back with
your Rook to see it you've got to defend
the eighth rank with your Rook it's true
but I've kept your king out of G5 which
should probably be a good sign for black
and if you play G7 and Shadow King G6
and go for this mate you just saw the
evaluation bar uh go all the way down
here uh because in this position after
Rook C6
your king is getting checked
it may look
it may look like white is winning
because you're about to get a new Queen
but no I'm not going to move my king I'm
gonna go Bishop d8 not just check not
just stopping your check but in fact
check mate because the king can't go
back to G5 this is actually an amazing
position oh that would hurt that would
hurt so much that is a wonderful setup
actually to see that this meat is
possible nicely pointed out there uh
Robert just goes on to show the
unexpected tactical motives that
actually still exist in a position like
this
it's crazy you never absolutely crazy
you know take a position for granted you
need to be looking out every single turn
because that Checkmate is as unexpected
as unexpected gets and that would make
you cry on the spot so I think that
Parham he's got to play Brooks here
Bishop of six but he's doing the right
thing why does he need to make the move
in 30 seconds when he has 30 minutes on
his timer spend time be accurate double
check verify and that's how you play and
he has played Bishop F6
accuracy and precision you were talking
about Barham showing it he moves the
bishop to F6 uh wanting to keep the Rook
as active as possible for as long as
possible I also see a lot of our chat
now supporting Parham in his task to
defend this very difficult end game
let's go Parham was the message that I
saw last and it looks like he's taking
the energy from you guys
well dingley Wren you know he wants to
take all the energy away from Parham but
there's just too much of it I mean that
guy is energetic as I was saying he
loves rap He loves basketball he's
always going to bopping his head around
when he's playing an online speed chess
events and here he's defending perfectly
and where is he going to move his Rook
back to C6 I was wondering if that Rook
could have gone to F5 protecting the
bishop and attacking this Pawn but
instead he chose to defend with Rook C6
and we're talking about it this Pawn is
not going to be able to move and I think
that
well what is White gonna do now
can't move your king
Rick F5 was interesting but perhaps he
just thought that that would be a little
scary spot for The Rook uh because if we
just back up one move while the players
have a thing if you go if you do put
your Rook to F5 that might have just
given white the option to actually slide
with the rook and start threatening a
mate on the back Rank and then yeah
tricky on how you would want to defend
that King so I think Rook C6 just a lot
more natural that Parham has gone for
and white slides over in any case to A7
so not threatening Rook 8 and we're
expecting black to do the same defend
the eighth rank with the Rook
and dingley run barely over a minute on
the clock right now and he cannot
blunder after Rook C8 do not play G7 we
just showed it Rook C6 threatens bishop
d8 checkmate and if you get your king
away Bishop dates not Checkmate anymore
because King goes to F5 and Bishop D4
with check picking up the Rook on A7 so
that would be just so sad if you're
dingley Ren or a fan of his but I really
don't think he's pushing the G7 anytime
soon he's far too strong to make a one
move blunder like that
you push G7 calculate that you're
completely winning otherwise you just
don't commit to it with your King on 86
you know you're walking into fire
directly he's not going to do that I see
Parham reach for a move and it's not
what we were expecting Robert but it's
another way to defend and fight against
The Rook on V6 so that he can fall back
to d8 when white gives a check
that's right and look at this white king
it's out of squares so if you play Rook
A8 and Rook d8 happens and you trade the
king cannot Escape if you push G7 the
bishop goes to F6 and just grabs the
pawn and if you play F5 the bishop still
goes to F6 because if you have to put G7
only legal move you take it you make a
draw in the end game so Parham really
showing brilliant defense uh in this one
Rook back to d8 there's just no progress
the bishop on F6 is way too powerful
Rook d8 played and ding now less than a
minute on the clock comes back through
K7 Parham could uh simply fall back with
the Rook to D6 and that would be a
repetition of the position that we just
had
and I think ding doesn't mind a few
repetitions if he is trying to play for
win gain a little bit time of the clock
but I just don't believe there's
anything at this point that uh he's
looking for because he knows that
Paramus proved that defensive posture
broke back to D6 wrote back to dative
suffering check and so uh there's
nothing really to worry about if you are
Palmer you're playing this superbly
just excellent stuff from from Parham
seriously I think that he deserves a lot
of credit because after yesterday's game
Tanya I honestly thought that he might
be in trouble in this tournament he had
the white pieces he was worse after like
15 moves uh Vincent was pressing him but
he did find a good tactic but then I
thought well he found a tactic to escape
that was both creative clever but also
you know it was fortuitous now you're
here and like no this was defense over
dozens and dozens of moves he earned
this one for sure
100 it was resource from yesterday but
today has been on another level because
it's been a marathon defense a really
long play defense and in fact evening
out of the opening he went for for
dynamic play he made he tried to create
a mess in the position uh but in the end
then came on top in that end game and
has been putting pressure and looked
like was so close I remember you asked
me to predict and I felt that Ding was
going to take this one Barham here
proving me wrong with his uh super
impressive defense
I also thought ding Loren would win but
Parham had other ideas he may be new to
this tournament he may have only been
invited a few days ago but he's still
going to play amazing chess so what does
parm thinking about that's my big
question here he's probably looking if
he can force a draw he could repeat the
position with Rook D6 but maybe he's
looking at some other moves to say
there's nothing that white can do
especially because this king is on H6
and has no moves so there might be
nothing better than just sliding back
and forth
he could very well just keep the Rook on
the eighth Rank and as you're mentioning
that white has got nothing better to do
uh you can he goes he goes for the
repetition of the of the position with
the move Rook D6 I think that's what I
saw uh and we have that on the board and
makes a lot of sense Rook B7 so things
still declining an immediate draw he
says he still wants to fight it the
problem in this position is that White's
King on 86 is just stuck if there is no
improvement you're not coming out of
that the Bishop from F6 isn't going to
move uh Rook goes back to d8 let's say
you attack the bishop with a
ready to go Rook F7
and I'm just wondering after Rook F7 is
Rook a fade a possibility
but maybe you take and go King 87 and
things could get a bit nasty with H6
coming in no exactly so The Rook trade
is not available on that square it just
goes to show that when black got his
King to G8 that was the all-important
square to keep the white king out of H7
so the king needs to stay on G8 and he
goes Rook to d8 if Rook F7 he'll
probably bring his Rook right back to D6
because white is Frozen in place you
can't move your Jeep on for many reasons
you got checkmated but also your Rook
would be hanging so you gotta go back
that way and the Black Brook will go
back to d8 so
F5 I think changing the position a
little bit he decides to finally move
upon and he's gone for the move F5 not
being able to make any more progress
with his Rook he strike different
strategies different ways of uh
threatening the mate but of course
Parham with his big defense and now ding
tries F5 but it doesn't change anything
because that's the most
forward that your Pawn is going to go
you're not getting F6 in your king is
still trapped on 86 oh there's no G7
ever there's no H6 ever so you still uh
you know you're stuck after F5
you're definitely stuck here and if this
bishop can wrap around to a square like
D2 this diagonal it would be check made
that's not going to happen but something
to keep an eye out for because it could
happen in a bullet game so F5 was the
choice this Rook can come up to D5 to
attack this Pawn that looks quite nice
to me you can't take the pawn so if you
had a free turn you wouldn't take
because then you get checkmated back
here so Rook D5 kind of just passes the
turn back to ding
I think you can move the bishop away
from F6 because if the King goes to G5
you still have some checks but why do
that why do that when you've got this
position where white skiing is actually
trapped on 86 it's such a nice Fortress
such a nice blockade and even if it
works uh I still think just sliding
around with the Rook white has achieved
the maximum that he could there is no
more progress to be made you could go
Rook C or rookie The Rook D5 the move
that you're suggesting uh even if the
bishop moves are fine I wouldn't want to
allow King G5
agreed and actually if you just move
your Rook along the last rank there's no
progress that white can make so if you
go Rook to eight G7 is again meant by
this Rook A6 move and your king is in
trouble so you don't get checkmated
because
um your Kink can escape you'll be able
to push this up on at some moment but
it's very very closely check
here can't can't go but you have F6 and
after Rook takes F6 check you have King
G5 because the Rook is in The Bishop's
path and it looks like you can make a
discovery and win The Rook but the
bishop is under attack so you just don't
have all the time you need as black to
win this game but you still are the
better side of position you can then
play on uh that would be quite amusing
if Parham decided ah no draw I'm gonna
try to beat you now
yeah imagine if we ended up with a rook
and Bishop versus rook and king and game
and then parham's the one who's pushing
for another 50 moves uh be quite a
turnaround but I don't think the
position is going to get that far I do
not see ding blundering away his three
Pawns in this position F5 played and
Parham thinking I think he's gonna hold
on with this position he's gonna just
keep that Bishop on F6 move around with
the Rook you can see him on the screen
he's completely focused I I can just
imagine the level of tiredness the two
players must be feeling right now Robert
it's a way into the seventh hour of play
the you know it's it's against
competition that is so difficult every
move takes so much out of you and these
two players are still fine
they must be exhausted they must be
hungry
um they must be just wanting to do
anything in a way besides play this
specific game but you have to play until
the final move Parham is doing just that
I love the way he's played this game his
over-the-board technique has been
stellar and he's also taking his time at
specific moments where he realizes hey
slow down this is a draw you know this
is a draw you don't need to rush it and
blunder so he does bring his Rook back
up to D6 he recognizes that if the Rook
checks on B8 Israel goes right back to
d8 and it's now up to ding he's pushed
upon restarted the move counter 50 moves
without a peace capture or a pawn move
result in a draw so will ding play this
out forever or will he just allow the
draw to happen that's the big question
well he has been playing it out and as
our audience our viewers are pointing
that Ding is fighting indeed he is you
want to make the most of every single
chance that you've got in the position
it just looks like ding has maximized
his position Parham showing immense
defense has withstanding it and ding now
please to move seven
on the board
I thought he would know he moved his
Rook away to A7
because G7 was would be a bit of a
shocker there just to check and you win
the pawn on G7 that would not happen
Rook A7 again this just goes on to show
that it is difficult for black uh for
white to make any Improvement and now
once the guy can fall back with the Rook
back and forth Rook B8 Rook B6 that's
the plan that you want and there's
nothing that white can do about if you
ever put well you can definitely can't
push your Pawn to G7 with the Rook here
because you'll get immediately
checkmated uh but with the Rook back on
d8 as soon as you play G7 The Rook comes
right back to D6 and that's a problem
for this King on H6 so uh there's
nothing that dingly Wren can do and
Parham he knows that but he's making
sure triple checking he's verifying and
he is going to hold this half point and
dignity probably will be a bit
disappointed just because he had the
white pieces he started off with a bang
and game one and he likely wanted to
continue that in game two and he had
some chances so
um
not the best day not the worst day of
course for ding but not the best day
either
looking at Barham I think he's so
confident about this position I won't be
surprised if he's already thinking what
he wants to order for dinner what does
he want to have because it's it's very
simple like you're pointing out just
keep moving the rock no danger at all
the King on 86 is stuck white truck
alone can't do anything
it's it's hard to imagine anything here
well what are you gonna have for dinner
it's actually past it's past midnight in
India it's uh past um uh way past
midnight it's almost 1am here so yeah
I'm also dreaming about dinner after
this yeah
I'm I'm very hungry and I think that
with the shuffling that's taking place
here uh dingley Wren you know he's just
holding on to whatever faint hope he has
that he can score a second straight win
but you know Parham is going to make
this draw if he doesn't make this draw
something has gone terribly wrong his
wires got crossed something is a problem
but you know it's clear he has his
defensive setup there's nothing that
white can do to avoid it because the
king is stuck on H6 and not getting out
Farm looks tired I don't know if you saw
that little shot of him he he does have
his hand on his head and I think you
know you know you're so close but your
opponent isn't giving up your opponent
keeps fighting keeps playing on it is
frustrating but Parham knows he's so
close to it he just needs to be accurate
for a couple more moves uh and this is
really a big moment for the 22 year old
to be able to hold his own against the
world number two
for sure and speaking of number two well
Anish giri has been second place in this
event five different times will this be
the first time he wins that remains to
be seen but we saw a very happy in his
Fury we spoke to Fiona earlier
finally how highly does this game rank
on your list of favorite games played
here in vacancy well I mean I've played
many many uh satisfying games and I can
say also many bad games I just played
many games like I say so
um yeah no it's it's a great uh great
feeling to win this way and I'm also
always proud to show some preparation uh
even though now in Rapid and Bliss it's
less of a thing but still you know I'm
always happy to get preparation
especially when it works out it looks
pretty nice and I think it was a very
nice idea I was very happy with it with
this Rook C2 idea it's a very cunning
one and it's really not on the surface
and I was really happy to you know not
only to show it but also that it led to
a nice picture
and there you had it happy Indie secure
he won his game today he moves to one
half points out of the two rounds that
he has played and we just saw dingley
Wren the final game of the round Rook A6
played attacking the bishop this
actually is an important choice because
if you carelessly move your Bishop
somewhere maybe the pawns start going up
the board if you play say Bishop to B2
is there F6 that's the big question can
I push that pawn uh the answer here is
no because if you play F6 your King on
H6 gets checkmated immediately so be
very careful I warned you all earlier
the King on H6 is vulnerable so do not
do not do not Overlook a check on this
diagonal
it was really interesting to hear
anisha's thoughts about about his game
and his General play in waikikante he's
played it so many times he's been the
ambassador of the tournament for several
years uh it is his favorite event and it
was nice to see him proud of the way his
game went today and understandably so
you know you this idea that we were
talking about as well with Rick C2 he
pointed it out and then went on to win
flawlessly so that was definitely a
really nice game I think apart from that
win uh if if Parham manages to save this
game save that half a point I would say
that this has been the second most
impressive game of the day
it has really really good defense you
know what it reminds me of uh Lavon
aronian yesterday against Magnus Carlson
that game ends in a draw if you just
look at the results you say oh what
really happened uh nothing just put the
point they've done that many times
before but it was painstaking effort to
make that draw and Parham he continues
to wait this out making sure he's not
gonna blunder and as you said he's tired
he's hungry uh he would like nothing
more than the game to be concluded but
when you're in that state when you know
that you're not thinking as clearly as
you did six hours ago that's when
mistakes happen so he is taking that
step back that breather so that he can
really analyze fresh every time because
in this position is he gonna play Bishop
E5 Bishop D4 Bishop C3 Bishop B2 is
there a difference so you're making any
of those moves should he leave his
Bishop where it is and play the move
rook f8 and just defend I like Rook f8
but then you may think after Rook C6 is
there some kind of funny uh situation
where you can't move your Rook because
you lose your bishop and if you move
your Bishop maybe the king gets out
there's just a lot of little things that
go into this position that Parham is
working out
and these little things can make your
brain so foggy it's so easy to lose hold
on reality you know these small small
positions with these tiny differences
you've played them over and over again
over the last 20 30 moves but you lose
the sense of reality when they keep
appearing your mind gets tired it is the
seventh hour of play uh you're already
low on energy so one can imagine uh it's
happened to all of us Robert you're
holding on you're holding on you're
holding on but at the very end you just
crumble because you know you just
make that one inaccurate move and it all
falls apart all the effort falls apart
and ding with Rook A6 has asked another
question because parham's Bishop has
been on F6 for a long time
psychologically he loves it there it
blocks the King on H6 it makes sure that
the King on 86 cannot come out to uh to
G5 anymore so it's very hard for him to
move that Bishop away from there even if
it might be a good move uh and as we can
see he has decided to keep it there just
simply because you don't wanna you don't
want to fix what's not broken Why move
that Bishop he's gone rook f8 and Dink
continues to question Parham exactly the
way you said he keeps The Rook on C6
attacking that Bishop now you don't have
a good Square for The Rook are you going
to go King etch it or will you move your
Bishop away and once again it's not a
pleasant choice of our home because he
really wants that Bishop there
well King is a move I didn't think about
and I'm gonna make the move and see what
happens keeps the status quo completely
wow that's hard to believe though right
the king h8 also works so if that's the
case then maybe it's good to make that
move you can also play the bishop on
this diagonal like Bishop H4 because you
can't play F6 I can just take it if you
play G7 I have Rook F6 check and then
once the Rooks are swapped you lose the
pawn on G7 so it seems like there are a
bunch of different drawing plans for a
Parham he just needs to choose one he
played his Bishop back to d8 keeping
this diagonal under his control
uh Bishop Diego and you know we speak we
keep talking about classical chess and
this game has been such a massive
example of the beauty of classical chess
and the kind of fight that it requires
the stamina it brings out it's not about
blunders it's not about sacrifices it's
about holding on and showing these
defensive resources uh and Robert we've
got over 20 000 people with us on Twitch
uh over 8 000 people on YouTube so a big
shout out to everyone who's joining us
on Twitch and on YouTube uh on this big
rather steal Chess Masters what a day
it's been and what a fight these
world-class players are putting out for
us
they are indeed and the fight is nearing
its conclusion Brook E6 played can
you take this Pawn F5 that's a big
question but the answer is no so look at
dingley Ren being a little trickster
over there Rook takes a five rookie a
check that's mate so you have to block
with the Rook takes takes and King H7
trying to promote the pawn if your
Bishop goes to F6 to stop G7 I go H6
next is G7 it is Unstoppable the pawn
reaches the other side and white would
win so instead of that the bishop goes
back to F6 nice try dingley Ren you're
not going to fool me says Parham and he
keeps the bishop back and forth back and
forth that with a draw has been agreed
Robert saying that Parham did not fall
for that final trick he's put up such a
mammoth defense in this one played like
a true Gladiator a true fighter a
difficult game ends in a draw a big
shout out to both these players dingler
and giving it his all really trying till
the absolute last breath in the position
to squeeze that winard and Parham up to
the task eventually ding agrees and
acknowledges the massive defensive
effort nothing to be done a draw is
agreed yeah and good point by you and
look at them all of a sudden they have
energy because they want to talk about
every little detail of the previous 80
moves of Chess that they played and
that's what happens they're so
fascinating they're so enthralled by the
game that they want to talk about what
happened on move 20. I don't remember
what happened on move 20 in this game
it's been forever ago but they went
through it they experience it every
single move had some kind of emotional
attachment and you try to put aside your
emotions while you're playing because
you need to remain objective but you you
squirm you go through it all and when it
is all said and done the game is a draw
they're analyzed they're not even going
to eat dinner yet they want to talk
about the position but Tanya the draw
was agreed which means we have all seven
results in the books only two games I
say only as if that's not a lot at this
level two decisive games is uh quite a
lot and Magnus Carlson wins the black
Anish Geary wins with white I think both
those two they're long time uh you know
kind of banterers on social media
they'll be happy with today's results
this is exactly the narrative that we
saw in round one and it repeats in round
two this time one with the white pieces
uh Anish winning in a tactile while
Magnus showing great positional sense
and technique a positional sacrifice
then going on to convert a nice trip but
really what's the dot was uh Parham
maksudlu all of 22 years old playing for
the first time in the Tata steel Masters
against one of the best players in the
world put under pressure from the very
beginning but takes it head on and
survives a huge scare a big Half Point
and if it weren't for Parham I think
we'll be talking as well about Arjun
eragisi with the black pieces two games
in a row uh he has performed admirably
solid defense never being much worse
showing off that good preparation and
form once you leave that prep so Arjun
with the black piece against Wesley so
that was impressive Levon aronian and
pragnanda not too much happened uh some
interesting moments but the game was
leveled throughout maybe prognananda you
know with his adventurous Queen D3 there
could have been something there but
nonetheless it draws a good result
Magnus we've discussed this game had
just finished Parham is a hero Anish
giri is a villain he just absolutely
crushed gookash and the many gukesh fans
out there are gonna look at the
standings right now and be pretty upset
because he came into this event at 27-25
he had his chances uh but he is now down
to oh out of two the only player who
hasn't drawn a single game
he has to remember that this is just the
start of the tournament it is such a
long way ahead you still got
what I mean 11 rounds do we played
that's an entire event to be played
right now so not to lose heart it's been
a difficult start uh but on the other
hand at the top of the leaderboard we've
got four players with one and a half
points Magnus Anish Ding and nodded back
lead the field wabiano Wesley level
Arjun Parham Jordan frog all at one
point and we've got Richard and Winston
with half a point while at the bottom of
the leaderboard and I remember last year
at the Masters it was a really tough
start was finding it difficult to score
he told me later on that he knew that he
just needed that one win to turn things
around it happened he came right back
right there playing in the challenges
and I have no doubt that this is the
advice that he will be giving to the
gukesh in the Tata steel Masters to just
hang in there all he needs is that one
day to turn things around well tomorrow
is a new day but tomorrow he gets the
white pieces against no dierberg Abdus
atarov who is in great form in this
event thus far so gukesh the only player
at zero points he is a tough matchup
tomorrow all the matchups are tough but
the matchups are worth circling and this
is obvious is Magnus Carlsen with the
white pieces against dingley Ren with
the black pieces they're co-leaders but
it's also a world championship matchup
that could have been that maybe would
have been had dingley Wren scored first
place in the candidates because Magnus
Carlson well he wasn't interested in
playing John The Palms again and okay
it's been said that he wouldn't have
played ding but that would have been a
legitimate challenge at least one that
he sees as such because
the only two players above 2800 are
those two Magnus and ding that is a
circle circle match world number one
against world number two the only two
2800s facing each other off but we've
got juicy matchups all around we've got
uh pragnananda and Winston two of the
most upcoming well not upcoming it's
kind of hard to call them that but two
prodigies one from India one from
Germany who've really been making their
Mark in Elite chess over the last year
will be facing each other off and we
also have Arjun versus Levon and Robert
that is always a fun matchup uh Arjun
has always been a very difficult
opponent for Lavon he's had a tough
score against him they both enjoy
playing against each other who can
forget the big fight from the Olympiad
between gukesh and not a back so a bit
of a grudge match one as well we've got
Richard against Wesley a massive Clash
of styles there
yes that is as different uh players as
you could possibly ask for Wesley so
calm coolant collected just wants to
play solid chess make a draw with the
black pieces Richard put his King on D1
the last time he had the white pieces
against Abdul satar of and uh five in a
carwana with the white pieces against
Jordan Von Forest two very well prepared
players two players who have won this
event before and in this particular
event I feel like both of them have been
a bit Rocky now in the two games that
Jordan has played he said the white
pieces and he's at the disadvantage in
both Fabi had white in game one against
Anish uh he never really got anything he
never got anything off the ground
whatsoever in game two against noribbeck
he was worse but he held steady so not
the best start for either player not
from the score card but from the play
that they have shown and Fabiano with
white you know he's looking at that
matchup as one that if he expects to win
this tournament he needs to take down
Jordan when he has the first move
advantage
big day of just coming Robert and such
juicy matchups it's going to be a lot of
fun and uh there on our screen we can
see the players Rising uh they don't
care about it right now they've had such
such a fun game such an ended fun game
uh they just can't get enough of Chess
and that's kind of heartwarming to see
that after the seven hours of play they
still want to take a look at what could
have happened
I love it they're feasting on the
analysis I'm sure they want to get on
over to the restaurant but they want to
discuss dissect digest this position and
I think a lot of you at home you know
it's a good one to study because one
little mistake and then it could have
gone from a draw to a loss for
paramaksudu he showed excellent
technique and while it is the finality
of this round it's round two in the
books round three is tomorrow same time
same place you will not want to miss it
5 a.m Pacific time is the start uh 2 p.m
essential European time so we are going
to say goodbye for now I'm gonna get
some food and we'll see you right early
tomorrow for more from Vikings
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]